Das Problem ist, wie kleine Zivilisationen oder kleine Städte, die sich separat entwickeln, und keine Art, die anderen Gruppen zu lernen, zu teilen, was sie lernen.
Ihr hört CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zur 191. Ausgabe dieser Sendereihe. Und heute geht's mal wieder um Technik. Und zwar wagen wir hier ein ein Blick in die Vergangenheit und ein bisschen auch, hoffe ich, in die Zukunft. Auf jeden Fall wollen wir die Gegenwart nochmal kräftig auseinandernehmen und alles dreht sich irgendwie um Internetversorgung mit einem Schwerpunkt hier auf die Situation in Deutschland, vielleicht auch weltweit und so im Festnetz, wie man da quasi die Abhängigen mit den Daten versorgt. Und dazu habe ich mir einen alten Haudegen hier ins Haus geholt, nämlich Clemens. Clemens Schrimpe, hallo. Du bist ja Veteran.
Ja, bin ein IT-Oper.
Ja, bist du, ne? Wann hast du denn, gehen wir noch mal weiter zurück, wie bist du denn in den Zaubertrank-Topf gefallen, so mit den Computern eigentlich? Kenn ich gar nicht die Story.
Na ja, Computer, ich bin schon vorher in den Trank gefallen. Also mich hat schon Telefonnetze, haben mich schon fasziniert. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich irgendwie schon als noch mit einstelliger Jahreszahl auf dem Buckel schon angefangen habe, am analogen Telefonanschluss meiner Eltern rumzubasteln. Höchst illegal damals noch. Aber habe auch Telefone gesammelt. Mich hat es immer fasziniert. Kommunikation über Ferne hinweg. Je weiter, je komplexer, desto besser hat mich immer sehr fasziniert. Und ich glaube, über diese ganze Schiene, über dieses Kommunizieren bin ich überhaupt an die ganze Computersache auch drangekommen. Also was mich auch immer auf der ganzen Computersache interessiert hat, war der Teil, wo Mensch mit Maschine redet über eine Entfernung oder zwei Maschinen miteinander reden über Entfernung. Und da eigentlich alles, was geht, da bin ich drangekommen, hab dann irgendwann angefangen, als Schüler Akustikkoppler selber zu löten und damit rumzubasteln und das hat man dann halt eben weitergetrieben.
Wo befinden wir uns jetzt gerade so in einem Zeitstrahlen?
Lass mal überlegen, das müsste schon irgendwie Late 70s sein. So 77, 78, 79.
Hast du an der Akustikkoppler rumgelötet?
Ja, 300 Bit pro Sekunde. Und dann die Offenbarung, als dann irgendwie, das war aber schon wesentlich, war dann schon in den 80ern, als die Telekom mit BTX, hieß ja nicht Telekom, als die Bundespost dann mit BTX am Start war, 1275, 1200 Boote in die Einrichtung, 75 Boote in die andere. Das war irgendwie, das war der Brenner. Man muss einfach vorstellen, wenn du vor je jahrelang 300 Bit pro Sekunde, das kann sich heute glaube ich keiner mehr vorstellen, 300 Bit pro Sekunde.
Da kann man auch mitlesen.
Da kannst du wirklich mitlesen, sind 30 Zeichen pro Sekunde. Und dann plötzlich 1200, waren 120 Zeichen pro Sekunde. Da konnte man dann so einen Bildschirm, mit so seinen 1000, 2000 Zeichen, konnte man dann so in 20 Sekunden mal vollmalen. Naja, das hat sich auch relativ lange gehalten. Also es war ja auch, denke ich, gerade in Deutschland durch diese Monopolstellung der Bundespost und ihrem doch sehr, wie soll man mal, anfänglich sehr schlechten Verhältnis zu Datendiensten, war man natürlich darauf angewiesen, das Telefonnetz dafür zu benutzen. Und man hat dann halt eben auch gebastelt. Man hat dann irgendwann selber angefangen, Modems zu importieren aus den USA, weil das so etwas in Deutschland nicht zugelassen gab. Dann die ersten V32-Modems mit 9600 Bit pro Sekunde, bis halt eben dann, was sozusagen das Ende der Modem-Ära eingeläutet hat, die V34-Biss-Dinger oder so, mit 57 Kilobit. Aber damit hat man sich sehr lange aufhalten müssen am Zeitstrahlen. Danach ging es dann, sollen wir mal schon, zwar auch in holprigen Schritten, aber dann ging es dann doch deutlich schneller. Dann kam irgendwann ISDN, die Offenbarung, 64 Kilobit.
Nicht so schnell hier mit den Pferden. Also, BTX hast du jetzt gesagt, wann war nochmal der offizielle Start von BTX?
BTX muss erfunden haben, sind glaube ich 1979 und so richtig am Start gekommen ist, 1981 oder so was?
Wurde in Österreich im Juni 82 eingeführt, in Deutschland September 83. Also, es wird ja immer gerne so gelächelt, wenn immer einer BTX sagt, dann lächeln immer alle so, ha ha ha. Aber ich fand Bildschirmtext in gewisser Hinsicht schon recht visionär, weil wenn man sich mal überlegt, wie heutzutage die meisten Leute so mit dem Internet umgehen, die haben da so ein Webbrowser und ab und so geben sie auch mal was ein, aber eigentlich klicken sie die ganze Zeit nur auf irgendwelche Hyperlinks und dann kommen so Bilder.
Ja, das ist schon.
Mit Porno und mit Bank.
Gab es damals auch Pixel-Porno, das war echt der Knaller.
Ja, ich meine genau das hat Bildschirmtext eigentlich auch gebracht. Von daher war es eine coole Idee, nur dass sie halt den Fehlern gemacht haben, die Leute dafür bezahlen zu lassen, diese Geräte zu kaufen, während sie ja in Frankreich, die deutlich Minitel-Dinge waren. Ich weiß nicht, das war glaube ich sogar kostenlos die Bereitstellung.
Die Geräte haben sie deswegen in Frankreich, kann mich noch erinnern, haben sie es so gemacht, da konntest du dein Abonnement für dein Telefonbuch kündigen, dafür hast du ein Minitel gekriegt. Das heißt, wenn du darauf verzichtet hast, dein gedrucktes Telefonbuch zu bekommen, dann hast du dafür ein Minitel gekriegt, weil die Funktionalität war drist. Und da war natürlich dann auch mehr drin. Da waren dann eben auch so wie bei BTX eben auch zusätzliche Dienste dann drin. Und Pixel-Porno. Und die Pixel-Porno. Ich meine, das musst du dir überlegen. In BTX gab es ja damals eigentlich keine Grafik in dem Sinne. Die Grafik haben sie dadurch gemacht, dass man konnte in so ein BTX-Formul ein Zeichensatz reinladen. Also ein Font. Man konnte ein Font reinladen. Das heißt, die haben dann ein Bild, was sie darstellen wollten, umgerechnet in die Pixel und haben daraus sozusagen einen neuen Font generiert und dann aus diesen Pseudobuchstaben dann eine Grafik generiert.
Jaja.
Es war schon ein bisschen abenteuerlich damals.
Aber hat eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert. War halt nicht so besonders sicher, wie er dann der CCC demonstriert hat. Das hat ja damals eigentlich noch keinen so richtig interessiert. Aber ich wollte jetzt nicht die alten Kamellen wieder aufwerben, sondern man muss sich einfach nur mal klarmachen, Anfang der 80er-Jahre war die Realität eine Modem-Realität und natürlich gab es kein Internet, weil es gab zwar diese Technologie, die war in dem Moment schon herbeigerufen, existierte aber eigentlich nur auf wenigen ausgewählten Computern in amerikanischen Universitätsnetzen und ganz, ganz, ganz wenigen anderen Computern an irgendwelchen Unis in Europa. Und es sollte dann eben noch sehr lange dauern. Aber natürlich war unsere Fragestellung, ist natürlich jetzt hier mal so einen Blick zu werfen auf die Technologien, die einem, ja in dem Fall, wie heißt es so schön, DFÜ-Dienste bereitgestellt haben.
Für die jüngeren Zuhörer, Datenferneübertragung.
Auch ohne Internet gab es ja schon diesen Bedarf, vor allem im Businessbereich, bei Banken etc. In der Großindustrie wurde das...
Auch bei Privatleuten. Ich meine, es gab ja damals auch eine sehr reiche Mailbox-Szene. Die existierte ja parallel zu diesen BTX, wo also so Geschichten wie Chat oder eben, wo man anfing, mit anderen Leuten, mit fremden Leuten, elektronisch zu kommunizieren, auch der Privatmann. Mit Nachrichten hinterlassen, alles proprietär. Ich weiß noch diese Fido-Netze, ich weiß nicht, ob du das noch was sagst. Das ist so ein Mailbox-Verbund, die sich dann gegenseitig mit Modems angerufen haben oder die ersten UACP-Netze, wo man dann sozusagen mit Unix-Varianten schon vorläuft, dasselbe Mail, was wir jetzt auch heute benutzen, RFC822-Mail, damals halt eben auch schon mit Modems hin und her geschubst hat mit UACP.
Gibt es noch mal die Gelegenheit, mal wieder einen schönen Querverweis hier auf eine alte Folge zu werfen, in dem Zusammenhang mit unserem gemeinsamen Freund Hans Hübner, Ausgabe 100, das Internet und die Hacker, wo wir auch sehr in diese Zeit reinschauen und so Hackerfahrschule zerren, etc., also wie man so unterwegs gewesen ist in den frühen Netzen, bevor es halt auch so richtig Internet war und dann später natürlich auch mit Internet. Das eine oder andere mögen wir hier nochmal wiederholen, aber dann gab es ja eigentlich auch so eine, also Modem war ja im Prinzip so ein bisschen so diese dynamische Wackel-Technologie, man steckt dann so seinen Hörer in so eine Klo-Mufe rein und dann überträgt man die Daten, wenn man sowas noch hatte.
Mein selbst gebaute Akustik-Koppler waren diese kleinen, diese kleinen 8 Ohm-Lautsprecher, die man so kaufen konnte beim Elektronikhandel, die man dann mit einem Einmachgummi auf das Telefon drauf geschnallt hat. Ja, ging auch.
Ging auch. Man durfte halt nicht so viel husten. Aber wann ging es denn mit dem X25 los? Also es gab ja von der CCITT so diverse Übertragungsstandards und mit X25 dann eigentlich auch das erste, war das so, das erste wirklich paketvermittelte Netz, denke ich schon, ne?
Na, sagen wir mal so, es war das erste Netz, das so eine Paketvermittlung benutzt hat, die für eine breitere Schicht, sagen wir mal, zugänglich war. Die, die mit dieser Technik grundsätzlich mal angefangen haben, war IBM mit dem SNR-Netz oder mit der SNR-Technologie, die natürlich nur industriell genutzt wurde. Da gab es überhaupt gar keinen Bezug dazu, das auch nur ansatzweise privat zu nutzen. Das gab auch nie ein öffentliches SNR-Netz oder so. Er liest diese Technologie auch gar nicht zu. Aber die haben sozusagen dieselben Grundlagen gelegt auf der Übermittlungsschicht. Genauer genommen ist es das SDLC, was die benutzt haben, und es ist dem HDLC, was dann danach kam, sehr nahe. Oder wird auf dem X25 basiert. Vielleicht sollte man noch mal sagen, X25, das ist das, was hier in Deutschland unter dem Namen Datex P vermarktet wurde. Die hieß es in anderen Ländern auch anders, in Kanada Telepak, und ich weiß noch, in Frankreich, in der Schweiz hieß es Transpak. Die Technologie dahinter ist X25. Das X.25-Netz, auch international, war übrigens auch ein Novum, dass es sozusagen auch eine Zusammenschaltung dieser Netze gab. Das erlaubte halt eben paketorientierte Kommunikation zwischen zwei Endpunkten und das eben auch das Schöne daran, eben man konnte es wählen. Man hatte sozusagen ein, je nachdem, was man für einen Anschluss hat, es gab verschiedene Datix-P-Anschlüsse, die man fest haben konnte, da konnte es ja von der Bundespost einlegen lassen, die waren relativ teuer, aber ging. Gab halt die Asynchronen, die Datix-P-20-Anschlüsse, Datix-P-20-H, wie Hauptanschluss. Und dann gab es die in richtig Paketvermittelnden Datix-P-10-H, wo man mehrere Kanäle gleichzeitig hatte, wo man verschiedene Verbindungen in alle Welt aufbauen konnte, parallel auf- und abbauen konnte. Und das war sozusagen der Durchbruch, denke ich, für viele Dienste auch, sich mal auch international da breit zu machen. Ich will nur mal ein Beispiel nennen.
Was musste man denn ins Haus gelegt bekommen, um überhaupt X25 machen zu können?
Na ja, es gab zwei aller Sachen. Es gab eine Anwalttechnik, ich glaube, das war der DATX P20F hieß der, glaube ich. Den konnte man anrufen. Der hatte so eine 019-irgendwas-Nummer. Da konnte man dich mit Modem drauf einwählen. Dann konnte man DATX-P-Rufnummern dann elektronisch schon ab diesem Zeitpunkt anwählen mit einem Terminal-Programm, wo die so ein glases Reverse-Charging zuließen, wo sozusagen die Verbindungskosten der Empfänger oder der Angerufene übernimmt, was auch ein Novum war in Deutschland. Bevorher gab es ja nicht mal R-Gespräche in Deutschland im Telefonnetz. Man konnte also eine Daten- oder überhaupt Verbindung aufbauen und der Angerufene zahlt. Das war auch schon mal ganz interessant. Oder man holte sich eine sogenannte NUI, weißte ich noch. Da konnte man dann damals beantragen, richtig mit einem schönen Formular mit Blaupapier drin und Durchschlag und so. Da konnte man eine NUI beantragen.
Also Network User Identification.
Genau, das war sozusagen die erste Netzzugangskennung, die man so als Normalbürger erwerben konnte. Die war sogar recht erschwindlich. Ich weiß gar nicht, 10 oder 15 Mark im Monat hat die gekostet. Das war so ein Abrechnungsmechanismus. Damit konnte man sich mit einem Modem und einem Terminal-Programm in diesen Datix P20F einen Wahlpunkt einwählen, der eine bundeseinheitliche Rufnummer hatte. Mit einem Terminal-Programm hat man dann seine NUI eingegeben, hat gesagt, hier erkenne dich, hier dein Passwort. Dann konnte man sich über das Datix P-Netz, über das X.25-Netz weiter verbinden lassen. Da gab es dann schon ein paar weltweite Sachen. Ich weiß, dass z.B. CompuSurf damals Nummern angeboten hat, wo man sich drauf connecten konnte. Und wo es Informationsdienste gab. Alles schön ASCII, keine Grafik, kein Nix, kein Klicken, keine Maus. Schön mit Text eingeben und so. Also nicht mal so bunt wie BTX, aber schön textbasiert, aber dafür eben weltweit. Ich kann mich erinnern, Washington Post war z.B. auch eins meiner interessanten Ziele, da konnte man hinconnecten, relativ günstig sogar. Und da mal relativ aktuelle News lesen, realtime. Die hatten Nachrichtenticker für jedermann, den man dort über Datix P X25 zugreifen konnte. Wenn man jetzt einen Datix P Anschluss haben wollte, den braucht es ja hauptsächlich, wenn du gerne Anrufe entgegennehmen wolltest. Also wenn du selber Dienste anbieten wolltest. Dann gab es halt eben diese Datix P X H Anschlüsse, die gab es...
Also H stand glaube ich für Hauptanschluss.
Genau, Hauptanschluss. Und die gab es dann in den wahnsinnigen Geschwindigkeiten, ich glaube 1200, 2400, 4800, 9600 Bits pro Sekunde und später, sehr viel später auch 64 Kilobit, sagenhafte 64 Kilobit.
Was für damalige Verhältnisse, also wir reden jetzt so von Mitte der 80er Jahre, Mitte, Ende.
Ja, das war voll, der 64 Kilobit war unvorstellbar.
Ja, aber schon die 9.6 war ja jetzt auch mehr, als man so mit Modem...
Auch die 9.6, die Telekom musste dafür, oder ich sag mal Telekom, die Bundespost musste dafür auch ganz schön basteln. Also sie haben dann ein schönes Netzanschaltgerät, so hießen damals diese Modems, die da hingestellt, was sie dann teilweise auch eben nicht nur mit zwei Drähten, sondern mit vier Drähten angebunden hatten, oder zu einem Multiplexer an der Vermittlungsstelle und so weiter und so fort. Also das war alles nicht so locker und war auch dementsprechend teuer. Ich weiß noch, so ein Ding hat so einen neuen Sechser, Datix P10H, hat glaube ich 250 Mark im Monat gekostet. Ich weiß es jetzt nicht mehr, aber so in dem Dreh. Also für Privatmann eigentlich nicht so das Ding.
Nicht so, was sich der Schüler noch so leistet.
Aber das Interessante war, du konntest halt eben, du konntest mehrere Kanäle drauf haben. Ich weiß nicht, man konnte glaube ich damals beantragen, bis zu 256 Kanäle. Das heißt, du konntest mit 256 Leuten gleichzeitig oder 255 Partnern live parallel kommunizieren. Das ist schon Paket basiert drunter. Aber das Interessante da wieder auch, muss man auch sagen, kommen wir wieder bei ganzen Telekom-Geschichten raus oder überhaupt Telekommunikationsindustrie-Geschichte. Sie haben den Paketunterbau wieder was übergestülpt oben, einen Mechanismus, der so eine Verbindung erlaubt. Weil Verbindungen sind immer wichtig, weil die kann man nämlich abrechnen. Eine Verbindung hat ein Beginn und ein Ende. Das heißt, man kann schön Zeit-Tarefe drauf definieren. Oder eine Verbindung hat halt, im schlimmsten Fall, werden eben auch die Bits gezählt, die da durchlaufen. Aber man hat sozusagen eben ein Beginn und ein Ende. Das war halt eben für Abrechnungszwecke sehr wichtig. Deswegen wurden im Datex-P-Netz ja eben auch Verbindungen gewählt. Virtuelle Verbindungen, genauso wie heute, wenn du deinen Browser aufmachst und gehst auf eine Webseite, macht er ja eine virtuelle Verbindung auf, nämlich eine TCP-Verbindung, auf der er dann sein HTTP-Request absetzt. So war das eben damals auch. Und die haben das eben künstlich sozusagen wieder gemacht, um Wählprozeduren definieren zu können und das abrechnen zu können. Obwohl eben drunter Pakete waren.
Das ist ganz interessant, weil das ist wirklich in jeder Hinsicht ein interessanter Vorläufer des Internets, weil das Netz selber die Daten paketvermittelt gemacht hat und damit natürlich eine ganz andere Effizienz hätte, als wenn sie jetzt diese Verbindungen tatsächlich hergestellt hätten, wie es ja im Telefonnetz damals noch gang und gäbe war. Wies das nicht irgendwie PVC, so Permanent Virtual Circuits?
Die gewählten waren SVCs. Man konnte auch PVCs beantragen. Das waren auch Verbindungen, aber welche, die dauerhaft da waren.
Ach, die Permanent Virtual Circuits und das andere waren die?
Die PVCs, die waren immer da. Also wenn du zwei Data-XP-Anschlüsse hattest, konntest du bei der Bundespost nochmal ein Geld hinterlassen im Monat, X, für einen PVC, und dann hat es eine bestimmte Kanal-Nummer, war dann vergeben, meinetwegen Kanal Nummer 1. Und alles, was du in den Kanal Nummer 1 reingesteckt hast, musstest du nicht wählen, die Gegenstelle, sondern das kam halt drüben auf Kanal 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, wieder auf der anderen Seite wieder raus.
Und das war dann eigentlich die Flatrate? Oder wurde man dann noch nach Trafik tarifiert?
Ich glaube, die haben keinen Trafik. Nee, nee, die haben nur noch Zeit gemacht. Die haben nur noch Zeit gemacht. Ich meine, du warst jetzt eh irgendwie begrenzt durch die Wandbreite, deines Anschlusses, da die Welt auch nicht so besonders hoch. Aber immerhin hatte man damit einen relativ entfernungsunabhängigen Tarif. Ich glaube, es gab eigentlich abgesehen von Auslandsgesprächen oder Auslandgesprächen, Auslandsverbindungen, gab es eigentlich keine Tarifunterschiede, ob ein Berliner jemand anders in Berlin angewählt hat oder irgendwie nach München eine Verbindung runter hatte. Das heißt, mit so einem Datix-PVC war man entfernungsunabhängig. Er war trotzdem noch relativ teuer, d.h. die Leute, die bloß einmal über die Straße was schicken wollten, haben sich trotzdem geärgert. Aber die Leute, die jetzt mal ein bisschen Daten durch die halbe Öffentlichkeit schicken wollten, die hatten natürlich dann günstig.
Ja, und zumal eben die einzige Alternative wäre das Telefonnetz gewesen. Und das war ja noch die Zeit, wo Orts- und Ferngespräche noch signifikante Unterschiede hatten, besonders in Berlin, aber auch an sich. War es preislich?
Ich meine, in Berlin hatten wir ja noch, Anfang der 90er hatten wir ja noch den berühmten Tarif, den du neulich schon mal erwähnt hast, irgendwo dieses, wo Wao sagte, der Nachteil an diesem Ortstarif in Berlin war, dass man im Monat immer 19 Einheiten verschwendet. Man hat halt bloß einmal angerufen für eine Einheit und es gab halt 20 Freieinheiten und das Ding stand halt nicht. Wir haben das auch gemacht. Ich hab in der Firma damals, wir hatten Datexp-Anschluss, weil wir auch Produkte gemacht haben dafür. Und dann sind wir umgezogen an einen neuen Standort und dadurch, dass das damals alles noch bundespostmodopol war, brauchte so eine Verlegung eines solchen Anschlusses halt so mal vier Monate oder so. Und das haben wir halt dadurch überbrückt, dass wir halt zwei analoge Telefonanschlüsse genommen haben, zwei Modems dazwischen, die auf Synchron gestellt haben, weil ganze X25 wird Synchron übertragen, nicht Asynchron. Und dann die Modems in so einen Autodial-Modus versetzt haben. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man sozusagen das Endgerät an Knipsa dran hat, wurde dann automatisch die andere Seite angewählt. Und dann haben wir damit sozusagen den DATXP-Anschluss, den wir damals hatten, bzw. war sogar ein WIN-Anschluss, ein Wissenschaftsnetz-Anschluss, der aber dieselbe Technik hatte wie DATXP, haben wir den an den neuen Standort verlegt. Das ging damals noch, wie dieser Berliner Flatrate. Aber danach kamen wir ja dann in dieses bundesdeutsche Schema hier mit diesen Ortsverbindungen, Nahverbindungen, Regio 50, Regio 200 und Fernverbindungen. Tarifierung übrigens abhängig von der Mondphase. Wieso? Übrigens auch im DATXP. Wir hatten in unserem DATXP-Produkt hatten wir ein Mechanismus, eine Accountingfunktion drin, die wir sozusagen für die einzelnen Verbindungen ausgerechnet hatten, was hat dich das jetzt gekostet? Und die hatte ein Algorithmus zur Berechnung der Mondphase drin. Ostermontag ist ein bundeseinheitlicher Feiertag und wann Ostermontag, das hängt vom Mond ab. Ostermontag wurde abgerechnet wie Sonntag.
Verstehe, ich habe es richtig ausgerechnet.
Klar, wenn schon dann richtig. Man hätte jetzt doch eine Tabelle für die nächsten 20 Jahre einhaken können, aber das wäre lame gewesen.
Damals wart ihr sehr engagiert in dem Bereich mit X25 und auch schon so frühes IP-Routing über solche Netze. Das war ja auch so der Zeitpunkt, wo wir uns kennengelernt haben. Übrigens bist du ja derjenige, der mir als erstes das Word-Word-Web gezeigt hat. Du standst irgendwann mal so vor mir und sagst, hier guck mal, und dann hat du auf einmal so die Mosaik-Brause vor der Nase und hier, guck mal, mit anklicken und hyperlinks und Bilder und ich dachte mir so, hm.
Ja, das kann sein. Ich hab damals diese, über einen unserer Datex-P-Anschlüsse, wir hatten nur einen 4.800er, hab ich damals, denke mal, als Mit einer der ersten das Internet nach Berlin geholt und zwar an dem Datex-P-Verbindung zur Uni Dortmund aufgebaut haben, wo ein paar Leute saßen, die auch heute noch in der Szene aktiv sind, zum Beispiel der rühmte Rüdiger Volk, der sozusagen, der, denk ich mal, der Telekom am Ende den Arsch gerettet hat, mit ihrem Einstieg in die ganze Internetgeschichte. Da kommen wir vielleicht noch drauf. Und auch Daniel Karrenberg, der auch sehr, sehr lange auch als Vorstand des REIB-Aktiv-Fans auch immer noch ist, also sozusagen für die europäische Internetszene sehr bedeutende Leute, die haben damals in Dortmund gebastelt. Die waren damals somit die ersten, die sich für diese ganze Internetgeschichte interessiert haben. Die hatten halt eben auch einen neuen 6er-Verbindung nach Amsterdam, von wo irgendwelche Bits tröpfelten aus den USA.
Ja genau, die Universität Dortmund war ja damals quasi der Ort, wo Deutschland ans Internet angeschlossen wurde, kann man sagen.
Ja, Dortmund und Karlsruhe. In Karlsruhe gab es auch noch den Arnold Nipper, der hat ja auch noch sich sehr bemüht da rum, aber Unidoo war eben ein sehr wichtiger Knoten, auch in den USP-Netzen und so. Es gab ja so eine Migration von dieser Mailbox-Szene, von der USP-Szene dahin und so. Und da war halt Unidoo eben auch ein sehr wichtiger Knoten und die haben sich auch, denke ich, mit als Erstes in Deutschland neben dem Arnold Nipper...
Gibt es da eigentlich einen besonderen Grund, warum das ausgerechnet da gestartet hing, dass jetzt nur an den Personen oder hat die Uni selbst irgendwas richtig gemacht damals?
Ich denke schon. Ich meine, da musst du mal gucken, da ist ja dann auch einer der ersten größeren ISPs daraus hervorgegangen, was ist das? Das ist ja auch ein Spin-Off von den Leuten, die da an der Uni Dortmund das betrieben haben. Später UUnet gekauft, dann weiß ich, keine Ahnung, das ist ja dann diese Ewige in der Blase 1.0. Also Ende der 90er und Anfang der 2000er, der ersten Web-Blaser, sind die alle gegenseitig gekauft. Es sind ja hier Leute durch Europa gezogen, ernsthaft, ich habe einen von denen gesehen, mit einem Koffer voll Geld. Die sind durch die Gegend gefahren, sind bei den ISPs aufgelaufen, bei den kleinen ISPs überall, haben ihren Koffer auf den Tisch gelegt, haben gesagt, wir wollen euch kaufen. Die haben nicht nur, das war dann eine Anzahlung, aber die haben gewusst, das sind hier die kleinen ISPs, die hier rumhüpfen. Das waren halt eben auch Leute, die aus der Hacker-Szene, aus der Geek-Szene, ich sag mal, in das Business aufgestiegen sind, die sozusagen ihr Hobby zum Beruf gemacht haben.
Und meistens halt auch noch beseelt von diesen Leuten überhaupt erstmal Zugang geben. Klar.
Da kommen wir auch noch drauf, dass wir hier noch alles angestellt haben, um hier mal ein paar Bits in der Stadt zu verteilen. Und da kamen wirklich Leute mit Investorengeld, die wirklich hier durch Europa gereist sind, quasi mit dem Koffervergelt. Kein Kommentar.
Wie hieß denn dein erstes Projekt nochmal?
Nee, NetMBX war eine Geschichte, da waren auch andere Leute mit beteiligt. Das war wirklich so ein Mailbox-Teil, was wir dann natürlich auch irgendwann aufgebohrt haben. Wir waren natürlich auch technologisch interessiert daran. Ursprünglich war NetMBX auch mal so eine Geek-Geschichte. Unsere Fantasie war mal so ein bisschen, was selber zu machen mit so Hacker-Technologie. Das ist May Create Temporary Network Mailboxes. Das heißt, es ist so ein Privilege. So ein Benutzer, die auf so einem System drauf hatten, diese Privilegien hatten alle irgendwelche Namen. Es gab TempMBX, TMPMBX, das waren die Temporary Mailboxes und NetMBX May Create Network Mailboxes. Das war sozusagen, dass du so eine Art Mini-Storage generieren durftest auf einer Decknet-Note, um da irgendwas abzulegen oder so. Da kommt es her.
TempMBX hieß ja auch so ein Rechner.
Wir hatten auch einen Rechner, der auch TempMBX hieß. Wir haben damals wirklich dann analoge Telefonanschlüsse gemietet, bis der Arzt kam. Wurde uns dran gehängt und da einen Wahl gemacht. Und natürlich mit Aufkommen von IP. Auch damit dann die ersten Sachen gemacht. Ich weiß noch die erste Geschichte, was wir damals noch hatten, war dann auch nach Dortmund. Eine 64 Kilowatt-Verbindung mit einer SFV-Festverbindung. Es gab in dem ersten ISDN-Netz, in dem nationalen ISDN-Netz, was die Bundespost ja noch aufgebaut hat, gab es noch diese permanenten Verbindungen, was wir vorhin schon mal erwähnt hatten, diese PVCs, gab es auch im ISDN. Da konnte man sich sozusagen eine Dauerwähl-Verbindung, der hat auch so einen schönen Abkürzer, ich komme gar nicht drauf.
Ich grübele auch die ganze Zeit schon.
Es war nicht afforded, war das Hardware-Ding. Im 1TR6-Netz, also im nationalen ISDN-Netz gab es sowas. Und da konnte man sich dann für ein paar Hundert Mark, konnte man sich dann so eine Leitung, eine dauerhaft aufgebaute ISDN-Verbindung schalten lassen. Und damit konnte man dann mal 64 Kilobit durch die Republik transportieren.
Und das war damals wirklich schnell?
Das war schnell. Wenn man jetzt damals, muss man überlegen, die Web-Browser kamen gerade erst auf. Gerade gab es auch wenig Content dafür. Was damals viel gab, war eben ein Mail und vor allen Dingen Newsnet. Gute alte News, was da drüber verbreitet wurde. Und die Leute kamen alle zu uns an mit Modems. Ein paar sehr wenige mit ISDN-Verbindungen, aber eben auch nur kurz, um dann ihre Mails abzuholen. Einen USP-Austausch zu machen zum Beispiel. Oder dann eben auch per USP transportiert die News, ihre News abzuholen, die abonnierten News. Und damit, also diesen ganzen Web-Content, wie wir ihn heute kennen, mit Browser, Bildchen, Flash, Blink, Video, Audio, Podcasts. Das gab es damals alles jahlich. Das ist erst alles später gekommen.
Ja, von daher gab es natürlich ganz andere Bandbreiten. Aber man brachte trotzdem deutlich, es gab weniger Daten zu übertragen, aber die Bandbreiten waren so niedrig, dass man deutlich mehr Zeit investieren musste. Ich weiß auch, ich habe in der Zeit immer mit meinem 2400er Modem die ganze Nacht eigentlich die ganze Zeit telefoniert. Das Modem war halt verbunden und hat 2, 3, 4 Stunden lang einfach so die Daten für den nächsten Tag geholt.
News zum Beispiel, ne?
News vor allem, natürlich, klar. Ein bisschen Mail war dann halt auch immer noch mit dabei.
Das ist aber interessant, weil diese Dinger kommen alle irgendwie wieder. Wenn du das mal heute anguckst, gerade hier mit deinem Podcast oder so, ich höre den ja auch, den lade ich mir runter. Oder den lehnt sich mein iPhone runter. Diese Offline-Reading oder Offline-Listening in diesem Falle ist sozusagen nicht out. Das kommen alle wieder.
Das stimmt.
Interessanter Vergleich, den habe ich so noch gar nicht.
Kommen alle immer schlimmer wieder.
Na gut, versuchen wir mal wieder so ein bisschen auf die Spur auch der technischen Entwicklung zu kommen. Also wir waren so, 80er-Jahre war halt geprägt von der Anwendung her, von den Mailbox-Netzen. Es gab halt Modems und teilweise in den USA gab es halt auch schon erste Netze wie CompuServe etc.
Auch alle modembasiert für den Benutzer.
Genau, so quasi so frühes Facebook, wo du so alle Dienste irgendwie integriert hattest. Man konnte da, ich weiß nicht, konnte man da auch chatten. Auf jeden Fall hatte man irgendwie E-Mail vor allem als primären Dienst. Und Firmen konnten halt dort Angebote platzieren, so wie es eben bei BTX auch war, dass man eben als Anbieter auftrat. Und überhaupt war dieses Anbieter-Konsumenten-Verhältnis relativ klar abgesteckt, aber alles ging im Wesentlichen auch über Kommandos oder zumindest einfache Zeichen-Oberflächen.
Und abrechenbar. Das musst du auch überlegen. Dadurch, dass du, also das ist hier im BTX, du konntest ja über dein BTX auch kostenpflichtige Dienste benutzen, die dann mit auf deiner BTX, sprich Telefonrechnung später drauf standen. Das heißt also, beide N wussten sehr genau, mit wem was zu tun hat, der Anbieter und der Konsument. Und der Konsument konnte halt eben, der Anbieter konnte halt immer auch sagen, hier habe ich Premium-Content. Und wenn du den haben willst, dann wählst du die BTX-Seite so und so an. Und das kostet sich dann aber eine Mark 50. Auch Zeittarif teilweise gab es auch. Sozusagen je länger du auf die Pixel-Pornos starst, desto teurer wurde es. Weiß ich nicht. Zeittarif oder Abruftarif. Aber das ist, denke ich, auch ein wichtiger Faktor, um überhaupt damals die Leute dafür begeistern zu können, diese Firmen. Heute funktioniert das ja alles anders. In dem Moment, wenn du jetzt ein Telekom T-Online, es gibt ein paar Dienste, die Telekom selber, hast du jetzt einen Alice-DSL-Anschluss oder so, dann gehst du auf irgendeine kostenlichtige Seite, wird Alice einen Teufel tun und die Abrechnung für diese Firma machen. Da sind wir irgendwie nicht. Das ist immer noch so ein bisschen der Traum von manchen Leuten, dass das mal irgendwie mal geht. Aber da hat die Industrie in dem Sinne, gegenüber den alten CompuServe-BTX-Systemen, hat so etwas verloren.
Ja, Payment ist der große Hinkefuß im Internet immer noch. Und das erklärt sich halt einfach aus dieser doch zu offenen Struktur. Aber jetzt noch mal kurz zusammenfassen. Also diese Mailbox-Szene im weiteren Sinne, eben gepaart mit so diesen ersten frühen Diensten, die alle mittlerweile verstorben oder in anderen Sachen aufgegangen sind, am Ende natürlich vor allem vom Web-Tod getrampelt wurden. Das war einfach so der DFÜ-Bedarf. Und technologisch haben sich halt die Telefonnetze noch parallel und separat entwickelt zu diesen frühen Datendiensten. Das X25 und das Telefonnetz, das waren eigentlich im Wesentlichen so die großen Dienstleistungen der Telekom. Jetzt vielleicht von irgendwelchen Spezial-Sachen. Und des Post-80er. Genau. Und auch weltweit. Aber Telekom war ja auch führend. Also ich glaube, von der Infrastruktur, Netzinfrastruktur machte Deutschland in den 80er Jahren keiner so richtig was vor.
Da technologisch weit geht, gibt es schon noch ein paar Länder, die andere Sachen, die sie doch besser hinkriegen. Also die Schweiz hat zum Beispiel auch nicht schlecht. Und gerade die Skandinavier ist auch heute noch so. Aber was die Deutschen natürlich schon ganz gut auch hinkriegen, ist es halt eben auch mal über 80 Millionen Leuten so mal zur Verfügung zu stellen. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie das so ist, aber es ist ja bis heute so, dass den ISDN-Anschluss noch, noch, solange es sie noch gibt, nämlich nicht mehr so lange. Ich habe noch einen gekriegt. Dass du den bundesweit kriegst. Du kannst halt eben irgendwie deine Hütte auf die Zugspitze setzen und anrufend sagen, hallo, hier ist deutsches Staatsgebiet, haben will. Und dann klettert einer mit einer Kabeltrommel hoch. Das ist der berühmte Universaldienst, wo es ja jetzt auch gerade politisch den Streit übergab. Dass man jetzt nicht mal überlegt hat, wir sind jetzt 20 Jahre weiter, es wäre mal interessant, diesen Universaldienst mal auszudehnen sozusagen auf DSL. Und da gab es jetzt gerade hier unsere Freunde von der FDP, von der Margin Party, die das erfolgreich sozusagen wieder rausgekillt haben aus den aktuellen Diskussionen. Weil natürlich der Industrie nicht recht ist, dass sie jedem Bauern mit beliebig viel Aufwand irgendwie in DSL hinlegen sollen, müssen. Aber beim ISCN gilt das halt. Und dadurch, dass es damals noch staatsbetriebbar war, wurde das halt eben auch gemacht. Das ist halt eben auch der Vorteil von diesen Staatsbetrieben oder auch teilweise Teilstaatsbetrieben, dass die halt eben auch Dinge machen, die wirtschaftlich denkend das Unternehmen einfach nicht machen würde. Mir ist das aufgefallen, wenn man so in bestimmten Ländern, zum Beispiel, das ärgert mich wahnsinnig. Ich bin jetzt in letzter Zeit sehr viel in Skandinavien gewesen. Jedes Mal, wenn ich da hinfahre, kriege ich so einen Hass auf die Situation in Deutschland. Weil wir gehen halt eben einfach Sachen. Ich war letztes Jahr in Island, weit, weit weg von Reykjavík, am letzten Fjord hinten, wirklich ganz hinten. Wo du fast schon nach Kanada greifen kannst. Oder nach Grönland. Also wirklich ganz weit hin. Und am Ende der Straße steht ein kleines Café, ein uraltes Häuschen, da haben ein paar junge Leute ein Café drin und für die paar Touris, die da sozusagen land's end hinten hinfahren. Und ich sitze da so und schlüpfe meinen Kaffee und guck, da hängt ein DSL-Router. Und dann habe ich mal mein iPad aufgeklappt und mich dann nach Freie WLAN für die Gäste und mich da eingeklinkt und mal nachgemessen, sieben Megabit. Die haben am Arsch der Welt, haben die sieben Megabit. Weil das leisten die sich dort einfach. Die haben einfach verstanden, dass diese, als Gesellschaft, dass sie hier auf der Insel haben sehr wenig Ressourcen, die haben nur das Know-how ihrer Leute, die Bildung ihrer Leute und dafür ist es halt eben notwendig, dass man eben auch sowas dort hat. Und da leistet man sich halt eben den Aufwand, an den Arsch der Welt einen DSL-Anschluss zu legen. Das ist in anderen skandinavischen Ländern auch so. Und in Deutschland ist es immer noch so, dass jetzt bis vor vier Wochen hatte keine 70 km von Berlin, der deutschen Hauptstadt, entfernt, kein DSL. Null. Na, da gab es nichts. ISTN gab es da, im Gegenteil, das gab es überall. Aber es gibt dort weder Mobilfunk mit Edge, noch DSL, noch sonst irgendwas. UMTS brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Und jetzt seit vier Wochen gibt es dort sowohl LTE als auch DSL.
Okay, dann wollen wir gleich nochmal...
Ja, ja, hinkommen.
Mich interessiert jetzt einfach nochmal dieser Umbruch, der ja auch ein technologischer Umbruch war, weil die technische Infrastruktur zur Bereitstellung eines X.25-Netzes und die technische Infrastruktur zur Bereitstellung eines analogen Telefonnetzes war im besten Fall nur in manchen Bereichen miteinander verquickt. Standorte, etc., Kabelwege vielleicht und so weiter. Aber an sich waren das vollkommen disjunkte Technologien und ganz andere Bereitstellungsformen. Mit ISDN war ja so diese Vision, ja, alles über ein Netz, Bild, hohen Daten, etc. Dann auch immer so ihr bekloppte Video-Bild-Telefonie-Vision, mit dem sie einem dieses ISDN verkaufen wollten, wo wir Nerds ja auch immer da gesessen haben und einen Kopf geschüttelt haben und gesagt haben, mach doch einfach mal diese 64 Kilo billig, ja, hier Standleitung und so weiter. Was hätte Deutschland für eine Internetrevolution erlebt, hätte es Anfang der 90er Jahre einfach diese ISDN-Verbindung für brauchbares Geld als Flatrate gegeben. Das wäre einfach, stimmt mir zu, wir würden in einem anderen Bildungsstaat leben jetzt.
Ja, wir hatten eben damals die Möglichkeit, oder haben auch heute noch, zumindest diese 64 Kilobit in jeden Winkel der Republik zu tragen. Überall hin. Und wie gesagt, allein die Tarifierung hat es natürlich auch verhindert, dass genau das eingetreten ist, was du gerade gesagt hast. Womit wir bei einem sehr interessanten Thema sind, diese ganze Telekommunikationsgeschichte in Deutschland bis heute, bis ins DSL rein, es wird sehr stark von Politik, von Firmenpolitik, aber auch von schlicht deutscher Sturheit geprägt. Wir kommen nachher noch drauf, wenn wir uns mal über ein bisschen ADSL-Technik unterhalten. Also es gibt durchaus Dinge am deutschen DSL, die so nicht sein müssten, wo halt einfach mal jemand bei der Telekom eine Entscheidung getroffen hat, das machen wir so und nicht anders, das haben wir schon immer so gemacht, das werden wir immer so machen. Und da gibt es etliche von diesen Sachen. Und diese ganzen Datendienste waren sehr, sehr lange Zeit eben als notwendiges Übel angesehen. Das hat die Industrie benötigt, um ihre Großrechner miteinander zu verkoppeln. Aber das ist nichts, wo sich die Bundespost oder später auch die Telekom dann primär in der Pflicht gesehen hat, da jetzt mal was zu tun, für die Infrastruktur, fürs Land oder fürs Volk. Auch diese ganzen IP-Sachen, man kann mich erinnern, diese X.25-Szene. Ich habe vorhin schon mal kurz das Wissenschaftsnetz erwähnt. Für die war IP und Internet in den ersten Jahren war das total verpöhnter Schmuddel. Das war ja nicht OSI-konform. Das ist ja so ein Bastelzeug, was irgendwie aus irgendwelchen amerikanischen Universitäten kommt. Und wir haben hier in Deutschland mit den OSI-Netzen gearbeitet.
Also Open System, also dieser X-Standard, diese Vision eines Netzwerkstandards.
Der Draht wurde neu erfunden, aber dafür schön ordentlich dokumentiert in Meta-Weisen, dicke Bände mit unverständlichen Fachausdrücken. Aber das war dokumentiert von offiziellen Standardisierungsgremien, nämlich von der ISO, wurde das dann auch beschlossen. Und nicht von irgendwelchen Leuten, die sich auf ITF-Meetings treffen und mal eben schnell den Standard an einer Hotelbar besprechen.
Oder irgendwelchen schmolligen Jungs, die einfach im Internet so was in so einem Textfall schreiben. Und dann macht man das so.
Genau. Und deswegen hat sich diese ganze Telekommunikationsindustrie sehr lange von diesen Dingern ferngehalten. Die Telekom eben auch. Und es sind eben solche Leute gewesen, wie der vorhin schon erwähnte Rüdiger Volk von der Uni Dortmund, der es irgendwie geschafft hat, da mal jemanden aufzuwecken, der gesagt hat, hallo, das ist die Zukunft, lass uns doch mal was machen. Lass uns doch mal mit der Infrastruktur, die wir haben, mit dem Zugriff auf Kabel, auf Leitungen, auf Bits, mal hier was aufbauen, was mal ein bisschen geht. Also womit man eben diese Zeugs auch machen kann. Und sowas hast du häufiger. Gerade in Deutschland, glaube ich, da ist sehr, sehr viel Sturheit vorhanden. Gerade eben bei der ehemaligen Bundespost oder bei der Telekom.
Aber im Prinzip die Investition in das ISDN-Netz, die war ja doch schon recht... Also ich hatte immer so den Eindruck, ISDN, das war einfach ein dickes Thema bei der Telekom. Und ganz klar stand ja auch die Vision, schnell auch das ganze Netz zu digitalisieren. Ich denke, so Anfang der 90er-Jahre hat sich schon abgezeichnet, dass man eben mit der Digitaltechnik ganz andere Leitungskapazität erzeugen kann. Man muss nicht für jedes Telefongespräch ein einzelnes Kabel haben. Im Einzelnen gab es das ja auch schon damals, dass da halt gemultiplexed wurden und hier und da auch mal eine digitale Leitung zum Einsatz kam, wo mehrere Gespräche übertragen wurden. Aber ISDN war ja wirklich auch zu dieser End-to-End-Traum, dass man wirklich digital bis ins Heim geht und da dann auch intelligente Telefone hat und eben besondere Dienste anbieten kann. Und tatsächlich ist ja über ISDN so einiges möglich, auch heute noch, von dem eigentlich kaum einer irgendwas weiß. Teilweise waren es auch Sachen, die man nicht braucht. Teilweise waren es Sachen, die man eigentlich immer haben wollte, aber wo man sich immer nur gefragt hat, warum es nicht voran ging. Vielleicht war ISDN einfach auch nicht good enough. Es war dann nicht genug Neues, dass sich das wirklich gelohnt hätte. Trotzdem hätte man damals zumindest den Schopf der Gelegenheit da gepackt, Datendienste auch wirklich zu pushen. Also was weiß ich, auch so ISDN-Karten für Rechner und so weiter.
Gab es ja alles. War ja dann auch gar nicht so teuer.
Irgendwann war es dann auch gar nicht mehr so teuer. Irgendwann hat sich das auch eine Zeit lang durchgesetzt. Aber irgendwann reichten dann halt auch diese 64 Kilometer nicht mehr aus.
Naja, und vor allen Dingen auch dieser Zeittarif. Der Zeittarif, glaube ich, das war der größte Knüppel dazwischen. Ich komme da nachher nochmal drauf, weil in dem besagten Dorf, von dem ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal gesprochen habe, ist jetzt DSL eingezogen. Und da findet so ein bisschen die digitale Revolution statt. Also die Leute, die vorher dort überhaupt mit Internet was zu tun haben, haben vorher ein Modem benutzt. Und die springen jetzt von Modemgeschwindigkeit auf 16 Mega mit DSL. Und das ist sehr interessant, das zu beobachten. Früher war das so, das war ein heiliger Akt. Du kannst dir ja fast vorstellen, da hat sich fast die ganze Familie fein angezogen, sich vom PC aufgebaut und dann wurde sich hochoffiziell eingewählt. Und dann wurde mal eine Seite abgeworfen. So ungefähr kannst du dir das vorstellen. Und jetzt ist es halt so, die Leute gucken mich immer ganz unglaublich an, wenn ich denen dann einen DSL-Router einrichte und einen Laptop. Wie wähle ich mich denn jetzt da ein? Ja, das tust du nicht, du bist drin. Aber ich muss mit nein, musst du nicht, du bist immer drin. Ja, aber nein, du bist einfach immer da. Du klappst den Laptop, lässt ihn stehen. Es kostet sich auch nichts. Kannst dein Video laufen lassen oder auch nicht. Oder nimmst du den Ding mit in die Küche, um dir dein Kochrezept da durchzulesen. Nein, du musst das nicht runterladen. Du musst jetzt nicht dich einwählen, darunter laden, dich wieder ausloggen oder so. Sondern du bist jetzt drin. Flatrate, so, drin. Das ist sehr interessant, das zu sehen, weil ich halt eben noch ganz anders denke. Das ist sozusagen, ich gehe jetzt ins Netz, war so ein PC-Rufan.
Das ist ja auch immer noch so dieses Einloggen oder so. Du kennst ja auch immer diese Umfragen, wenn Leute einen zur Internetnutzung befragen. Ja, wie viele Stunden am Tag verbringen sie denn im Internet?
24.
Kann ja auch echt nur noch mal im Kopf schütteln oder so.
Ja, aber es ist wirklich so. Und diese, das war mit ISDN war das genauso. Du hattest zwar mehr Bits, aber du hattest halt eben Zeittarif gehabt. Erst später gab es irgendwelche Leute, die dann irgendwelche Flatrates oder so temporär, ich weiß noch, der ARKOR hat es gemacht, als sie denn damals angefangen haben, ihr eigenes Netz aufzubauen und da Leute anzuschließen. Da haben sie Leute beworben und sagen, ja, drei Monate gibt es bei ihnen DSL, bis dahin können sie über ISDN surfen für Flatrate oder so. Als Überbrückungsgeschichte haben die das gemacht. Aber der Zeittarif und eben dieser ganze Faktum, dass man sich einwählen musste, hochfahren, einwählen, rein, raus oder so, bringt einfach dich zu einer ganz anderen Nutzung von dem Ding. Aber das ist ganz anders, als wenn du dich heute da hast und ein iPad einfach auf dem Tisch liegen hast, das machst du an und einfach was aufrufst und machst es wieder aus oder nicht. Das ist eben eine ganz andere Art der Nutzung. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie kam ich dann jetzt drauf?
Wir haben verschiedene Aspekte. Ich wollte noch mal auf diese Einführung von ISDN in Deutschland zu sprechen kommen. Und zwar jetzt auch mal in technischer Hinsicht. Was hat denn das, war das nicht dann schon der Weg des kompletten Umbaus der Telefonnetzwerkinfrastruktur Deutschlands? Also die ganzen digitalen Vermittlungsstellen, die mit ISDN eingeführt wurden, das hat ja quasi den Boden gelegt für digitale Dienste, auch wenn Internet damals noch keiner so richtig gesagt hat.
Überhaupt nicht.
War nicht in Sicht. Genau, war nicht in Sicht. Und dann hat man auch gleich den nächsten...
Du hast gerade BTX per ISDN mit 64 Kilowatt. Ach so, das gab es auch.
Ja, immerhin.
Ja, aber dann gab es ja gleich diesen nächsten Traum. Ich hatte nämlich so den Eindruck, Deutschland hatte auch so eine ganz eigene Vorstellung von Zukunft, also auch technologisch. ISDN, das war dann sozusagen schon irgendwie die Realität. Während die anderen Länder, so in den USA und so weiter, wenn du da ISDN gesagt hast, wusste ja keiner, wovon du redest. Ist auch heute nicht anders. Und dann wurde ja dann auch die nächste Zukunft so geplant, strategisch, wie Telcos das eben so machen. Na ja, wenn wir jetzt noch schneller werden wollen, dann brauchen wir dann halt optische Anschlussleitung. Breitband ISDN, genau. Und dann fingen sie halt irgendwie an, Glasfaser zu verbuddeln.
Na ja, Vorsicht, interessanter Punkt, und jetzt spielt die Politik wieder mit rein, interessanter Punkt war, dass die ISDN-Einführung war, sollen wir mal, just zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo die Deutsche Wiedervereinigung kam. In Westdeutschland, Westberlin wurde ISDN, glaube ich, 89 offiziell eingeführt. Und dann, irgendwie ein halber Jahr später, wussten sie, okay, wir haben dann noch ein bisschen Fläche mitzuversorgen. Und da haben sie dann natürlich auch dann Entscheidungen getroffen, natürlich auch bedingt durch die Politik, dass sie sagen, okay, da müssen wir jetzt eh ein neues Telefonnetz aufbauen, dann machen wir das doch gleich richtig. Und dann machen wir das auch einmal rundrum. Das ist, wie er sagte, diese deutsche Geschichte, dass man sagt, wenn man sich dann endlich mal so etwas entschließt, das zu machen, dann wird das halt eben auch durchgezogen. Dann wird das halt eben auch bundesweit gemacht. In Deutschland haben wir, glaube ich, 5.300 Vermittlungsstellen oder so was. Das ist schon ein bisschen Holz, die mal alle umzubauen. Und das haben sie dann aber durchgezogen. Das hat noch ein bisschen gedauert. Ich glaube, die letzte analoge Vermittlungsstelle haben sie 1997 oder 1999 abgeschaltet. Aber das war nur noch so ein bisschen was für ein paar Leute, die noch einen analogen Wählschirmtelefon hatten. Wer da digitale Dienste haben wollte, der konnte die eigentlich schon bundesweit überall benutzen. Seit 1993, 1994 oder so. Irgendwie haben sie denn Fernanschaltungen gemacht oder so. Also erst mal nur jede zweite Vermittlungsstelle auf digital gebracht haben. Und die hatten genügend Verbindungskabel dazwischen, dass wenn jetzt mal ein Kunde unbedingt was haben wollte, dann haben sie einfach durchgeschaltet. Aber ich denke, dass politisch auch, das war halt eben, ich sag mal, ich kann es nicht belegen, aber ich denke mal, das wurde halt eben aus dieser Aufbau-Ostkasse bezahlt. Private Unternehmen ihren Fightstanz eben auf dem ehemaligen Monopolnetz dort tanzt, wo man sagt, hallo, das ist mein Steuergeld, was da liegt. Dafür wollt ihr mich jetzt abzocken. Das ist aber, da wurde halt sozusagen, da war mal sozusagen, das war Kernaufgabe, Aufbau-Ost. Wir machen das hier alles klar. Mit neuster bunter Technik eben auch mit Glasfaser. Was toll war, weil das gab dann, das wurde relativ schnell im Osten renoviert. Die Vermittlungsstellen eben ausgetauscht, modernste digitale Vermittlungsstellen rein. Was denen allerdings hinterher dann auch irgendwann ein bisschen in den Arsch gebissen hat, als die DSL-Geschichte hochkam und sie feststellten, oh, das haben wir ein bisschen zu viel Glas.
Irgendwann hat nämlich auch die USA festgestellt, dass mal ein bisschen mehr Bandbreite als normaler Modemspeed doch vielleicht ganz nett wäre. Nur, dass halt da die Realität ganz anders ist und dass man da nicht so einen zentralen Staatsplan verkündet mit, jetzt bauen wir mal überall ESDN rein, sondern da gab es schon viel zu viele gegenläufige Interessen. Und natürlich hat man einfach das genommen, was da war, das war Kupferkabel und dann wurde eben mit neuen Chips und neuer Effizienz und neuer Frequenzbearbeitung da einfach DSL geboren. Und auf einmal, oh Wunder, oh Wunder, kam man eben aus denselben Kabeln, die vorher irgendwie nicht mehr als 64 Kilobit aushielten, bevor sie anfingen zu dampfen, konnte man eben dann doch erklecklich mehr rausziehen, unter anderem eben durch diesen Trick, dass man sagt, wir gehen wieder zurück in die BTX-Zeit und haben mehr Download als Upload und schaffen damit eben so ein bisschen Freiraum da im Frequenzband.
Die Grundidee war ja, war die Erkenntnis, die sie dann irgendwann gefunden haben, dass sie ihr Netz, dieses analoge Netz immer nur mit einer Bandbreite von 3,1 Kilohertz ausgenutzt haben. Eigentlich seit Graham Bell das Telefon erfunden hat, gibt es halt das, also ein analoge Telefonnetz übertägt von 300 Hertz bis 3,4 Kilohertz. Das heißt, da hast du zwischen 3100 Hertz Bandbreite. Und darauf war immer alles optimiert. Die ganzen Modems und alle, da waren alle darauf eingeschossen, weil das war das, was man durch das Netz übertragen konnte. Und sonst jemand kam dann mal auf die Idee, der jetzt gesagt wäre, aber wenn wir jetzt mal diese dusselige alte Vermittlungstechnik, egal ob nur analog oder digital, da mal rausnehmen und nur das nackte Kupfer nehmen, da geht doch noch was. Und wenn man so schaut, so ein normales ADSL, das erste ADSL, was kam, hat die Bandbreite benutzt bis 1,1 MHz. Da passt natürlich schon ein bisschen mehr rein als in 3,1 Kilohertz. Heutzutage haben wir mit ADSL 2, das was viele Leute zu Hause haben, diese berühmten 16 Megabit-Anschlüsse von Telekom, LS, Acorn, die benutzen halt eben ADSL 2 Plus mit 2,2 MHz Bandbreite. VDSL geht es ja auch noch ein bisschen weiter hoch, hat aber entsprechend kürzere Strecken. Da musst du schon dichter dran sein am Kunden. Da kommen wir dann noch drauf, denke ich mal, wenn wir ein bisschen die Struktur besprechen, wie das so aussieht. Aber das war sozusagen die Erkenntnis, dass man einfach sagt, wir nehmen diese vollkommen ausgeknusperte Modem-Technik, die man ja hatte am Ende der Modem-Ära. Du musst dir mal überlegen, über diese schlappen 3,1 Kilohertz haben sie es halt geschafft, irgendwie 57 Kilobyte drüber zu prügeln. Mit Quadratamplituden, Phasen, Schieß-Micht-Tot-Modulationen und weiß ich nicht, was denen nicht alles eingefallen ist. Und ihr sagt, nachdem wir das jetzt ausgeknuspert haben, was passiert eigentlich, wenn wir jetzt mal mehr Bandbreite auf dem Kabel nehmen, aber die selbe ausgeknusperte Modem-Technik, wenn wir jetzt mal das Gate öffnen und sagen, was hier, mach mal. So sind sie halt in die Megabit-Ära eingeschwebt relativ schnell. Der Nachteil ist, das lässt sich eben nicht mehr wählen. Das kannst du nicht durch die Vermittlungstechnik durchwählen. Du kannst halt nur das Stückchen Kupfer nehmen, von der Vermittlungsstelle bis zum Endkundenraus, die berühmte letzte Meile. Das heißt, man muss eine parallele Infrastruktur installieren zu der Wähltechnik. Man muss jetzt noch ein bisschen Geld in die Hand nehmen und an jeder Vermittlungsstelle noch mal ein Schränkchen reinschrauben, wo so ein bisschen Technik drin ist. Und die natürlich untereinander auch noch miteinander verbinden. Aber das ist sozusagen die epochale Erkenntnis, dass das Kupferwatt schon seit Jahren verbuddelt wurde. Man benutze immer noch Kupferleitungen, oder vielleicht auch alte Alu-Leitungen in der DDR noch. Irgendetwas, das alle persönlich noch eingraben hat. In welchen ländlichen Gegenden benutzt man heute immer noch, um darauf Megabits zu transportieren. Das ist, glaube ich, der spannende Teil.
Ja, eigentlich eine sehr effiziente Nutzung. Nur gab es dann die Übergangsphase, wo man glaubte, die Zukunft ist optisch. Wenn wir schneller werden wollen, müssen wir überall optische Kabel reinlegen. Wo es natürlich ganz hübsch wäre, wenn wir jetzt alle eine optische Leitung hätten, die ordentlich funktioniert, dann wären auch mal 100 Megabits kein Thema. Und es ist auch absehbar, denke ich mal, dass das auch irgendwann, beziehungsweise teilweise ist es schon Realität in bestimmten Gegenden. Wir hatten ja dann hier in Berlin Friedrichshain und auch in anderen Gegenden. Friedrichshain war besonders bekannt dafür.
Opal-geschädigt.
Genau, dieses Opal-Ghetto, also Opal für optische Anschlussleitungen. Überall lag Glasfaser frisch, aber irgendwie haben sie nicht dran gedacht, Kupfer auch noch mit reinzulegen, weil wozu? Das ist ja die Vergangenheit. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass es dann da auch eben, wie in deinem Dorf auf Ewigkeiten, kein DSL gab. Ich glaube, die Situation ist mittlerweile überwunden.
In Friedrichshain. Auf den Dörfern ist es jetzt eine interessante Entwicklung zu sehen, die Telekom stellte. Man kann es immer sehr schön sehen an diesen Kästen. Wenn man so durch die Straße geht, man hat so diesen alten, den guten alten Postkasten, sagen wir mal. Da steht sogar noch Post drauf. Der ist so, wie ist er, so Hüfthoch oder so. Je nachdem, wie groß so seine Hüfte ist. Aber nicht wesentlich höher. Diese grauen Teile. Ja, grau sind sie alle. Also, sagen wir mal, so Kühlschrankhoch oder so, vielleicht so ein kleiner. Und dann ist das 30, 40 Zentimeter tief, einen Meter breit. Das sind die alten Kabelverzweiger, die KVs, die da rumstehen. Das ist das, was man schon als Kind kennt. Die standen schon immer da. Da hat man schon als Kind drauf gesessen. Und jetzt gibt es welche, die sind in einem helleren Grau, ein bisschen tiefer, ein bisschen breiter und vor allen Dingen höher und haben oben Lüftungsschlitze. Und wenn man mal sein Ohr dran hält, kann man bei manchen auch was Summen hören. Das sind nämlich die, die schon aktive Technik drin haben. Das heißt, das ist jetzt der Trend, den die Telekom vor ein paar Jahren seit 2006, 2007 haben sie halt angefangen, die in den Städten zu verteilen, um ihr VDSL-Produkte an den Mann zu bringen. Aber dieselben Kästen benutzen sie jetzt eben auch, um auf dem Land die Bits an den Mann zu bringen. Das sind halt eben größere Verteiler, die auch eine Stromversorgung drin hatten. Die alten KVs waren ja einfach nur so Schränke. Die standen da rum mit ein paar Klemmen, wo man Kabel zusammenklemmen konnte, aber da war nichts Aktives drin. Die neuen Kästchen haben richtig eine Stromversorgung drin, eine kleine Batterie auch unten und richtig aktive Technik.
Ich glaube, dass es um die DSL-Entwicklung und dieses ganze Drama, was sich bei Neuanschlüssen bei Einzelnen immer wieder entfaltet, um das zu verstehen, die typische Telefonnetzinfrastruktur vor DSL und nach DSL beleuchten. Also es gab halt Vermittlungsstellen. Was hast du gesagt? 5.300? Das sind so die großen. Das ist so das, was so eine Vorwahl hat und wo viel drehende Mechanik war.
Sag mal so, was traditionell eine Vorwahl hatte. In Städten, ich glaube in Berlin, haben wir so 200 von den Dingern. Knapp 200, die natürlich alle unter derselben Vorwahl sind in den anderen Städten auch, aber so vom Prinzip stimmt es. Heute ist das nicht mehr so. Heute hast du auf gerade im Osten...
Ja, mit 030 fingen sie an, aber danach standen die ersten 3 Stellen wieder für irgendeinen Bereich. Über die Nummer hat man quasi die Geografie auch durchschritten.
In Zeiten vor rufen wir an Portabilität.
Genau. Und von dort ging dann Kabel ins Feld, in die Landschaft, in die Straßen. Die nächste Haltestelle sind diese kleinen grauen Boxen, von denen du sprichst. Das sind diese KVs, Kabelverteilung.
Kabelverteiler, ja. Da gehen dann immer so dicke Kabel hin, vom HVT, vom Hauptverteiler, der sich in der Regel im Keller oder im Erdgeschoss dieser Vermittlungsstelle befindet. Dann gehen diese Kabel zu diesen Kabelverzweigern. Verzweiger heißen die, die heißen nicht Verteiler, Verzweiger. In den Straßen, die so rumstehen, von dort aus gehen die Kabel in die Hausanschlüsse. Und von dort, wenn es jetzt ein Mehrfamilienhaus ist zum Beispiel, werden sie dann halt eben in die einzelnen Wohnungen verteilt. Das ist so der Tradition.
Das heißt, es gibt eigentlich zwei...
Die sind aber passiv gewesen. Passiv heißt, da ist keine Elektronik drin, da sind nur Schaltklemmen und ein Draht.
Also angeschlossen werden, wenn man ein Telefon beantragt hat, heißt eigentlich nur, dass zunächst einmal eine Leitung auserkoren wird, wo dann ich dranhänge, in der Vermittlungsstelle, die auf ein Kabel gelegt wird, was so in meine Gegend kommt, in diese KV, dann muss der Telekom-Postmann da wiederum dieses Kabel mit meinem Haus verbinden, also sozusagen eine Leitung zum Haus finden, die noch frei ist. Und dann ist das irgendwie bei mir im Haus im Keller und dann muss es halt noch ein Kabel in meine Wohnung geben und dann kommt das halt irgendwann raus. Okay, gut, so kennt man das ja im Prinzip auch. So, jetzt wollte man DSL einführen und hat man dann auch getan. Und wo muss jetzt die Technik als erstes ausgetauscht werden? Jetzt sind wir so für das Ur-DSL, für das allererste DSL.
Na ja, ausgetauscht nicht. Das Spannende ist ja, dass man für DSL sich gedacht hat, wir bauen die Technik so, dass man sie parallel betreiben kann zu einem bestehenden Telefonanschluss. Es war sogar lange Zeit so, dass die Telekom ihre DSL ausschließlich auf eigene Telefonanschlüsse draufgelegt hat. Dass die sozusagen nicht entbündelt gab. Ja, kommen wir noch drauf. Das heißt, du musstest eh schon einen Telefon- oder einen ISDN-Anschluss von der Telekom haben und dann haben sie dir auf dieselbe Kupferader nochmal ein DSL draufgelegt. Dazu wird der nutzbare Frequenzbereich aufgeteilt in einen niederfrequenten Teil, nämlich dem, wo die alte Telefonie sich abspielt. Und einen hochfrequenten Teil, wie wir vorhin erwähnten, beim UR DSL 1,1 MHz. Dieser hochfrequente Teil fängt, glaube ich, bei 135 oder 138 Kilohertz oder so was. Und der Teil darunter bleibt sozusagen für die Telefonie des ISDN. Dafür ist dieser Splitter da. Dieser Splitter ist rein technisch gesehen, da ist zwar Elektronik drin, aber es ist eigentlich mehr oder weniger nur eine passive Frequenzweiche. Da gibt es nochmal einen Pendant dazu in der Vermittlungsstelle. Also dort gibt es auch einen Splitter. Er sieht ja nicht so aus wie der.
Das DSL ist sozusagen in der Vermittlungsstelle so telefon- und internetseparat. Und wird dann eigentlich nur auf dem Kabelweg bis in meine Wohnung zusammen moduliert. Das schnelle in den hochfrequenten Teil, das alte bleibt da, wo es eigentlich auch schon vorher war. Und wird auch nicht umtransplant oder so weit. Sondern es wird einfach nur oben noch was dazugefügt. Und der Splitter teilt das wieder auseinander.
Genau, es ist eine passive Frequenzweiche. Die eigentlich, glaube ich, gar nicht notwendig wäre. Weil die Modems sind so gut. Also so ein DSL-Modem lässt sich nicht da durchstören, wenn da unten auf 3 Kilohertz noch jemand rumquetscht. Das hat selber seine eigenen Filter drin. Und ein normaler, analoge Telefon schert sich auch in Scheißdreck, um welche Signale im 500-Kilohertz-Bereich.
Aber man muss ja eh andere Stecker bereitstellen, dann kann man das dann auch gleich noch machen.
Deswegen, so ein Splitter ist sehr, sehr simpel. Der hat keine aktive Elektronik, braucht auch eigentlich keinen Strom. So richtig passive, gute, alte Frequenzweiche.
So, und da muss man dann aber wiederum noch ein Modem dranhängen, weil natürlich über diese lange Strecke schon wieder Modulation gefahren wird. Also auch da haben wir eigentlich noch ein Modem, wie früher auch.
Nur, dass es diesmal mehr Platz hat. Dass es mehr Bandbreite hat.
Und dass es nicht mehr wählen muss, weil es hat da seine Leitung eigentlich dediziert.
Ja, dadurch, dass DSL in dem Sinne nicht gewählt wird, wir haben ja gerade eben gesagt, wird in der Vermittlungsstelle auch getrennt, ist das Gegenstück zu dem Modem, was du zu Hause hast, schon in deiner Vermittlungsstelle. Das heißt, du musst da gar keinen mehr anwählen. Du kannst auch gar keinen mehr anwählen in dem Sinne. Und durch die Splitter auf beiden Seiten getrennt, glauben die, sie haben selber fürsichtet Kabel und amüsieren sich dann da, die beiden Modems.
Nur, dass man dann trotzdem doch wieder wählen muss, weil man in seinem Router dann wiederum eine Zugangscode eingeben muss.
In anderen Ländern fällt aus dem DSL einfach das IP raus. In Deutschland ist das halt so. Da hat man sich eben überlegt, wir machen da noch mehrere Schichten dazwischen. Das sind so richtig Hanebüchen. Da sind mehrere Protokollschichten dazwischen, die da eigentlich gar nicht hingehören oder die man eigentlich nicht braucht. Da ist noch ein Ethernet dazwischen. Da ist ein Ethernet und eine ATM drin. Also, um es genau zu sagen, wenn du hier ein IP-Paket losschickst, dann ist das IP over PPPoE over Ethernet over ATM. Das ist also echt drei, viermal eingepackt. Das hat man damals auch eingeführt, weil die Telekom oder Post, wer auch immer, nee, damals hieß es schon Telekom, wollte halt wieder grundsätzlich die Struktur haben, das zu sagen, ja, wir haben zwar hier eine Leitung, aber ich möchte gerne eine WEL-Verbindung haben, damit ich wieder einen Beginn und einen Enden habe. Damit man Zeittarife machen kann, damit man überhaupt sozusagen einen weiß, wann ist jetzt da eigentlich der Kunde drin, damit es sozusagen ein offizielles Ich-bin-drin und Ich-bin-nicht-drin gibt. Aus was weiß ich auch für Legalgründen und Abhörtechnik und frag mich was, dass es sozusagen einen offiziell determinierten Zeitpunkt gibt, wo man sagt, Ich-bin-drin, Ich-bin-nicht-drin.
Um deine Dorfmitbewohner da nicht zu sehr mit der Zukunft zu schocken, hättest du ihnen ja das DSL auch so einrichten können, dass sie sich wirklich anwählen und wieder abwählen, um einfach da auch sich zu Hause zu fühlen. Nicht, dass sie jetzt da...
Ja, aber da sind wir wieder bei dem vorhin erwähnten Monopolnetz, auf dem da die Telekom rumtanzt. Jetzt hat sie diese Kästchen dahingestellt aufs Dorf. Und sie nimmt sich auch das Recht drauf, da jetzt die nächsten zwei Jahre lang alleine Herrscher zu sein auf diesem Kästchen. Und da eben auch keinen Mitbewerber drauf zu lassen oder so was. Und offiziell gibt es zwar irgendwie vier oder fünf Tarife deutschlandweit, die man so buchen kann, aber wenn du drei von diesen fünfen bestellst, kriegst du den Anschluss einfach nicht. Denn das ist aus magischen Gründen kein portfrei. Oder so. Das heißt, du musst halt schon irgendwie das volle Paket buchen, so das 3495-Paket mit Flat-Raid und Trala und Pipapo. Dann kriegst du mit viel, viel Gequengel und Genörgel innerhalb von 14 Tagen, 3 Wochen einen Anschluss. Ansonsten dauert es halt eben noch. Das ist wirklich echt hanebüchen. Das ist ganz schlimm. Aber wenn du den Flat-Raid hast, konfiguriert natürlich den Leuten da draußen den Router, so dass der immer drin ist.
Zurück nochmal zu dem, wie DSL jetzt wirklich dranhängt. Ich weiß nicht, sollten wir jetzt ATM nochmal kurz ins Spiel werfen, weil du das jetzt gerade erwähnt hast? Oder verwirrt uns das jetzt nur?
Ich weiß nicht. ATM, wir können ja mal kurz was dazu sagen. Bei ISDN war es ja so, dass man zwar schon ein digitales Netz hatte, allerdings ist dieses Netz immer noch leitungsvermittelt. Das heißt, es wurden halt eben Signalwege geschaltet, physisch oder auch natürlich dann virtuell, die dir dann immer sozusagen einen Nutzkanal, den berühmten B-Kanal zur Verfügung stellten. 64 Kilobit von A nach B wurde gewählt, hat deine Anfang und deine Ende. Natürlich hat man dann in der Technik auch Ströme gemixt. Das hast du ja vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt, dass man sozusagen die Erkenntnis hatte, dass man über ein Stück Kupfer oder Glase auch immer mehr als ein Gespräch übertragen konnte. Das heißt, man hat die zusammengebündet. Es gab diese PDH, diese Pläsiokrone-Hierarchie.
Pläsiokrone-Digitale-Hierarchie.
Ah, der Fast-Googler. Damit hat man angefangen, diese Kanäle sozusagen durch Zeit-Multiplex zusammenzubündeln. Es gibt also so eine Hierarchie davon. Man kann also von diesen B-Kanälen, die man so einsammelt von vielen Kunden, 31 Stück zusammennehmen und die in einen 2-Mbit-Topf packen. Wenn man jetzt nachrechnet, stellt man fest, dass da eigentlich 32 reinpassen. Aber so ein bisschen hält man sich immer über für die gesamte ORM, Operations and Maintenance. Also Clock-Synchronisierung, Management, Fehler-Kollektur, tralala, pipapo. Also kannst du 31 von den Dingern nehmen und die in einen 2-Mbit-Anschluss tun. Von diesen 2-Mbit-Anschlüssen kannst du halt wieder 16 nehmen und die in einen 34-Mbit-Anschluss reinschmeißen. Von diesen 34-Mbit kann man... Weiß nicht, was ist die nächste Stufe, die wir hier in Deutschland hatten? Ich glaube, die nächste war 150-Mbit, 6-22. Das ist aber dann schon SDH, das ist dann schon ein bisschen kind of digital hierarchy. Aber das heißt, man kann die so zusammenbündeln und dann entsprechend wieder entbündeln, aber es ist so, dass das immer noch einzelne Leitungen oder Kanäle sind. Das heißt, wenn jetzt jemand seine 64-Mbit-Anschluss gerade nicht benutzt, dann belegen die trotzdem eben diesen Zeitschlitz auf diesen Multiplex-Kanal. Das heißt, das war eben noch nicht so effektiv wie heutzutage in einer Paketvermittlung.
Aber das war im Prinzip so die Methode, wie man überhaupt größere Bandbreitennutzung über die Kabel erzielt hat. Einfach höhere Leitungsgeschwindigkeit und ein Zeitmultiplex, das heißt, langsamere Leitungen werden so zusammengenommen.
So funktioniert uns auch das vorhin schon erwähnte OPAL, die optische Anschlussleitung. Das ist eben so, dass du dann in diesem KV, diesem Verteiler, der auf der Straße steht, hast du ein kleines Kästchen drin, der im einfachsten Falle mit 2 Megabit an die Vermittlungsstelle angebunden ist. Und die einzelnen Kanäle von den Kunden, die letztendlich da dranhängen, die ISDN-Kanäle oder so, einfach nur zeitmultiplext und nach Hause schickt. Da ist also noch keinerlei Vermittlungshirn oder sonst irgendwas drin. Das ist ein stumpfer Multiplexer, das Ding. Und die werden dann erst sozusagen über ein Kabel oder ein Glasfaser oder ein Draht in die Vermittlungsstelle geführt und dann dort eben wieder aufgeteilt, als würden die Kunden dort direkt mit ihren einzelnen Anschlüssen dranhängen. Man hat also sozusagen einfach einen Teil, ich nenne jetzt mal so die Ports von so einer Vermittlungsstelle, hat man halt einfach an einer langen Strip, an einer langen Glasfaser gehängt und die dichter zum Kunden gestellt. Dadurch gibt es übrigens auch ganz interessante Konstellationen. Ich will es nur kurz erwähnen, weil du vorhin sagtest, eine Vermittlungsstelle, eine Vorwahl. Man hat da, als man Ostdeutschland erschlossen hat, telekommunikationstechnisch, ist man ja hingegangen und hat gesagt, wir machen hier einen tollen Rufnummernplan dafür und den machen wir gleich mal ein bisschen breiter. Es gibt ja 5-stellige Vorwahlen, wobei ich jetzt immer dazu sagen muss, also für autonormale Verwahlungen werden das 6-stellig, weil die zählen die Null mit, aber die Null zählt eigentlich nicht mit zur Vermittlungsstellung. Also diese 033, 012 oder so und so, also diese 5-stelligen Dinger, die gibt es ja nur in Ostdeutschland. Und da hat man wirklich dann mikronesische Ortsnetze gebaut. Es gibt also durchaus da die Situation, dass du da Ortsnetze hast, da sind irgendwie 3, 4, 5, also Vorwahlen, wo 3, 4, 5 Dörfer drin sind. Die haben nicht mal ihre eigene Vermittlungsstelle. Da ist es dann so, da gibt es eine Vermittlungsstelle, die steht in der Mitte von 3 oder 4 von diesen Dingern und in dieser Vermittlungsstelle werden dann mehrere Ortsnetze abgebildet virtuell. Was ich damals schon astlig fand, weil wir hatten ganz am Anfang dieses Gesprächs schon erwähnt, den Nahtarif und den Ferntarif und Regio 50 und so. Und die waren echt gekniffen. Ich meine, hier als Berliner hast du halt 3,5 Millionen Berliner gehabt und im Nahtarif liegt Potsdam und Teltow und Oranienburg und so weiter und fort. Das kannst du mal schlapp über 4 Millionen Leute anrufen zum Orts- oder Nahtarif. Und so eine Leute, die da in Reinsberge oder in Löwenberg, Menz oder sowas wohnen, die konnten vielleicht gerade mal 500 Nasen anrufen zum Nahtarif. Das fand ich schon ein bisschen komisch.
Die haben wahrscheinlich einfach gedacht, die haben eh nicht so viele Freunde.
Zurück zum ATM. Wie gesagt, bei den ISDN, das normale ISDN, Leitungsvermittelt, also du hast halt deinen Kanal irgendwie belegt, der wurde vielleicht mal zusammengemultiplex, aber wenn du den nicht benutzt hast, war die Bandbreite einfach wasted, die war einfach weg. Beim ATM hat man sich überlegt, wir wollen jetzt mal was machen, wir wollen jetzt mal zwei Sachen zusammenbringen, wir wollen jetzt mal Paketvermittlung zusammenbringen mit Leitungsvermittlung. Es gab dann auch schon erste Versuche, dass man so gesagt hat, wir machen mal das, was wir sonst machen im ISDND-Kanal oder im X25, hat aber festgestellt, dass das ein bisschen ein Problem erzeugt, wenn du halt so nannte synchrone Dienste hast, wie Audio oder Video oder so. Wobei, witzigerweise, Audio ist noch schlimmer. Im Video, der Mensch kann viel eher mal verknusen, wenn er auf ein Bild guckt und es druckelt mal kurz, er bleibt stehen, aber wenn es im Audio hakt, dann sagt das Gehirn meistens relativ bald, geht gar nicht. Also muss man dafür sorgen, dass in einem Netz konstante Datenströme generieren können, die auch nicht gestört werden. Und trotzdem aber versuchen, diese Geschichten möglichst gut auszufüllen. Konstanter Datenströme hattest du mit dem PTH-System. Da hast du halt eben deinen B-Kanal gehabt, der gehörte dir, ob du ihn benutzt hast oder nicht. Aber der war immer da für dich, der war auch zeitlich deterministisch, der wurde nicht mal schneller, mal langsamer oder so, oder hat mal eine kürze oder längere Verzögerung gehabt, sondern der war halt da.
Immer an deiner Seite.
Und sowas wollte man halt eben auch haben. Und da hat man halt sich eben das mit dem ATM überlegt. Bei ATM, um mal ganz grob zu sagen, wie es funktioniert, ist man hackt einfach alles, was man hat in 48 Byte-Happen, macht noch einen schönen 5-Byte-Header davor, d.h. man kommt hinterher mit 53 Byte raus, oder 53 Octets, und die schickt man schön aneinander, gerade durch die Gegend, diese Containers. Kannst du dir so vorstellen wie so eine kleine, wie so eine Eisenbahn, wie so ein Spielzeug-Eisenbahn, wo halt kleine Lastwagen auf einer Schiene drauf sind, die alle gleich groß sind. Dadurch kann man halt relativ genau bestimmen, wann die Dinge ankommen. D.h. du kannst eben sagen auf einer, ich weiß nicht, du kannst jetzt nicht nachdenken, aber auf so einer schönen, schnellen Verbindung, auf so einer 150 Megabit-Strecke kannst du ausrechnen, wie viel 100.000 von diesen Dingern da pro Sekunde durchlaufen. Und dadurch, dass das halt so schön synchron ist und so schön getaktet ist, kannst du sagen, okay, lieber Tim, für dein Audio-Stream von deinem Studio zum Sendezentrum kriegst du halt jeden 47.11. Wagen da drin. Der gehört dir. Der ist garantiert, dass das deiner ist. Dadurch hast du halt eben ein sehr genau bestimmtes Zeitverhalten. Für die ganze Geschichte kannst du halt eben da deinen Audio-Stream reinkippen und dann hast du diesen Dienst.
Lustigerweise, ich meine, du redest jetzt davon, dass das dann so schöne, synchrone Dienste bereitstellt, aber ATM steht ja eigentlich für Asynchronous Transfer Mode. Weil es ja eigentlich Paket vermittelt ist. Also eigentlich mischt sich das da halt alles. Dadurch, dass man die Pakete so klein wählt und auch auf einer festen Größe macht man eben diesen Flow. Ich meine, das ist so Perlencatchen-mäßig. Da kommen halt viele kleine Mini-Paketchen, die dann schön aufgereiht mit hohem Druck irgendwie durch dünne Leitungen gepustet werden. Und das war so ein bisschen der Traum, eben die Anforderungen von außen so zu verallgemeinern, um eben gut nutzbare große Leitungen zu bekommen.
Ja, das Schöne ist, du kannst das ja mischen. Du kannst halt deine Synchronendienste, die haben halt eine festgelegte Zellrate, wo du genau weißt, ich tue für meinen Audiostreben so und so viel Kilobit da rein. Das heißt, ich brauche pro Sekunde so und so viele Zellen. Die kannst du dir garantieren lassen, dass du die kriegst in diesem riesengroßen Zug aus Lauterwaggons. Und das Schöne ist, dass dazwischendrin halt eben jede Menge Zellen frei bleiben. Und die kannst du halt mit Diensten befüllen, die du eben, wo das egal ist, in welchem Timing die ankommen, dass die auch mal gerne mal schneller, mal langsamer mit ein bisschen höher oder weniger Latenz ankommen, zum Beispiel IP-Verkehr. Der einzige Nachteil ist, was heißt Nachteil, was du natürlich machen musst, ist, du musst natürlich deine Daten klein hacken. Es gibt die wenigsten IP-Pakete, die in 48-Bit-Nutzlast reinpassen. Da passt meistens vielleicht nur ein TCP-AC rein oder so. Oder ein kleiner PING oder so. Aber sonst sind die meisten ja größer. Und das heißt, du musst sie halt klein hacken. Auf freie Zellen verteilen. Die freien Zellen streust du sozusagen zwischen die fest vorbelegten Zellen. Ja, lässt die mitschwimmen und drüben sammelst du sie wieder ein, sammelst sie wieder zusammen, machst wieder ein großes Paket, rausschiegst sie wieder weiter. Also, um mit uns dabei zu bleiben, was wir vorhin gesagt haben, ist sogar noch viel schlimmer. Wenn du aus deinem ADSL-Anschluss ein IP-Paket rausschiebst, ist das IP über Ethernet, über ARL5, nämlich der ATM Adaption Layer Type 5, über ATM. PPPoE habe ich jetzt ganz vergessen. Es wird sehr häufig ein und wieder ausgepackt. Dieses ARL5 ist sozusagen der Mechanismus, der dafür sorgt, dass du größere Datenfragmente, so Pakete eben, Ethernet-Pakete, also was eben zags in diese 48 Beithäppchen und die auf freie Zellen verteilst und die auf der anderen Seite wieder einsammelst und wieder zusammenbaust.
Sprich, ATM ist so die Technologie, die heutzutage im Wesentlichen der digitalen Übertragung auf allen möglichen Wegen zugrunde liegt, die aber so kleinteilig ist, dass sie quasi von allem benutzt werden kann. In dem Fall halt auch für diese DSL-Übertragung.
Kleinteilig und eben konstant, das ist der wichtige Teil. Die kleinen Teile haben eine bekannte Größe. ATM-Zellen sind immer 53 Beit groß. Ich habe eben neulich mal irgendwo gelesen, wie sie zu der komischen Größe gekommen sind. Das kann jetzt ein fieses Gerücht sein, ich weiß es nicht. Aber das Gerücht besagte, dass sie da im Rahmen der Standardisierung, wo sich auch ausnahmsweise Amerikaner mit an den Tisch setzten und die Amerikaner sagten, wir wollen 64 Beit große Zellen. Und die Europäer sagten, wir wollen 32 Beit große Zellen. Und dann haben die ihre ganze Club-Mate weggesoffen, die sie da hatten. Und irgendwann haben sie gesagt, nehmen wir die Mitte, nehmen wir 58. Aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das so war. Aber das ist, wie gesagt, der interessante Teil davon, dass du dadurch eben ein konstantes Zeitverhalten hast. Asynchron übrigens deshalb, weil durch diese Zellaufteilung kannst du eben auch Leute unterschiedlicher Geschwindigkeit miteinander verbinden und unterschiedlichen Clockings. Das heißt, du kannst halt diese Züge aus Zellen, wie ich es immer sage, auf großen rangierbaren Höfen, auf dickere Schienen schicken, zusammen mit anderen Zügen. Das heißt, du kannst halt eben diesen Zellstrom mal irgendwo abkippen auf eine lange Strecke mit ein paar hundert Megabit mehr und dann wieder eben runterziehen auf die einzelnen Anschlussstretteln bis zum Kundenraus. Interessanterweise ist es schön, dass wir es jetzt erwähnt haben, aber eigentlich können wir es vergessen, weil diese Technik funktioniert super toll, gab es auch lange Zeit, aber es ist halt eben verhältnismäßig aufwendig und auch teuer. Und inzwischen hat man halt eben Techniken wie Gigabit Ethernet. Und Gigabit Ethernet ist jetzt, was so Amerikaner gerne Commodity nennen, also was du auch irgendwie in der Drogerie nebenan kaufen kannst, oder im Baumarkt. Bei meiner Landhütte gibt es einen Baumarkt und die haben echt einen Gigabit-Switch. So einen 5-Port-Switch haben sie in ihrer Satelliten- und Haus-Elektronik-Abteilung haben die da zu hängen. Also Gigabit Ethernet ist halt einfach so rein technisch und übertragungstechnisch, was sozusagen relativ günstig zu haben ist und auch billig herzustellen, billig zu verbreiten ist. Und damit hast du eigentlich sozusagen so viel Bandbreite, dass man jetzt gar nicht mehr darauf angewiesen ist, die synchronen Dienste so kleinteilig hinzutun. Weil du hast halt eigentlich immer auch ein Zeitverhalten von dem ganzen Zeugs, was dir halt eben erlaubt, diese synchronen Dienste eben super abzubilden auf dem Gigabit Ethernet.
Braucht halt viele Leitungen, aber meinst du, dass demnächst dann...
Die Leitungen, ATM, gehen dir auch nicht durch Gedanken übertragen. Auch das braucht eine Leitung. Aber irgendwann hast du ja mal irgendeine Switching-Technologie oder irgendwas dazwischen. Und Gigabit Ethernet Switch ist halt eben deutlich billiger, auch im industriellen Maßstab oder auch für die Telekom-Industrie die Chips dafür herzukriegen, als eben ATM-Geschichten.
Was heißt das, dass künftig zwischen der Wohnung und der Vermittlungsstelle tatsächlich Gigabit Ethernet liegen wird?
Ja, wir hatten ja schon erwähnt, dass jetzt die Telekom anfängt, diese KVs auszubauen und aktive Technik einzubauen. Also die Modems, wir können ja mal den Namen des DSLAM, DSL Access Module, glaube ich, heißt das. Dass die sozusagen jetzt auf die Straße wandern.
Nein, Line Access Multiplexer heißt das.
Line Access Multiplexer. Sozusagen das Gegenstück zu deinen Modem. Eigentlich auch ein Modem. Nur halt mehrere in einem Gehäuse. Und dass die jetzt zunehmend nicht mehr per ATM weiter angebunden sind an den Rest des Netzes, an den Backbones, sondern dass die Telekom da eben auf ganz normales, schönes, billiges Gigabit Ethernet setzt.
Wir waren ja jetzt bei diesem normalen DSL. Und wir haben uns gesagt, im Wesentlichen wird jetzt hier einfach dasselbe Kabel genommen, wo Telefon drauf ist und DSL läuft einfach parallel in einem Frequenzbereich. Wird am Ende nochmal so weggesplittet, müsste aber nicht unbedingt. Auf jeden Fall hat man das dann schön auseinanderklammbüsert und dann hat man irgendwie schnelles Internet und seine alte Telefonie unverändert, genauso wie es vorher war, egal ob es analog ist oder ISD-Telefon ist. Jetzt diese DSLams, die sind dann aber erst mit dem nächsten DSL-Schritt erforderlich gewesen.
DSL gab immer einen DSLAM.
Ja, aber der war dann in der Vermittlungsstelle.
Der war in der Vermittlungsstelle, genau. Ist auch bei den meisten Leuten heute immer noch.
Okay, also das ist der Name für das, was auf der anderen Seite ist quasi. Auf meiner Seite das DSL-Modem. Und der spricht mit dem DSLAM.
Der spricht mit dem DSLAM.
Aber der zieht auch jetzt teilweise in diese Kabelverzweiger mit ein.
Dieser DSLAM zieht halt jetzt eben in Kabelverzweiger. Also für Next Generation, also VDSL, ist er da schon, weil er darf halt gar nicht so weit weg sein. Man muss ja überlegen, man geht so üblicherweise von Verbindungslängen aus im Kilometerbereich. Ein 1,5 Kilometer vielleicht, die man durchschnittlich hat von einer Wohnung zur Vermittlungsstelle. DSL, das alte DSL funktioniert überhaupt grundsätzlich, sagen wir mal, so in einem Bereich bis, sagen wir mal, 4, 5 Kilometer oder so. Danach ist halt einfach die Leitungsdämpfung durch diese lange Leitung viel zu hoch, als dass man da noch so ein hochfrequentes Signal dadurch kriegt. Oder ein brauchbares Signal dadurch kriegt. Da gibt es jetzt 2 aller Sachen, was man dagegen tun kann. Man kann irgendwie andere Modulationstechnik benutzen, bessere Modulationstechnik. Man kann mehr von dem Frequenzband benutzen, da kommen wir gleich noch drauf. Das ist wieder das Thema Sturheit in Deutschland. Oder man bringt halt, wie heißt das so schön, wenn der Prophet nicht zum Berg kommt, muss der Berg zum Propheten kommen oder so. Also man bringt halt den DSLAM dichter an den Kunden ran. Indem man ihn nämlich nicht in der Vermittlungsstelle vorhält, sondern indem man ihn halt eben in diesen KV tut. Damit kristet halt eben hin auf jeden Fall die Leitungslänge von dort zum Endgerät beim Kunden zu Hause irgendwie auf vielleicht 800, 900 Meter maximal zu drücken, wenn überhaupt so weit.
Sodass man dann auch schnelles Netz hat. Aber was ist denn dann das Problem, den Dörfern DSL zu geben?
Das Problem ist, dass du da wieder aktive Technik aufbauen musst. Und natürlich findet, hat derjenige, der das Telekommunikationsunternehmen aufbaut, hat natürlich einen gewissen Sockelbetracht, den sie erst mal investieren müssen. Sie müssen nämlich jetzt, wo vorher nur Clemmen waren, also keinen Strom waren, müssen sie jetzt einen Kasten hinbauen, da kriegt eine Stromversorgung. Da will natürlich der örtliche Stromversorger noch mal was für haben. Da ist ein Zähler drin, auch wirklich. Wie so ein kleiner Haushalt wird das Ding versorgt. Dann ist da Stromversorgung, alle was Strom verbraucht, heizt. Da ist natürlich auch wieder Lüfter drin und so weiter und so fort. Dann musst du da aktive Technik einbauen, die kostet was. Das heißt, du musst erst mal einen Sockelbetracht von mehreren tausend Euro investieren, überhaupt mal diesen Kasten da stehen zu haben, mit einer Technik, so hast du noch keine einzelnen Kunden angeschlossen. Und dann ist so ein DSLAM, der hat immer so Portgruppen, in dem rühmten 16er-Schritten. Da schiebst du so eine Baugruppe rein und hast so 16 Ports. Oder 32, 48 oder so. Wie man halt so Ethernet-Switches aufbaut. Und es ist natürlich doof, wenn du ein Dorf hast, das bloß fünf Häuser hat. Und selbst bei 100 Prozent Vermarktungserfolg in diesem Dorf belegst du halt nur fünf von diesen 16 Ports. Du musst aber trotzdem die ganze Karte, du musst die ganze Linecard bezahlen mit allen 16 Ports. Deswegen macht es natürlich, so ein Telekommunikationsunternehmer macht es viel lieber an die Vermittlungsstelle, weil da kommen ein paar Tausend Leute an. Da ist ja die Verteilung der Leute auf die verfügbaren Ports viel besser kontrollierbar, viel besser steuerbar. Du hast halt eben so ein Quantum. Der Quantensprung dort sind halt eben die Ports auf so einer Linecard. Es gibt zwar auch andere Geräte, es gibt sogenannte Micro-Dislams. Das sind wirklich so ganz kleine Dinger, die brauchen ja nicht mal einen Kasten, sondern die kannst du mit an so einen Mast hängen. Auf dem Land wird ja auch gerne nochmal über Masten Kabel verteilt, nicht eingebuddelt. Da kannst du dich oben hinhängen, so haben sie zum Beispiel in Frankreich, in den Niederlanden und auch in Skandinavien sehr viele Leute versorgt, was auch sehr weitläufig ist, mit so Micro-Dislams. Aber irgendwie war da, keine Ahnung, in Deutschland der Telekom auch wieder der Mond zu neu. Ich wüsste nicht, dass so eine Dinge in Deutschland eingesetzt werden. Vielleicht haben sie irgendwo einen Feldversuch oder so.
Oder so Baugruppen, wo nur acht dran sind oder so.
Aber auch dann musst du die ganze Kiste wieder aufbauen. Du musst die ganze Kiste, eine Stromversorgung reinlegen und dann will dein Stromversorger auch wieder eine Grundgebühr für deinen Elektroanschluss haben und so weiter und so fort. Also das ist halt eben ein Aufwand, der sich eben nur ab einer bestimmten Nutzungsrate rechnet.
Ja gut, aber ich meine jetzt ein Dorf mit fünf Häusern, so. Das ist jetzt das Extrem. Wir haben ja auch Kleinstädte, wo Hunderte von Leuten sind, also wo man so einen 16er-Port sicherlich auch voll kriegen würde, die auch nicht angeschlossen sind.
Das ist Politik. Ich kriege jedes Mal Lachanfälle, wenn ich höre von Merkels digitaler Agenda und wir müssen und so. Es ist alles Gerede, was da passiert. Es passieren übrigens auch noch andere Sachen. Ich habe ja jahrelang versucht, in diesem Dorf, wo ich da meine Hütte habe, auch mal andere Leute zu begeistern. Also andere Firmen, die haben zwar auch das selbe Problem, dass sie erstmal so einen Kasten hintun müssen und dafür Geld bezahlen müssen auch. Und dann auch noch die letzten 50 Meter Kupfer von der Telekom mieten müssten. Aber die gehen da nicht hin. Man hat mir dann unter der Hand zu verstehen gegeben, dass sie das deswegen nicht machen, weil in dem Moment, wo sie den Antrag stellen, bei der Telekom an den Kasten ranzuwollen, also wenn so ein, ich sage jetzt mal ein Aqor, das war nicht Aqor, aber wenn jetzt so ein Aqor oder so ein Vodafone jetzt dahin geht, hallo, wir wollen ja jetzt gerne mal einen DSLAM hinbauen und wollen jetzt gerne Zugriff zu den Teilnehmeranschlussleitungen haben, liebe Telekom, pump, stellt die Telekom da selber eine Kiste hin. Und das heißt, du hast dann als Mitbewerber der Telekom, hast du dann natürlich umsonst investiert oder kannst eben das Potential von so einem 100-Leute-Dorf eben nicht ausschöpfen, weil die Telekom baut wieder ihr Ding hin, schreibt natürlich ihre Bestandskunden an, dann sind ja alle Telekom-Kunden da draußen, macht ihr noch mal einen anderen Zweedendeal oder schickt, wie in dem Falle da jetzt passiert, eine wirklich echt so eine Vertriebsblondine rum, die durchs Dorf rennt und überall klingelt und sagt, freuen Sie sich, jetzt gibt es hier DSL von der Telekom. Und deswegen investiert dort keiner mehr. Weil die Telekom nicht unweigerlich mitkriegt, dass sie das tun und dann notfalls eben selber ihr Kästchen ausbaut.
Also Sie investieren auch nicht mal so das Vertriebspotenzial, um festzustellen, wer denn sich jetzt hier als Kunde generieren ließe.
Ja, das war auch relativ einfach, weil der Dorf hat ja auch selber schon Unterschriftenaktionen gemacht und über den Bürgermeistern so. Also wir haben schon ein bisschen Tamm-Tamm dort gemacht, dass die Telekommunikationsfirmen wissen, dass hier irgendwie so breite Leute sitzen.
Ja gut, aber warum hat denn dann die Telekom jetzt keinen Incentive, das einfach selber zu tun in dem Moment?
Das kostet Geld und das ist...
Ja, aber man hat doch dann auch gleich Kunden.
Ja, aber Sie haben doch viel mehr Spaß damit, sich in den großen Städten mit den anderen zu kloppen gegen die anderen Technologien und mit billig angeboten gegen Kabelnetzbetreiber und gegen Alice und Arcor und wie noch immer anzustinken. Es macht doch viel mehr Spaß als Kunden, die man ohnehin sicher hat. Die kann man ja immer noch irgendwann abernten, weil es kriegt es ja kein anderer. Es gibt jetzt einen Hintergrund, warum wir das jetzt machen, weil es ist der Telekom, haben die sich überlegt, wir schalten jetzt mal mittelfristig ein bisschen was von unserer alten Telefontechnologie ab, weil die Wartungskosten und die Betriebskosten von dem Zeug gehen jetzt langsam deutlich in die Höhe. An den eigentlichen Anschlüssen bzw. an den Gesprächen kannst du nichts mehr verdienen. Überleg mal, fast jeder hat heute eine Festnetz-Flatrate. Und wenn nicht, dann hast du Gespräche um die halbe Welt für 0,6 Cent pro Minute. Also daran verdienst du nicht mehr das große Geld. Demgegenüber stehen jetzt natürlich die Betriebskosten für so eine gute alte Vermittlungsstelle. Die Analogen gibt es ja nicht mehr, aber selbst wenn du so eine digitale Vermittlungsstelle hast mit so einer EWSD da drin, das ist eine ordentliche Heizung. Das frisst Strom und da sind Baugruppen drin, uralte Baugruppen, die es nur gibt, von Siemens oder Ericsson oder wem auch immer, was man da jetzt verbaut hat, wo die Leute schon längst in Rente sind, die die Firmware dafür geschrieben haben. Das ist auch ein Thema, das zunehmend schwerer warten lässt. Und dann wollen sie auch gerne loswerden. Und deren Weg dahingehend ist es, per Voice-over IP zu machen, was ja auch schlau ist, aber dafür brauchst du IP. Da musst du halt eben hingehen und den Leuten jetzt wirklich mal IP vor die Füße legen.
Also du meinst, jetzt ist eigentlich der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo diese technologische Ablösung jetzt von alleine passiert?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das offiziell irgendwo hingeschrieben gibt oder als offizielle Statement von irgendwelchen Ministerien, aber das ISDN-Netz wird, glaube ich, nur noch bis 2014 vermarktet. Dann haben die noch ein bisschen Bestandschutz, die Anschlüsse, die da drauf sind oder so was. Aber du kannst nach 2014 keinen ISDN-Anschluss mehr beantragen. Wird ja auch darüber diskutiert, das eben aus dieser Universaldienstleistung eben rauszunehmen. Hatte ich ja vorhin erwähnt, diese Verpflichtung, dass man das überall hin liefern muss auf deutschem Hoatzibid.
Ohne, dass das Internet selbst jetzt schon in der Universaldienstleistung drin wäre. Also die Universaldienstleistung fällt eigentlich weg, wenn sie das nicht findet.
Ja, es wird kommen. Es war jetzt am Ende wirklich nur noch die FDP. Na ja, nach der nächsten Bundestagswahl hat sich das auch erledigt. Und die restlichen Parteien waren sich eigentlich schon darauf einig, dass das kommen muss. Es muss auch kommen. Es muss halt die Versorgungspflicht haben. Und wenn sie das andere alles abbauen, das analoge und das DSDN-Netz.
Das hätte auch schon vor zehn Jahren eigentlich kommen müssen. Aber das hat natürlich China begriffen, das ist ja logisch.
Na hier nicht, in anderen Ländern schon.
So, jetzt um nochmal diese ganze DSL-Entwicklung mitzubekommen. Also DSL, wie nennt man das? Das erste DSL nennt man jetzt DSL-1, das nennt man einfach nur DSL. Und dann gab es DSL-2.
ADSL-1, ADSL-2. Das ist das, was wir jetzt kennen, was die Leute sozusagen zu Hause haben.
Was war der Unterschied jetzt von dem 1 zu 2? Einfach nur anderes Frequenzband?
Ich glaube, ADSL-2 gibt es bei uns in Deutschland gar nicht. Es gibt nur ADSL-2 Plus. Und man hat dort andere Modulationstechniken eingesetzt. Man hat die verfügbare Bandbreite auf dem Kupferkabel nochmal verdoppelt. Wie gesagt, da ist halt die obere Grenzfrequenz dann bei 2,2 MHz. Das bringt zwar auf den langen Leitungen nicht so viel, aber es bringt zumindest bei den kurzen Leitungen in der Stadt, bringt es dir halt eben eine ganze Menge. Du kriegst bei den üblichen kurzen Verbindungen, die du hier hast, eine rohe Rate von 25 Megabit bis zu 25 Megabit, kannst du damit machen, von denen die meisten Anbieter nur 16 durchreichen. Das ist für uns ein sehr interessantes Thema. Die Differenz zwischen dem, was geht, was technisch möglich ist und was wirklich angeboten wird, ist teilweise horrend. Da kommen wir zu einem sehr fiesen Thema.
Es gibt verschiedene Mysterien bei DSL. Wie zwanghaft ist eigentlich diese Asymmetrie in dem ganzen Spiel? Der Unterschied zwischen dem Upstream und dem Downstream ist ja enorm. Bei VDSL hat sich das jetzt ein bisschen relativiert. Ist diese ganze Modulationstechnik so festgebrannt, dass das eben gar nicht anders geht, dass man die hohen Geschwindigkeiten im Downstream nur deswegen erreicht, weil der Upstream so niedrig ist und man könnte das gar nicht anders nivellieren? Oder anders gefragt, könnte man sogar mit der existierenden Technologie einen einzelnen Port auch anders konfigurieren, dass man sagt, der kriegt jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr ab und beim Downen müsste man noch ein bisschen was wegnehmen?
Nein, man kann sich auch umpolen, wenn du willst. Rein technisch gesehen kannst du auch sagen, wir machen jetzt 16 Megabit Uplink und 1 Megabit Downlink. Really? Ja, das sind vom Prinzip dieselben Chips in der Vermittlungsstelle wie hier. Was dem zugrunde liegt, es gibt halt eben, sagen wir mal so, was diese Bandbreitengeschichte angeht, gibt es halt mehrere Faktoren. Erstmal, was stelle ich auf der analogen Strecke zur Verfügung? Da kommen wir jetzt zu dem Thema der deutschen Sturheit. Als Platzhirsch und vor allen Dingen auch als Besitzer der meisten, allermeisten Teilnehmeranschlussleitung hat die Telekom da mal so ein paar Sachen ausgerufen, hat gesagt, wir betreiben in Deutschland nur ADSL nach dem Standard Q9921 oder Punkt 2 Annex B. Das heißt, wir lassen mal bitte schön alle Frequenzen unterhalb dieser 138 Kilohertz oder so, darunter lassen wir mal in Ruhe, egal ob die gebraucht werden oder nicht. Das heißt, was man gesagt hat, es gibt auch einen Hintergrund dafür.
Also das, was freigehalten ist für das alte Telefon.
Das, was freigehalten ist. Aber wie ich ja vorhin schon sagte, das alte Telefonnetz braucht eigentlich, ein analoge Anschluss braucht eigentlich nur die Bandbreite bis 3,4 Kilohertz. Das heißt, in diesem unteren Frequenzbereich, der übrigens besonders gut geeignet ist, weitere Strecken zu realisieren, liegt sozusagen eine politische Sperre drauf. Und zwar ist das, ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, je höher die Frequenz und je länger die Leitung, desto stärker die Dämpfung. Das heißt, je niedriger die Frequenz ist, desto weiter könntest du damit kommen. Aber es gibt halt da diese politische Sperre drauf, weil der Hintergrund war der, dass man sich gesagt hat, wir wollen alle Leute gleich behandeln, egal ob es einen analogen oder einen ISTN-Anschluss haben. Wir wollen also sozusagen nicht Leute auch noch dafür belohnen, dass sie keinen ISTN-Anschluss haben, also dass sie einen analogen Anschluss haben, indem wir ihnen mehr Bandbreite geben. Es hat auch logistische Vorteile, weil es betrifft ja, wie gesagt, diese Grenzfrequenz ist ja ein wichtiger Faktor, weil es ein Splitter ist, der sozusagen die Frequenzweiche darstellt. Du müsstest sozusagen in Deutschland, wenn du das anders machen würdest, müsstest du zweierlei Splitter verteilen, nämlich einmal einen Splitter für einen analogen Anschluss und einmal einen Splitter für einen ISTN-Anschluss. Das hat man aus logistischen Gründen nicht machen wollen. Und eben auch aus dem politischen Grund heraus, dass man Leute sozusagen nicht noch dafür belohnen wollte, eine alte Technik, nämlich einen analogen Telefonanschluss, zu benutzen. Da hat man gesagt, wir reservieren immer den ganzen Frequenzbereich unten, wo sozusagen ein ISTN-Signal reinpassen könnte, auch wenn der Kunde gar kein ISTN hat. Und damit schießen sich insgesamt Bandbreite und natürlich auch...
Wie viel Bandbreite ist denn nötig für ISTN?
Also, wie sagt der, sind eigentlich... Der ISTN-Signal hat so etwas von 120 Kilohertz oder so was, braucht das eigentlich. Dann hat man noch so ein bisschen Schutzzone. 125, ich weiß es nicht genau, aber so in dem Dreh 120, 125 Kilohertz. Und deswegen hat man da eben noch ein bisschen Schutzzone. Deswegen fängt DSL in Deutschland eben erst nördlich davon an. Das ist in anderen Ländern nicht so. Da wird auch ein Mischbetrieb gemacht. Also, das kann man auch tun. Kannst du dir nach Schweiz zum Beispiel angucken oder in Schweden. Da machen sie das nämlich so. Und da nehmen sie natürlich dann auch an analogen Anschlüssen ein viel breiteres Spektrum. Beziehungsweise es gibt ja dann auch diese entbündelten Anschlüsse.
Wo gar kein Telefon mehr dabei ist.
Wo gar kein Telefon mehr drauf ist, wo auf der Kopfarstrippe nur noch DSL drauf ist. Oder vom Prinzip eigentlich von 0 Hz bis 2,5 MHz oder so was. Das gesamte Spektrum zur Verfügung hättest. Wo man natürlich, wie gesagt, gerade was Reichweite angeht, noch mit viel längeren Leitungen klarkommen würde und eben auch mehr Bits auf diesen langen Leitungen transportieren könnte. Das geht. Das machen einem die Schweizer vor und die Schweden, dass man sowas einfach machen kann.
Was erzielen die dann? Was für eine Verbesserung stellt das dann effektiv dar? Selbe Geschwindigkeit wie viel weiter?
Selbe Geschwindigkeit weiter oder im Nahbereich. Die bieten auch wirklich die 25 Megabit an, was hier in Deutschland gar nicht gemacht wird. Es ist ja in Deutschland eh so, dass wenn du einen Anschluss hast, wo du auf der Vermittlungsstelle wohnst oder gegenüber, oder wo du einen Outdoor-Deslam hast im KV, der auf der Straße gegenüber steht, dann hast du rohe 25 Megabit. Ja, das sagt dir so ein DSL-Modem, wenn du eins hast, was dir das verrät, zum Beispiel eine Fritz-Box. Das ist das Nightmare jeder Telekommunikationsgesellschaft, diese Fritz-Boxen, die hassen diese Dinger. Weil die Kunden klicken immer alle drauf, und die Fritz-Box sagt ihnen ja, also ich habe hier mal gemessen, deine Leitung gibt 25 Megabit her, aber dein Provider gibt dir bloß 6. Als nächstes hast du den Hörer an der Hand und schimpfst deinen Provider an und sagst, sag mal hallo, geht es noch? Ich habe sogar Extreme erlebt, letztes Jahr habe ich mal für jemanden was gemacht auf Usedom, auch dort ist Telekom wieder Platzhirsch. Da hat die Telekom gesagt, also mehr als ein Megabit können wir ihnen nicht liefern. Und die Fritz-Box hat 18 ausgemessen. Es ist also wirklich schon, es ist ein echtes Ärgernis. Diese Ausmessreihe machen alle Modems. Die Fritz-Box und ich weiß nicht vielleicht auch ein, zwei andere, die sind halt so nett, die zeigen dir das über die Oberfläche an. Da siehst du genau die Verteilung des Frequenzspektrums. Die rechnen dir genau vor, wie viele Bits da eigentlich gehen. Und sie schreiben auch genau hin, wie viele Bits dir dein Provider wirklich gibt davon. Das ist natürlich schon ein großes politisches Ärgernis für die Leute. Ich liebe das sehr.
Das heißt, um es zusammenzufassen mit dem ADSL 2+, was hier in Deutschland gefahren wird, falls man sagen würde, ich brauche jetzt hier nicht noch Telefon, weil ich habe sowieso Mobilfunk und Flatrate und tralala und zweites Telefon, alles Quatsch. Und wenn ich es brauche, dann mache ich Voice-over-IP und weg mich. Lass es doch einfach weg. Gib mir die volle Frequenzbandbreite und so weiter. Dann könnte ich darüber theoretisch und praktisch auch 25 Megabit downstream kriegen.
Und weiter als jetzt.
Und noch weiter als jetzt. Und die 16, die sie mir sowieso nur geben wollen, sogar noch sehr viel weiter. Kannst du das irgendwie quantifizieren, von wie viel weiter wir jetzt reden? Reden wir jetzt noch von ein paar hundert Metern? Oder verdoppelt sich da irgendwas?
Ja, verdoppelt nicht. Aber du kannst bestimmt noch mal ein, zwei Kilometer rausholen. Momentan ist, denke ich mal, so mit einer ganz guten Entfernung, wo es noch einigermaßen geht, wo du noch so 10, 11, 12 Megabit rauskriegst, sind so drei, dreieinhalb Kilometer. Wenn du die mit einem kompletten Frequenzspektrum fahren könntest, dann, denke ich, würdest du sicherlich auch wieder die 16, 18 hinkriegen. Also du kriegst jetzt die 25 Megabit nicht dann irgendwie 6, 7, 8 Kilometer weg. Sagen wir mal so, es ist interessant in der Masse, du kannst halt mehr Leute mit Mehrbit versorgen.
Ja, und vor allem, man könnte ja das ja auch so tarifieren, dass man sagt, man zahlt einfach für jedes Megabit, was erzielt wird, zahlt man halt einfach Geld. Also ich meine, wenn ich jetzt so den normalen 16 Megabit-Tarif einfach mal durch 16 Teile und dann wiederum mal...
Mal Geld.
Mal was, was dann wirklich da ist.
Ja, ich meine, da ist jetzt...
Also technisch denkbar wäre das?
Technisch ist es denkbar. Ich denke, das wäre politisch nicht so durchsetzbar, weil du dann sozusagen randommäßig Leute dafür bestraft, wie weit sie von deiner Vermittlungsstelle wegwohnen, oftet sie ja eigentlich keinen Einfluss haben. Das ist ja jetzt nicht ein Leistungsmerkmal, wo du dir sagst, ich möchte dir mehr nicht leisten.
Sie würden ja für dieselbe Geschwindigkeit auch dasselbe zahlen. Und wenn sie mehr kriegen können, dann zahlen sie auch mehr.
Du meinst, dass die Leute jetzt weniger zahlen, die dadurch angepisst sind, dass sie eben weit von der Vermittlungsstelle wegwohnen.
Ja, wenn du nur 6 Megabit kriegst und kannst, dann kriegst du halt auch nur 6 Megabit. Du zahlst aber auch nur die 6, was dann halt entsprechend weniger ist als die 16 etc. Ich meine, wie man es konkret staffelt, ist noch mal eine andere Frage. Aber denkbar wäre es ja so. Die Telekom würde ja sozusagen auch einen Plus haben davon. Oder jeder Anbieter würde ja einen Plus haben davon.
Darum geht es dann nicht. Das hat ja wieder was mit Logik zu tun. Die Telekom macht ja auch noch Sachen. Da muss man dazu sagen.
Die Upload-Seite. Im Prinzip könnte man das auch umdrehen. Also es wäre jetzt auch vorstellbar, dass ich quasi so ein Admin-Interface bekomme und sage, ich würde jetzt gerne meinen, aber mal so betreiben, dass ich jetzt...
Das ist politisch nicht vorstellbar, aber technisch ist es.
Ja, aber wenn ich es jetzt symmetrisch mache, heißt das wirklich, dass ich ein 16-1er auch in einem 8-8 oder 7-7 fahren könnte?
Es ist so, dass diese Aufteilung in Up- und Downstream basiert auf sogenannten Profilen. Da gibt es halt mehrere Dutzend von. Die sind alle schön durchnummeriert, mit irgendwelchen Buchstaben dran.
Jetzt im DSL-Standard.
In den DSL-Standard? Eigentlich durch alle durch. Das fing an mit ADSL. In ADSL 2 wurden die dann erweitert. ADSL 2 Plus bis hin VDSL, VDSL 2. Da gibt es immer diese Profile, die das Konfigurieren dieses DSLAMs, dieses Modems in der Vermittlungsstelle oder im KV ermöglichen. Dass der Netzbetreiber sagt, ich möchte dich gerne so betreiben. Da wird die Bitrate nicht exakt vorgegeben, sondern da wird gesagt, welche Frequenzbereiche nutzen wir aus für Up und welche für Downlink. Wenn man sich das anguckt, wie sich das im Spektrum darstellt, bei dem normalen ADSL oder ADSL2-Signal, wo wir sozusagen anfangen, ist es so, dass oberhalb dieser Grenzfrequenz, wo wir sozusagen anfangen, also oberhalb dieser 138 Kilohertz, kommt erst mal ein Stückchen Upstream. Das ist der Teil der Frequenzbereiche, wo du sendest mit dein Modem Richtung Vermittlungsstelle. Dann kommt eine kleine Lücke und dann kommt der Rest sozusagen bis hinten, wo es nicht mehr geht, wird sozusagen aufgefüllt mit Downstream. Und diese Linie kannst du vom Prinzip durch Wahl eines Profils hin und her schieben. Es ist sogar so, im VDSL wird es sogar so gemacht, da sind diese Dinger sogar verwoben ineinander. Das heißt, da kommt ein Stück Frequenzband, da ist Upstream, dann kommt Downstream, dann wieder Upstream, dann wieder Downstream. Das wird so 3-4 Mal gemacht. So wird das Signal sozusagen ein bisschen verteilt auf die verfügbare Bandbreite. Und du kannst auch Profile nehmen, die symmetrisch sind oder eben andersrum. Das geht auch. Die gibt es, die sind auch in dem Equipment drin, aber die konfiguriert keiner.
Und wenn ich jetzt bei so einem anderen Provider, es gibt ja so ein paar, die bieten ja tatsächlich symmetrisches DSL an, SDSL. Das heißt, das ist dann auch eigentlich nichts anderes als das normale ADSL mit so einem Synchronprofil? Oder ist das dann nochmal eine andere Technik?
Ja, es ist ja nicht asynchron, sondern symmetrisch. Also mit einem symmetrischen Profil, ja. Das kannst du so machen, ne? Es gibt übrigens sehr viele Technologien.
Kann man so machen oder ist so?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die das so anbieten oder was die für Hintergründe haben, warum sie das so nicht machen. Es gibt ja Technologien, die...
Ich meine, die Provider, die SDSL explizit anbieten, die verwenden auch die normale ADSL-Technologie bloß mit einem anderen Profil.
Ich vermute, die benutzen VDSL, VDSL 1 oder vielleicht auch schon VDSL 2 mit symmetrischen Profilen.
Also es ist eigentlich technisch derselbe Kram?
Es ist derselbe Kram. Und nochmal, das Modem, was du hier drin hast, kann durchaus sein... Da sind ja noch analoge Baugruppen dazu. Da hast du ja nicht bloß den Chip drin, sondern hast ja auch noch ein paar analoge Bauteile drin, so ein paar Filter. Das kann also durchaus sein, dass das übliche billige Scheng, Shang, Chong, DSL Modem aus Taiwan oder so weiter, von seinen analogen Komponenten her, filtertechnisch, nicht in der Lage ist, dass du jetzt, sagen wir mal, über einen bestimmten Bereich hinaus senden kannst. Aber rein von den Chips her und von den Standards her kannst du das machen. Du kannst diese Linie hin und her schieben, nicht beliebig, sondern in irgendwelchen Quanten, nämlich durch diese Profile definiert, aber da gibt es auch symmetrische Profile. Ich weiß das, weil ich habe nämlich mal was gebastelt mit so genannten Long-Reach Ethernet. So nennt es Cisco. Vom Prinzip ist das ein Ethernet-Switch, der hat Ports dran, wo VDSL1 drauf ist. Das ist sozusagen für eine Hausverteilung, wenn du Ethernet auf einem Firmengelände verteilen willst, wo du nur alte Telefon-Kupferleitungen hast. Und da sieht man diese Profile und kann sie einstellen. Dann habe ich es zu teufel gemacht, dass ich eben Profile eingestellt habe, 5.5 zum Beispiel, 5 Megabit down, 5 Megabit up oder so. Da kann man die hin- und herschieben. Und Long-Range-Ethernet ist VDSL1. Das ist das selbe Zeug, das auch die Telekons in ihren Vermittlungsstellen benutzen. Also diese Profile gibt es. Man könnte sich auch überlegen, wenn du Kupfer am Boden hast, hast du meistens nicht nur dieses eine Adanpaar. Theoretisch kannst du auch hingehen und sagen, wir machen das so, wir benutzen zwei Adanpaare. Wir benutzen eins für den Downstream. Wir hauen das richtig voll, die gesamte Bandbreite, die das Ding hergibt, nur mit Downstream. Und das andere Ding knallen wir voll mit Uplink.
Dann hätte ich 25 Megabit Synchron.
Mehr sogar. Dann wirst du wahrscheinlich 30, 30 oder so was hinkriegen. Auf zwei Doppeladern oder so.
Weil sich dann nichts mehr aufteilt, ich keine Sicherheitsräume brauche etc. einfach gib ihm.
Theoretisch ist das denkbar. Es ist wie gesagt, es ist ein administrativer Ding. Es gibt sehr, sehr viele Technologien, wir könnten jetzt noch weit abschweifen. Naja, gib dir mal ein Beispiel. Die berühmte Diskussion über IPv6. Ich mach selber sehr viel IPv6. Ich mach auch IPv6 über DSL, aber bin sozusagen mein eigener Provider dort. Warum machen es die großen Telcos nicht? Nicht weil ihre Router das nicht können oder ihr Backboard nicht kann, sondern ich vermute einfach deswegen, weil dieses ganze Graffel, was drum herum ist. Ihre Hotline kann das nicht, die verstehen ja nicht mal IPv4. Geschweige denn IPv6. Ihre Abhörschnittstellen können das nicht, ihre Vorratsdatenhaltung kann das nicht, ihre watwissig kann das nicht. Aber es geht nicht darum, dass sie selber keinen IPv6 in ihrem Netz ertragen könnten oder so was. Das geht, ich kann es dir vormachen und kann es dir auf dem normalen DSL-Anschluss von der Telekom oder VDSL-Anschluss kann ich dir V6 anknipsen. Aber es ist die ganzen Prozeduren drum herum, die Verwaltung, die Zuordnung von Adressen, was auch immer. Du kannst mir das anknipsen?
Kannst du mir das auch anknipsen? Das kann man machen. Da geht was, kann ich dir das zeigen.
Aber es ist der interessante Teil daran, dass man versucht, dadurch, dass das Produkt billig ist, am Ende des Tages versucht man, das so weit wie möglich zu standardisieren. Wobei jetzt, witzigerweise, gerade die Telekom als Einzeiganbieter in Deutschland immer wieder selber gerne den Fuß schießt, nämlich durch eine feste Bandbreitenberechnung. Das machen sie immer wieder noch gerne. Bei den alten ADSL-Anschlüssen, die sie nicht mit Outdoor-DESLAMPS machen, berechnet die Telekom vorher, bevor sie dir den Anschluss schaltet, aufgrund der Aktienlage, wie viel Bits du da rauskriegst. Die haben hier ihren Netzplan, wissen, aha, da hat jemand im Jahr 1982 mal ein Stück Kupferkabel mit 0,4 Quadratmillimeter Querschnitt vergraben, und das ist so und so lang, und das geht zu dem KV, und dann geht es von da mit dem Kabel weiter, und dann rechnen die aus, was da für Bits drauf kommen. Und dieser Algorithmus ist schlicht und ergreifend kaputt. Der ist einfach, hat so viele Leute schon aufgeregt, weil du stellst einen Anschluss, und mit 16 Megabit Anschluss, und die kommen und sagten, ne, bei ihnen gehen bloß einer. Dann sagst du, Zähne knirschen, na gut, gib her das Ding, hängst deine Fritzbox dran, und die Fritzbox sagt, ja, ich messe 18 Megabit, aber dein Provider gibt dir bloß einen. Und wie gesagt, wenn du mit solchen Leuten zu tun hast, dann brauchen wir jetzt nicht darüber zu diskutieren, dass du jetzt gerne ein anderes Profil haben möchtest, ein symmetrisches oder sowas. Das kannst du ja haben, aber dann bist du halt Business-Kunde. Kommst du auf ein Business-DiS-Land, da kriegst du einen SDSL-Anschluss, da ist es so konfiguriert, dann kostet sich aber der Anschluss eben auch nicht 20 Euro im Monat oder 30, sondern 200, so einfach ist das.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, dafür hat uns der Herrgott den Shitstorm und den Massenaufstand gegeben. Ich meine, da ist ja einfach mal hier so ein telekomatischer Frühling wahrscheinlich nötig. Und dann einfach mal Änderungen erweist.
Die ertragen den schon so lange und die sind so schmerzbefreit. Ich meine, diese Situation gibt es ja schon lange. Der Shitstorm ist halt immer auch ein bisschen abgeflacht, weil in den großen Städten, wo sie halt eben mit vielen anderen konkurrieren, haben die Leute halt schon vor vielen, vielen Jahren gesagt, fuck you, ich gehe halt zum Kabeldeutschland, ARKOR, Alice, you name it. Du hast halt eben genügend Alternativen.
Die wollen wir auch gleich noch mal technisch abklopfen. Kurz um bei DSL zu bleiben. Organisatorisch meinst du oder technisch?
Ja, es gibt da noch ein paar Sachen. Manche benutzen auch das Netz der Telekom mit. Was übrigens witzig ist, weil die Kunden dann meistens bessere Dienstmerkmale haben als die Telekom-Kunden selber. Aber manche haben auch eigene Technik. Das steht einfach dasselbe. In den großen Städten wie in Berlin steht in der Vermittlungsstelle neben dem DSLAM von der Telekom steht einer von Alice, also Telefonica, einer von Acor, also Vodafone, und wahrscheinlich hier noch von QSC oder welchen kleineren Providern. Die stehen da brav nebeneinander, bzw. sie stehen in sogenannten Co-Location-Räumen. Das gibt es in jeder Vermittlungsstelle. Mit dem Fall des offiziellen Telekom-Monopols wurde die Telekom auch verpflichtet, Zugang zu diesen Basisdingen zu geben, wie eben der Teil im Anschlussleitung. Und um das möglich zu machen, da du ja aktives Equipment dort brauchst, wurden dann in den Häusern, wo die Vermittlungsstellen sind, so nette Co-Lokationsräume eingerichtet. Hier in so einer Stadt wie Berlin hast du die Vermittlungsstelle, das ist so ein Haus, das steht im Broom. Und da gibt's eben Räume, kleine Räume, da ist Stromversorgung drin, Klima und so weiter und so fort, ein Türenschlüssel. Und diesen Schlüssel hat nur jemand von AQUA oder Vodafone oder Telefonica oder wie auch immer. Dann haben die da ihr Equipment drin, da gibt's so Leisten, so Kontaktleisten, die durchgeführt werden zum HVT, dieser berühmte Hauptverteiler. Und wenn also jetzt ein AQUA-Kunde so einen Dienst kriegt, dann beantragt halt eben der AQUA oder der Bodo-Fun, wie sie heute heißen, bei der Telekom eben diese Schaltung in diesen Kollokationsraum rein. Das heißt, die Kupferleitung, die ankommt vom Kunden am HVT, wird dann durchgeschaltet in diesen Raum und dann geht sie dann auf das Equipment drauf. Das ist natürlich bei den vorhin erwähnten 5.300 Vermittlungsstellen, die wir in Deutschland haben, natürlich auch ein tierischer Aufwand, wenn jetzt jeder Provider überall hingehen würde und jeder dieser Dinger dort versehen würde mit eigener Technik, die man ja untereinander auch noch verbinden muss, was ja auch noch kostet. Deswegen gab es da schon eine gewisse Konzentration. Es gibt da so Firmen wie z.B. Telefonica, die noch bevor sie den LS und den O2 und so weiter alle zusammen gekauft haben, schon diese Technik dort bereitgestellt haben, aber die nicht an Endkunden verkauft haben. Das heißt, die waren immer so ein Provider-Provider. Da konntest du halt eben hingehen als, ich weiß nicht, ob Friedet das gemacht hat, aber es gab ja diese Versen-Provider, die eben gesagt haben, ich brauche hier mal einen DSL-Anschluss für einen Kunden in kleinen Kuhkakerode, sagte der Telefoniker, ja, da haben wir einen DSL-Anschluss zu stehen, dann konntest du dir dort einen Port mieten.
Das heißt, Telefonika war quasi Untermieter bei der Telekom, die auf den Kabeln sitzt, und du konntest aber dann eben noch mal so als virtueller DSL-Dienstleister dich bei Telefonika einkaufen und dir dann sozusagen da was kaufen. So wie es ja die Telekom auch macht.
Genau.
Gibt ja auch so was wie 1&1 und so weiter, keine eigene Infrastruktur, sondern die benutzen einfach nur die Telekom-Infrastruktur.
Nicht nur, die benutzen auch Telefonika, die benutzen Kreuz und Queralt, die gucken halt, wer wo verfügbar ist. Genau, das stellt sich aber für den Kunden wie ein Netz oder ein Produkt dar. Also da gibt es auch diese Übergabeschnittstellen auf unterschiedlicher Ebene. Manche zum Beispiel 1&1 benutzt teilweise sogar den IP-Backbone von der Telekom mit. Das heißt, die kaufen nicht nur sozusagen den Zugang zur Teilnehmeranschlussleitung mit einem DSLAM-Port dran, sondern auch sagen, mach doch da mal IP drauf, liebe Telekom. Und treten sozusagen nur als Reseller in dem Sinne auf. Das machen sie aber nicht überall. Das hängt wie gesagt davon ab, ob das ADSL ist oder ob das VDSL ist und ob du noch irgendwelche anderen Dienstleistungen mit dazu hast. Also noch Telefongeschichten, normal, analog oder ISDN mit drauf. Da gibt es also ein ziemliches Wirrwarr und Hin- und Her und Verrechnungen und tralala und Pipapo.
VDSL ist jetzt quasi so das aktuelle, was man so bekommen kann. Das beste Netz eigentlich. VDSL und VDSL 2.
Es gibt hier nur VDSL 2. VDSL 1 wurde in Deutschland nie deployed. Aber VDSL ist das, was wir hier haben, was du hier auch hast, VDSL 2.
Das fängt ja dann bei 25 Megabit an. Ich meine, das ist ja lustig. Hätte ich auch mit dem normalen DSL haben können. Vielleicht sogar auch tatsächlich hier ganz real. Trotzdem nimmt man da jetzt eine andere Technik. Was ist denn bei VDSL?
Die Technik ist dieselbe. Nur du bringst sie dichter an den Kunden und erweiterst das Frequenzspektron noch mal nach oben. Das heißt, du schiebst es noch dichter an den Kunden ran und gehst nicht nur bis 2,2 Mhz, sondern ich müsste jetzt wirklich nachgucken. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht noch mal bis 4 oder 5. Ich weiß nicht, wo die Obergrenzfrequenz ist. Kann man noch mal nachgucken. Und schiebst es noch dichter an den Kunden ran.
Das heißt, bei VDSL ist es quasi erforderlich, dass dieser DSL in den KV kommt.
Oder wenn du witzigerweise ziemlich dicht an deiner Vermittlungsstelle wohnst, dann gibt es auch da Kunden, aber die wären nicht weiter als einen Kilometer weg. Also wenn du weiter als einen Kilometer oder 1,1 oder 1,3 Kilometer wegwohnst von deiner Vermittlungsstelle, dann kannst du, wenn du innerhalb dieses Radios lebst, dann steht das Ding sozusagen auch mit in der Vermittlungsstelle. Weil dann ist sozusagen in manchen Situationen ist dein KV auch faktisch in der Vermittlungsstelle.
Rein technologisch, protokolltechnisch ist das eigentlich dasselbe in grün.
Ist dasselbe in grün nur breiter. Also noch mal frequenzmäßig wieder breiter. Mit, wie gesagt, teilweise etwas komplexeren Profilen, wo man also ab und downlink auf den Frequenzbindern mischt. Also nicht total so unten Uplink, oben Downlink, sondern immer mal so als Versetzter, je nachdem wie man es haben will.
Aber trotzdem ist dieser Telefon- und ISDN-Bereich immer noch nicht dabei.
Den haben sie dann mit rausgenommen. Auf dem VDSL-Anschluss, ich glaube in Deutschland. Also auf jeden Fall nicht diese hohe Grenzfrequenz benutzt, sondern der ist unten mit raus.
Das heißt, ein VDSL-Splitter ist auch tatsächlich anders als ein normaler?
Ein VDSL, lass mich mal kurz überlegen.
Ist sogar noch denselben Splitter. Nee, ich glaube, ich habe den Splitter gar nicht geändert.
Du hattest vorher auf dem Anschluss hier auch einen ADSL drauf.
Ja, und ich glaube, ich benutze nach wie vor denselben.
Der ist ja nach oben auf. Das ist ja ein Hochpass und ein Tiefpass. Der ist ja nach oben hinauf. Die neueren, die ersten, die sie hatten, die hatten auch oben noch einen Cap, weil sie dann Angst hatten, das gibt ja so irgendwelche komischen Interferenzen mit irgendeinem kleinen Frequenzband, was Amateur-Funker benutzen, wo sie am Anfang Angst hatten, wenn wir jetzt in ganz Deutschland irgendwie DSL anknipsen, dann fangen plötzlich ein paar Amateure an, Tränen in den Augen zu kriegen. Aber das war dann wohl doch nicht so. Dann haben sie gesagt, Scheiß drauf, weiß ich nicht. Die Dinger sind nach oben offen. Aber wir können es gleich noch mal anschauen. Du hast ja eine Fritzbox. Da sieht man auch genau das Spektrum, wo was wie benutzt wird. Auch wie viele Bits da liegen. Das ist ja das Spannende an dieser DMT-Technik, die ADSL benutzt. Das sollte man vielleicht auch noch mal erwähnen. Das Gesamte zur Verfügung stehende Frequenzband wird aufgeteilt in Kanäle. Die sind so ungefähr 4 Kilohertz breit. Und in diese Kanäle, die werden einzeln durchgemessen. Wenn man so ein DSL-Modem anmacht, dann geht es in einen Zustand, den nennt sich Training. Da sieht man immer, dass die meisten DSL-Modems blinken. Das heißt, man kann sie noch nicht benutzen, aber sie unterhalten sich schon mit der Vermittlungsstelle. In dieser Phase probieren sie sozusagen für jeden dieser Kanäle, das sind so bei VDSL oder Nibir, bei ADIS-L2+, glaube ich, sind das 512 Kanäle, bei VDSL sogar noch mehr, probieren die aus in Zusammenarbeit mit der Vermittlungsstelle, was geht hier, wie gut ist diese Leitung?
Also so ein automatisches Durchmessen.
Ja, die messen das richtig aus. Und sagen jetzt, okay, in diesem Frequenzband können wir halt auf diesen 4,0 Quitsch-Kilohertz-Kanal so und so viele Bits reinstopfen. Und da habe ich irgendwie ein Störsignal, den benutzen wir gar nicht. Aber weiter oben ist wieder toll, da haue ich dann richtig meine 8 Bits oder so etwas rein in den Kanal. Und so sammelt sich das zusammen. Das ist jetzt auch der Punkt, was ich vorhin schon sagte, dass halt eben diese DSL-Modems, die eben anzeigen, was die Leitung wirklich hergibt. Das ist ein echtes Messprotokoll oder Ergebnis eines Messvorgangs, den das Modem mit dem echten Modem in der Vermittlungsstelle zusammen erstellt hat.
Ich bin schon ganz frustriert, weil ich habe gerade den Punkt entdeckt, wo steht Leitungskapazität. Das ist wahrscheinlich das, was du meinst.
Ja, und was steht da bei dir?
99.840.
Und was gibt es?
Und der Upload, na 51.000. Also ich kriege die Hälfte von dem, was ich könnte, sowohl hin als auch zurück. Ich könnte 20 Megabit Uplink haben.
Und da ginge sogar noch mehr. Wenn du mit der selben Technik, wenn du vielleicht auch noch die vorhin erwähnten 4-Drähte benutzt, statt 2 kannst du halt eben auch schön Spaß haben. Du kannst richtig 200 Megabit machen.
Aber 4-Drähte würde ja de facto bedeuten, dass die Kapazität in der Erde halbiert wird.
Ja, aber wir haben zu viel davon. Wie wir haben zu viel? Was heißt zu viel? Wir haben jedenfalls mehr, als man so denkt. Es liegt auch daran, dass zum Beispiel selbst in einem einzelnen Hausanschluss die Bundespost oder die Telekom, wir reden jetzt von Kupfer, wir reden nicht von alten, alten, stoffumwickelten Aluleitungen oder sowas, aber wir reden jetzt von Kupfer, das, was seit den 70er Jahren gelegt wurde in Deutschland. Da gab es nie nur einzelne Adern. Es wurden mindestens, aller mindestens, immer 2 Doppeladern, also 4 gelegt. Und die meisten Hauptanschlüsse, selbst bei Einfamilienhäusern oder so, die haben 6 Doppeladern oder 8 Doppeladern.
Da haben wir auch mal einen zweiten Telefonanschluss bekommen.
Du hast auch selbst in Wohnungen, in Altbauwohnungen, immer einen 4er Kabel, was drunter geht, zum Hausverteiler. Ich habe es nie irgendwo gesehen, dass jemand nur eine Doppelader hat.
Das heißt, ich könnte im Prinzip mit der Technik hier davon ausgehen, dass hier noch eine andere Doppelader für mich problemlos bereitgestellt werden könnte, ohne dass Leute sich aus dem Haus stürzen, weil sie dann kein Internet mehr haben.
Oder dass Leute draußen eine Schippe in die Hand nehmen müssen, was ja der wichtige Faktor ist.
Könnte ich hier im Prinzip 100 Megabits...
200...
.in jede Richtung...
Aber warum? Warum solltet ihr die Telekom dir so was legen, wenn sie dir auch ein Business-Produkt verkaufen kann, wo du so schön den Bürgersteig für aufmachst, eine Glasfaser reinlegen und dich 1000 Squeege Euro im Monat verchargeln? Ich würde ihnen dafür Geld geben. Würdest du ihnen dafür vielleicht 60 Euro statt 50 geben?
Oder was? Ich würde ihnen 100 Megabit Internet haben können. Das wäre mir ein Huni wert. Für die heißt es am Ende nur, entweder sie nehmen meinen 100er oder sie kriegen ihn nicht.
Ja, aber nochmal, die halten das kurz, bis die Konkurrenz kommt und sie beißt.
Das heißt, man bräuchte jetzt einfach mal Konkurrenz. Die sagt, ach so, hier, sie haben da noch ein paar Kupferadern.
Das heißt, du warst ein Konkurrenz. Die sagt, ach so, hier, sie haben da noch ein paar Kupferadern. Okay, die sind jetzt nicht exklusiv deine. Und hier im Bereich der Metaebene, hier ist so eine Hipster-Gegend. Hier hipster bestimmt Leute, die auch so einen Anschluss haben und denen natürlich auch totbitternden.
Ja, in meinem Fall gibt's das. Kabel-Deutschland reicht zumindest nicht hier bis ins Studio. Das hab ich schon geprüft.
Aber die bieten so was an, aber die sind halt nicht exklusiv deine. Nicht nur, aber du kommst zu Pima da haben wir 100 Megawatt draus. Aber das ist preislich und verfügbarkeitstechnisch noch nicht so relevant, dass die Platzhirchen im ADSL-Bereich irgendwie tangiert. Das wird dann spannend, wenn ich denke... Wir haben mal mit dem Einzug von LTE, wenn die jetzt die Anbieter mit dem LTE auch in die Städte dürfen, was sie bisher nicht durften, das ist ein interessantes Politikum, als man damals die Frequenzen freigegeben hat dafür, hat man gesagt, ja, du darfst einer steigern, aber anstatt jetzt dich wieder ins Getümmel zu stürzen und ins Konkurrenz gewurstet in den großen Städten, wo wir schon 50 ADSL-Anbieter und zwei Kabel-Anbieter und was sie nicht alles haben, gehst du jetzt erstmal in versorgstes Land. Das haben sie jetzt zwei, drei Jahre lang gemacht, so ein bisschen.
Das hat dir in deinem Dorf auch sozusagen die Änderung gebracht.
Und jetzt, ich denke so, ab diesem Jahr dürfen sie jetzt auch anfangen, Zeugs in den Städten zu platzieren. Und das heißt, man kriegt dann eben auch durch die Luft ordentliche Bitraten hin und kriegst mit LTE ja auch in den 50, 60, 70, 100 Megabit theoretisch hin, auch mehr. Wenn da mal jemand kommt, ein anständiges Angebot macht, dann sagt halt irgendwann die Telekom oder anderen Anbieter, oh naja gut, da gab's doch noch so Profile, die wir noch nicht aktiviert haben. Da fasst keiner nochmal ein Equipment an oder nimmt eine Schaufel in die Hand, um noch ein Kabel zu vergraben. Vielleicht bohren sie nochmal ihren Backbone ein bisschen auf, wenn sie nett sind. Vielleicht aber auch nicht.
Wollen sie einen neuen Buchstaben irgendwie aus dem Schrank oder heißt das X-DSL und dann gibt's das einfach.
Ja, aber das ist rein mit Marketing. Aber das geht, kann man machen.
Oh Gott, jetzt bin ich aber frustriert. Aber theoretisch könnte man auch so einen virtuellen DSL-Provider aufmachen. Naja, der sich jetzt so was weiß ich hier bei der Telefonika oder wer auch sonst noch irgendwie untervermietet.
Und sagen, gibt mir bitte ein anderes Profil auf dem Port.
Ja, das machen die nicht.
Ne, schießen sich ja selber mit den Fuß.
Achso, das heißt, ich kann nur das, was die auch an Profilen fahren, kaufen. Da müsste man schon eigene Technik machen. Aber wenn ich jetzt eigene Technik irgendwo reinstelle, kannst du machen. Dann könnte man auch so zwei Doppeladern in Anspruch nehmen.
Kannst du alles machen, was du willst. Inzwischen hast du als...
Kostet dann aber auch das Doppelte quasi, weil man ja wahrscheinlich jede Doppelala auch separat bezahlt, oder?
Ja, aber du kannst ja inzwischen nur halb kaufen. Wenn du so was Schnelles machen willst, musst du eh dichter ran an den Kunden. Das heißt, du musst dir ein Kästchen aufbauen, was du neben dem KV von der Telekom stellst, auf die Straße. Den musst du natürlich versorgen, diesen Kasten. Das heißt, da musst du ein Stück Glas oder irgendwas hinlegen.
Also in diesen KV kommt man gar nicht rein?
Nee, du kommst daneben.
Daneben.
Du darfst was daneben stellen und du hast auch das Recht, dann dort ein Kabel reinzuziehen oder reinziehen zu lassen von der Telekom. Die Telekom behält selber die Hoheit über diese Ding, über die Teilnehmeranschlussleitung oder dieses Stückchen noch eben vom KV zu dir in der Hause. Das kannst du mieten. Das ist natürlich billiger als die Gesamtstrecke von der Vermittlungsstelle. Und du bist auch als Monopolnetzbetreiber, das die Telekom auch dazu verpflichtet, dir diesen Zugang zu diesem KV eben, also den zu geben. Das heißt, du kannst da was daneben stellen und eigene Technik da reinbauen und dann sagen hier, viel Spaß. Aber dann hast du wieder selber einen Kasten auf der Straße, den du wieder mit Strom versorgen musst, wo du den auch erstmal an deinen Backboden angeschlossen haben musst, wo du also ein bisschen Glas verlegen musst und so. Du bist insoweit, dass du Glas zusammen mieten musst. Gerade in den Städten gibt es reichlich Zeugs, was im Boden vergraben wurde. Da war zu Zeiten der Blase 1.0, also Ende der 90er, Anfang 2000 oder so, wo ja wild Glas gelegt wurde, überall. Du siehst es heute immer noch, wenn du an manchen Autobahnen lang fährst und gerade als Beifahrer mal Zeit hast, mal rauszuschauen. Das ist immer so ein Stückchen, so 10, 20 Meter weg. Neben der Autobahn siehst du dann auf Holzpflöcken immer noch oben so ein Kabel liegen. Da haben sie sich überlegt, das buddeln wir mal ein, wenn wir mal Zeit haben. Manche von denen liegen heute noch oben.
Auf den Stromleitungen oder was jetzt?
Nein, nicht auf den Stromleitungen, es sind wirklich nur Glasfaser-Dinger, die in dicken Isolierungen sind, wie so Gartenschlauch-Dinger. Schwarz. Immer alle paar hundert Meter hast du noch mal eine Schleife drin, mit so einem Splice-Kasten drin. Die liegen neben der Autobahn. Zu dieser Zeit war alles akut jeder, der wehgerecht hatte. Es wurde zum Beispiel BVG total beliebt, weil sie hatten U-Bahnschächte. Das heißt, du konntest, ohne einen Schaufel anfassen zu können, quer durch Berlin Fasern ziehen. Die haben ganz coole Sachen gemacht, gute Deals gemacht. Die haben zum Beispiel gesagt zu solchen Anbietern, die da rein wollten, sagen, ja, könnt ihr gerne machen. Aber ihr zieht uns umsonst eine Strippe mit. Wenn ihr eh schon durch die Tunnel fahrt und an die Decke nagelt, nagelt ihr gleich noch ein Glasfaserkabel von uns mit dran. Oder zum Beispiel, wir haben ja in Berlin reichlich Kanäle. Im Landwehrkanal liegt auch einiges an Glasfaser inzwischen. Das haben sie sich zuerst nicht getraut, weil sie dachten, ach scheiße, da schmeißt da einer einen Anker drauf oder so. Aber irgendwann haben sie doch festgestellt, wir haben sehr, sehr viele Kanäle, die auch alle miteinander verbunden sind. Aber wir sehen von ein paar Schleusen, wo du sozusagen nicht großartig was beantragen musst. Normalerweise, wenn du eine Straße aufmachst, musst du ja immer beantragen. Und den Tiefbau und la la la und Absicherung der Baustelle und aufbuddeln und reinlegen und zumachen und aufpassen, dass man beim Ausbuddeln nicht das Kabel von den Mitbewerbern rausreißt. Oder eine Gastleitung oder sonst irgendwas, ne? Deswegen war jeder, der irgendein Wegrecht hatte, total begehrt dort. Wie gesagt, die Bahnen haben das ja selber gemacht. Der AQOR ist ja eine Tochter gewesen oder ein Spin-off der DB Telematik, also wo die deutsche Bundesbahn selber schon gesagt hat, wir schmeißen mal in Langunterschieden ein paar Glasfaserkabel. Und daraus sind halt eben solche Firmen wie AQOR denn entstanden. Und es gibt eigentlich, witzigerweise gibt es eine ganze Menge Glas im Boden. Wenn man hier mal in der Innenstadt von Berlin mal mit offenen Augen durch die Gegend läuft und auf den Fußboden mal schaut und sich diese Deckel da anschaut, die da liegen, findet man so ein gutes halbes Dutzend Firmen, die dort ihre Glasfaserkabel drin haben.
Colt und so, oder?
Colt, Versatel, Level 3 zum Beispiel, auch noch ganz bekannt. Die haben also diese Stadt-Glasfasernetze. Das geht teilweise sogar bis in die Outskirts. Vor ein paar Jahren habe ich es mal gesehen am U-Bahnhof Rudow, was ja nur das Ende der U7 ist, also sozusagen schon fast in Schönefeld draußen. Auch da gibt es noch einen Colt-Deckel. Also es gibt es schon, die haben sich ausgelastet. Na, unausgelastet, aber die haben reichlich gelegt. Das war die Goldgräber-Stimmung damals, die haben alle Zeugs reingelegt. Und es gibt halt Glasfaser-Backbones quer durch ganz Europa, auch durch Osteuropa, gerade nach dem Fall der Mauer hier oder dem Fall des eisernen Vorhangs, wie man immer so schön sagt, wurde halt eben auch dort gelegt wie Tier. Und die konnte man, kann man auch heute immer noch, kann man diese Glasfasern erwärmen. Damals gab es so einen sogenannten IRU's, die Irrevocable Rights of Use. Das heißt, man konnte, es gab eine Firma, die hat nur die Kabel verlegt, hat aber selber gar keine aktive Technik draufgeschaltet. Sie haben nur gesagt, hier, ich vermiete dir, da sind jetzt 12 Fasern drin in dem Kabel, ich vermiete dir zwei davon, oder ich vermiete sie dir dauerhaft für die nächsten 25 Jahre. Ohne Kündigungsmöglichkeit, diese Irrevocable Rights of Use. Da hast du so einen 25-Jahres-Vertrag gemacht, da konntest du halt eben eine Glasfaser haben, von Kopenhagen, was ist ich, nach Genf. Für, was weiß ich, keine Ahnung, 100.000 Euro, 150.000 Euro oder so, was damals nicht so viel war. Nicht Euro, Mark und so Zeugs. Darauf haben die halt ihre Netze aufgebaut. Und da ist wahnsinnig viel von verlegt worden. Auch überhaupt, transatlantisch zum Beispiel, gibt es auch Kapazitäten möglich, bis der Arzt kommt.
Das heißt, es gibt schon die Möglichkeit auch, neben der Telekom ein vollwertiger Provider zu sein, der wirklich konkurrenzfähige DSL-Angebote in die Heule hat.
Das lohnt sich nicht. Die Marge darin ist zu gering. Der Konkurrenzdruck in der Stadt ist zu hoch, als dass du irgendwie gegen die anstinken kannst. Und wie ich ja schon gerade sagte, wenn jetzt hier jemand, der Telekom ernsthaft zu nahe kommt, dann aktivieren die halt einfach noch mal die Profile in ihren VDSL DSLAMs, die sie vorher nicht mit Marsch angeguckt haben, und drehen halt eben noch mal die Bandbreite wieder hoch.
Schreit ja so ein bisschen nach so einer gewissen Deregulierung. Ich meine, das hast du ja vorhin schon erwähnt, viel dieser Infrastruktur ist einfach mit Steuergeld aufgebaut worden. Das war dann noch ein Zeichen der Bundespost. Dann war es halt irgendwann mal ein Privatunternehmen. Und jetzt haben wir da das Problem, dass eben sowohl die Netze, also dass die Kabelwege etc. in derselben Firma liegen, die eben auch die Produkte über diese Kabel anbietet.
Naja, das wird ja auch schon gemacht, aber da musst du halt mal gucken. Da gibt es halt eine Regulierungsbehörde dazwischen, die spektakulär auftaucht in den Zeitungen, wenn sie jetzt mal was macht, was der Telekom mal nicht schmeckt. Aber in der Regel, ich will nicht sagen, ich kann die jetzt auch so nicht beurteilen, ob die jetzt besonders telekomfreundlich sind, aber du musst mal überlegen, kannst du mal nach googeln, wie der derzeitige Preis einer Teilnehmeranschlussleitung ist, der dürfte immer noch so um die 10 Euro liegen, vielleicht 9 Euro oder sonst was sein. Wenn du jetzt ein DSL-Anbieter bist, das heißt, du musst deine ganze Technik aufbauen, da reintun, deinen Backbone aufbauen, dann kriegst du von deinem Kunden 1995 für den Dosteligen Flatrate-Anschluss, musst vielleicht sogar noch einen Telefonanschluss mit reinpacken oder sonst was für deine 1995. Und ladst dann aber noch für den letzten Kilometer Kupfer an die Telekom als Monopolnetzbetreiber noch mal die Hälfte deines Brotübertrages, den du einziehst von deinem Kunden, nur für die Teilnehmeranschlussleitung, dann ist halt deine Marge entsprechend klein. Deswegen macht es auch, denke ich mal, nicht so einen Spaß für viele, da jetzt noch mal in diesen Markt einzusteigen.
Zehn Euro? Was hast du jetzt? Zehn Euro zwanzig ist es seit 2009.
Er ist nicht wesentlich drunter. Und guck dir an, die meisten Angebote, wie sie alle da sind, Flatrate 1995. Das heißt, du lässt die Hälfte deines Geldes, der Bruttoeinnahme, nur für das Stückchen Kupfer bei der Telekom, und aus dem Rest musst du jetzt anfangen, deine ganze Infrastruktur zu bauen und zu betreiben. Das macht vielen keinen Spaß. Und ganz ehrlich, für Otto Normalverbraucher reichen diese 16 Megabit und 25 Megabit voll aus. Das sind halt ein paar Mac-User, die ein iTunes-Store benutzen oder mal ein Update machen, die ja nicht mal schaffen, diese 16 Megabit überhaupt voll zu machen. Ein Otto Normal-User kriegt die mit seinen Gerätschaften, die er dort hat, oder mit den Web-Diensten, die er benutzt, gar nicht voll. Selbst wenn er den ganzen Tag YouTube guckt, kriegt er die 16 Megabit nicht voll. Also die Leute, die jetzt mehr als das haben wollen oder wirklich VDSL haben wollen, sind entweder Leute, die diesen ganzen Tag T-Home gucken, in HD und welche Filme gucken, oder eben Leute wie du, die sozusagen im professionellen Bereich schon sind, also eigentlich aus dem Kundensegment für Privatkunden rausfallen, die so Spezialeinwendungen haben, wie ich will jetzt hier einen dicken Uploadstream haben oder sowas.
Ja, ich hätte gerne mal so einen Nerd-Tarif.
Das wäre cool.
Seitdem ich jetzt diese 10 Megabit... Du weißt gar nicht, was das bei mir geändert hat. Also wirklich, ich meine, ich erinnere mich noch... Also mein Spruch war, dass schon immer so dieses Menschenrecht auf 2 Megabit Grundversorgung, das glaube ich, das habe ich irgendwie schon seit Mitte der 90er Jahre getönt. Natürlich kannst du dir auch vorstellen, wie man dann so angeguckt wurde. Ich weiß auch noch nicht, ich war dann irgendwann auch so damit, wie ich merkwürdig netzkulturell geprägten Diskussionsveranstaltungen, die jetzt keinen großen Schatten und Fußabtritt hinterlassen hatte in der Geschichte. Aber da ging es dann auch irgendwie um We want Bandwidth. Ich melde mich ab, habe diese Diskussion eine Weile verfolgt und kann es dir etwa vorstellen, was da für ein Quatsch geredet wurde. Ich habe mich dann irgendwann lautstark gemeldet und einfach mal symmetrische Leitungen gefordert und überhaupt einfach mal schnelle Leitungen für alle. Und die schauten mich alle vollkommen entgeistert an und dann so wozu sollte man denn schnellen Leitungen gebrauchen in das Internet? Da meinte ich, strinken sie doch mal ihr Hirn an, mir würde so einiges einfallen. Wie wäre es denn zum Beispiel mal mit einem Backup? Dann lachten sie alle. Wozu sollte man denn sein Backup ins Internet übertragen? Und was haben wir irgendwie dieses Jahr als Thema?
Also wie gesagt, da geht noch ein bisschen was rein technisch gesehen und es ist halt ein politisches Spiel und das ist wie gesagt auch ein es ist ein Trauerspiel, weil die Politik sich auch nicht einsetzt bzw. teilweise auch Sachen blockiert. Ich kann vielleicht noch mal eine kleine Anekdote beitragen dazu, die das mal ein bisschen illustriert. Die hat zwar jetzt nichts mit Festnetz zu tun, aber die hat was mit dem politischen Gegebenheit zu tun. War wie gesagt jetzt häufiger mal in Skandinavien unterwegs, in den letzten Monaten, auch in den letzten Jahren. Und in Schweden kriege ich mit, ich habe eine schwedische SIM-Karte, ihr kriegt dort überall UMTS. Auch wirklich da in the middle of fucking nowhere. hätte ich jetzt Piep drücken müssen? Die F-Word. Und die wenn man sich das mal näher anguckt, wie die das machen ist, da gibt es halt eben ein UMTS-Netz, das taucht auf deinem Handy rauf und es sieht als Sweden. Und dann klickst du mal ein bisschen rum, denkst du, das ist ja ein geiler Netz, überall verfügbar, die haben ja super Abdeckungen. Dann klickst du mal rum und denkst, wenn wir mal eine SIM-Karte von Sweden haben, es gibt keine SIM-Karte von Sweden.
Dann ist es ein Vollbacknetz, was alle benutzen können?
Es ist ein Netz, was sich mehrere Operator dort teilen. Wo sozusagen die Flecken auf dem Land versorgt, wo es sich nicht lohnt, für jeden von den vier Leuten selber sein Türmchen aufzubauen. Das heißt, du roamsst sozusagen auf einem virtuellen Netz. Ja, als, wie gesagt, vier große Provider.
Wo sie ja gerade die Kosten teilen.
Das ist in Deutschland so nicht zulässig, weil da kommt dann die Kartellbehörde und sagt, da müssen wir aber den Anwender schützen. Und durch solchen Schutz ist es halt eben so, dass bei uns die UMTS-Abdeckung auf dem Land für ein Arsch ist. Abseits, witziger, wenn du mal UMTS siehst auf dem Land, dann an der Autobahn. Da, wo die Leute ihr Handy nicht benutzen dürfen, da gibt es dann Abdeckung. Da, wo man es benutzen kann, entlang der Bahnlinien, gibt es die nicht. Auch wieder so eine Idiotie, die mir bis heute nicht klar ist. Aber, ähm, ja, ich weiß nicht, die werden davor geschützt, dass die Netzbetreiber zusammen kooperieren und sich vielleicht um was auskungeln. Und dadurch sozusagen ein Kartell bilden. Und an dieser Stelle fragt man sich mal, okay, das ist schön, jetzt bin ich beschützt davor, dass die Netzbetreiber keinen Kartell bilden. Und damit bin ich effektiv davor beschützt, UMTS auf dem Land zu kriegen. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Und so ist halt eben die Politik.
Das würde ja auch in der Stadt durchaus sinnvoll sein.
Ja, könnte man auch machen. Könnte man theoretisch auch machen. Da will natürlich jeder Provider, da lohnt es sich auch, da hast du genügend Leute drauf, da lohnt es sich auch, sozusagen selber mal besser Technik zu installieren, auch zu machen. Das tun die übrigens in Schweden auch. Also in Schweden gibt es schon länger LTE, nicht bloß das, aber gibt es eben auch UMTS. Und die fahren auch auf ihrem UMTS 20 Megabit. Das geht nämlich auch. Das funktioniert, habe ich gerade ausprobiert im Dezember. Da gehst du in einen Laden und holst dir einen Stick, der auch diese 20 Megabit kann. Ich glaube, da kann sogar noch mehr, 24 oder 25 Megabit. Der kostet 199 Kronen inklusive SIM-Karte. Durch 10 ungefähr sind also 20 Euro. Du bekommst den Stick mit einer SIM-Karte, die funktioniert für einen Monat. Und prepaid kannst du dann aufladen, immer so für 100 Kronen oder so.
Da sind dann auch schon Daten mit drin?
Ich weiß gar nicht, 5G, 10G, irgendwas ist dir egal. Oh Gott. Also das geht. Wenn ich den Leuten hier erzähle in Deutschland, ist immer die erste Reaktion, die dämliche Reaktion, dass sie dann kommen mit, ne, aber es sind doch viel weniger Leute. Ich sag, jetzt denkt doch mal bitte drüber nach. Das Land ist viel größer, es sind viel weniger Leute und sie kriegen es trotzdem gebacken. Sie kriegen es trotzdem gebacken, ihr Volk dort zu versorgen.
Mit deutlich weniger Kunden und viel größerer Fläche.
Ich meine, der Staat hat doch auch was getan. Sie haben z.B. in einer großen Infrastrukturmaßnahme sind es mal hingegangen, haben gesagt, wir legen mal eine große Glasfaserschleife quer durch unser Land, also wirklich unten von der Südspitze quer durchs Land bis hoch, durch die Ballungszentren, aber eben auch bis hoch nach Kiruna-Wara oder wirklich der Lands End da oben hinten und einmal auf der anderen Seite wieder runter. Und das war eine nationale Infrastrukturmaßnahme. Und an diesen Backbone oder sowas, da können sich jetzt Provider einmieten und sagen, ich hätte hier gerne was. Da verteilen die auch ihre öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehprogramme drüber und so. Also es wird halt eben so für öffentlich-rechtliche Sachen benutzt. Aber es wird halt eben auch gesagt, hier so Provider, musst du nicht selber das Land aufhacken, die 3000, 4000 Kilometer, da sind bis da hoch und wieder runter, sondern wir haben das mal für dich gemacht. Hier mietest du jetzt irgendwie mal eine Phase an.
Und der Staat verdient da noch was dran?
Der Staat verdient vielleicht ein bisschen, weil er daran schafft, es ist sozusagen für so ein Provider, der jetzt oben in Kiruna oder so ein paar People versorgen will. Ja, der Staat schafft eine Grundlage.
Eine Datenautobahn.
Der schafft eine Datenautobahn, auf deren Basis sozusagen Leute wieder anbieten können. Und dadurch kriegen sie es halt eben auch hin, eben auch in diesem Riesen, auf dieser Riesenfläche, eben auch die Parnasen da. Das heißt Parnasen, Schweden ist ja der größte Land da oben, aber trotzdem ist es nur ein Nachteil von dem, was hier in Deutschland rumhüpft.
Was heißt so richtig Bewegung kommen, das fällt eigentlich erst nur dann, wenn sich einerseits auf der politischen Seite etwas tut. Also dieses generelle, dieses Verstehen, dass das Bereitstellen von schnellen Datenwegen überall dieses Land voranbringt, das scheint irgendwie...
Wir müssen sowas haben, wie ein ADAC für Datenautobahnen. So eine Lobby, so ein ADAC ist ja diese Autofahrerlobby, die auch Geld einsammelt und damit auch Lobbyisten hier beschäftigt, dass sie immer auf den Politiker-Köpfen rumhauen und sagen, hier wollen wir noch eine Straße ausbauen und da bitte noch und da nicht so viel Geld in den ÖPNV verschwenden.
Naja, ich sag nur, gibt's...
Aber Bitkom ist eine Industrievereinigung, ist kein ADAC. Bitkom wäre so was wie, das Equivalent dazu wäre, sagen wir mal, der Verband der Straßenbaufirmen und der Autohersteller. Aber du willst eigentlich einen Verband haben mit ein paar Millionen Mitgliedern von Endbenutzern. So, wirsindeinzelfall.de müssten eigentlich sozusagen das mal ausweiten und sagen, wir machen jemanden vereinen, machen wir ordentlich Lobbyarbeit. Oder schließen uns meinetwegen als Genossenschaft zusammen, bauen sowas selber.
Naja, da sind wir jetzt wieder bei diesem Shitstorm-Phänomen. Ich meine, wenn man sich vielleicht mal nicht immer nur auf Twitter auskotzt, wie schlimm alles ist, oder mal so eine Webseite baut, wäre das ja vielleicht auch ein bisschen krass zu überlegen, ob man nicht an der Stelle einfach mal so ein Movement startet. Die Frage ist nur, in welche Richtung dieses Movement marschieren sollte.
Ich meine, theoretisch kannst du das auch so geben. Es gibt genügend Leute, die Leute an die Wand malen, die EU malen es an die Wand. Man kann sich das den Nachbarländern angucken. Überall kannst du das nicht nur in Skandinavien, sondern auch die anderen um uns herum können. Selbst die Polen können das. Für was jetzt? Die Infrastrukturmaßnahmen besser machen, besser verteilen. Also DSL, gerade Stichwort DSL auf dem Land. Erst mal ein bisschen Flächendeckung hinmachen und so weiter. Da kann man auch mal hinschauen. Dann gibt es natürlich auch genügend Leute, die in Deutschland rumhüpfen und sagen, man müsste doch mal zuletzt hier Piraten im Abgeordnetenhaus. Dann sitzt da die CDU-Rege und sagt, ich verstehe das nicht, was wollt ihr? Wir verstehen das nicht. Wenn du denen sagst, wir brauchen eine dickere Straße, damit du im Benz da schneller fahren kannst, das verstehen sie. Aber das ist noch nicht in den Hürden dieser Leute angekommen, dass so eine Infrastrukturmaßnahme eben auch volkswirtschaftlich sinnvoll ist, wie das vorhin erwähnte Beispiel aus Island, wo die halt einfach sagen, wir haben hier eine Stoff der Insel, außer Wärme und fünf Schafen und ein paar Fischen vor der Tür. Wir haben nur sozusagen die Ressources, sozusagen nur der Intellekt unserer Bevölkerung. Und mit dem müssen wir etwas antun. Und die müssen wir bündeln, müssen wir versorgen. Und deswegen, diese Erkenntnis, wie sie, wie gesagt, in Skandinavien und überall vorherrscht oder so, auch wie in anderen Ländern, fehlt hier einfach völlig. Hier wird das Internet gesehen als das böse Ein- und Ausfallstor für Hacker, Kinderpornografen und sonst irgendwas. Dementsprechend passiert da auch infrastrukturmäßig, außer warmen Worten, nichts. Man überlässt es der Industrie, das zu machen, wie sie es will, aber so was wie erwähnte Datenautobahnen oder so, das ist hier nicht in Sicht. Das macht die Industrie schon selber. Das ist mal so schön neoliberal. Das reguliert der Markt schon.
Man muss sozusagen das Fernsehprogramm ändern. Deutschland sucht das Gigabit.
Und die Technik ist da, das geht. Deswegen ist es nicht so, dass man das jetzt erfinden müsste.
Vielleicht sollen wir nochmal auf diese Techniken kommen. Teilweise hast du es ja schon angesprochen. DSL, das haben wir jetzt ganz gut abgefrühstückt. Da wäre auch noch Luft nach oben. Da ist eine Menge zu holen. Das ist im Wesentlichen ein Problem der Deregulierung und ein Problem der Deregulierung. Vielleicht auch der Regulierung.
Vielleicht müsste man mal wirklich die Anbieter wieder an die Kandare nehmen, politisch und sagen, hier Telekom, hör mal auf mit diesem Blödsinn. Zum Beispiel diese feste Bandbreitenberechnung, die wirklich ein unglaublicher Blödsinn. Dass er einfach sagt, hallo, ein Universaldienst, bitte mit freilaufenden DSL-Modems. Das heißt, die handeln selber aus, was geht, holen daraus was drin ist und nicht das, was du ausgerechnet hast. Und dafür halt auch einen vernünftigen Preis und dafür vielleicht auch einen ordentlichen Zugang für alternative Anbieter, was den IP-Layer angeht oder IPv6-Layer oder so was. Das gibt es alle, aber derzeit nicht reguliert. Die Regulierungsbehörde lässt von dem ganzen DSL-Trödel komplett die Finger. Wie gesagt, biet es an oder biet es nicht an, ist uns scheißegal. Es gibt immer mal wieder die Diskussion, es gab ja sogar, witzigerweise, bei dieser ganzen VDSL-Geschichte, die berühmte Lex Telekom, dass die Telekom gesagt hat, wir würden jetzt hier ein VDSL-Netz aufbauen, müssen aber ein bisschen investieren in diese Kästen, die auf der Straße stehen. Und das tun wir aber nur, wenn wir von der Verpflichtung befreit werden, da Mitbewerber für eine gewisse Zeit drauf zu lassen. Das hat etwa damals, vor ein paar Jahren, als Lex Telekom sozusagen, wo sie auch Ärger für gekriegt haben, weil die EU hat gesagt, das geht so eigentlich nicht. Ich glaube, das ist immer noch ein Verfahren anhängig. Aber nur so haben die sich überhaupt darauf eingelassen, das anzufassen. Und keine andere hat das angefasst, weil sie entweder das Geld nicht hatten oder die Grundressourcen nicht hatten, nämlich die Glasfaser, die man auch braucht dahin, was die Telekom ja längst aus Steuermitteln finanziert hatte. Das haben sie ja geerbt, konnten sich auf diesem Teil ausruhen. Und die Alternativen, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, die fassen das nicht an, weil in dem Moment, wo sie das versuchen anzufassen, sagen, hallo, ich möchte mal an den Kunden, an den Kasten ran, weil ich will deine Kunden versorgen, sagt die Telekom, ja, mach doch ruhig, bevor du deine eigenen Kasten schreibst.
Genau.
Zack. Ja, aber jetzt gibt es ja auch noch Alternativen an dieser ganzen DSL-Telekom-Realität vorbei. Also Kabel Deutschland ist so einer dieser Anbieter.
Oder Kabel-Netzbetreiber.
Kabel-Netzbetreiber, genau, ich weiß nicht, wie viele gibt es da so.
Die konzentrieren sich, die kaufen sich alle gegenseitig wieder zusammen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich bin selber, da ich auch keinen Fernseher besitze, da nicht so in dieser Szene drin, aber so drei oder vier.
Was für eine Technik kommt denn da zum Einsatz?
Da gibt es einen Standard für, nennt sich DOCSIS. D-O-C-S-I-S. Kannst du mal nach googeln, wofür dieser Dacronym steht. DOCSIS 3.0 ist derzeit aktuell. Das heißt, da gibt es auch standardisierte Modems für und standardisierte Schnittstellen und so was Ähnliches wie im DSL. Das muss man übrigens sagen, bei all dieser Klopperei und Konkurrenz hin und her, wir haben im DSL netterweise die Situation, zumindest hier in Europa, dass diese Dinge alle kompatibel sind. Das heißt, du kannst also, wenn du in den Laden gehst, nicht sagen, ich hätte gerne DSL-Modem für A-Core oder für LS oder wie noch immer, sondern die basieren alle auf denselben Standards und sind auch voll interoperabel. Selbst ADSL und VDSL. Du kannst deine VDSL-Fritz-Box auch hier abschrauben und woanders an deinen ADSL-Anschluss stecken. Geht immer noch das Ding. Langsamer, aber geht immer noch. Ähnlich sieht es im Kabelbereich aus. Da gibt es halt, wie gesagt, diesen DOCSIS-Standard.
Data Over Cable Service Interface Specific.
Siehst du, DOCSIS 3.0 ist derzeit aktuell. Du kriegst da auch theoretisch irgendwie 2, 300 Megawatt oder so. Das ist so die Obergrenze von dem, was sie da derzeit spezifiziert haben, was du damit machen kannst. Die haben eben auch einen ganz lustigen Uplink. Also die können auch Uplink-mäßig was machen. Ist vom Prinzip dasselbe in Grün, nicht über die Kupferdoppelader, was du hier machst beim DSL, sondern über das Quarks-Kabel. Und dass du halt eben nicht alleine drauf bist, ist eben der spannende Teil. Das heißt, so eine Verbindung steht nicht exklusiv dir zur Verfügung, sondern von dem nächsten Kabel-Fernsehverteiler, wo so ein entsprechendes Gegenwohl drin ist, wird halt eben eine ganze Straße oder zwei, drei Straßenzüge versorgt. Und alle Leute, die da so einen Anschluss drauf haben, hängen da sozusagen mit auf dem Ding drauf.
Ist auch so ein bisschen wie früher. Ich meine, die Internet hat ja auch mal mit Quarks-Kabel angefangen. Und eigentlich ist es nichts anderes.
Eigentlich ist es nichts anderes, nur man nutzt halt eben schon besser Übertragungstechnik. Das ist auch wieder DMT, also auch wieder dieselbe Technik, die dahinter steht, dass man sich sein verfügbares Frequenzband aufteilt in kleine Kanäle und die einzeln durchmisst, wie sauber die sind, wie brauchbar die sind. Und gut, das muss man ja eben kabel deswegen machen, weil dann gibt es ja eh diese Kanalaufteilung auch für die Fernsehkanäle. Also DMT ist dieses Discreet Multi-Tone. Wo man sozusagen im Kabelfernsehen dediziert, man so einen Kanal, auf dem normalerweise ein Fernsehsender senden würde oder sowas, und bringt da dann die Signale auf. Wobei es aber auch Mischformen gibt, dass man sagt, nur in dem Rückweg, also in dem, was du sendest, benutzen wir DMT, in dem anderen Weg von der Vermittlungsstelle oder vom Netzknoten zu dir rein, benutzt man teilweise dieselben Mechanismen wie im DVBC, also MPEG-Container. Das heißt, man kann das eben selbst, das ist technisch sogar möglich, auf derselben Frequenz gemultiplext mit irgendwelchen Fernsehsignalen zu betreiben. Ich weiß jetzt hier gar nicht, was die in Deutschland machen. Ich habe, wie gesagt, selber keinen Kabelanschluss, aber diese Standards lassen das alle zu. Die Endgeräte sehen übrigens genauso aus. Da gibt es auch eine Fritzbox wieder, die halte Koax-Anschluss statt so einem Ariat 45 für dein DSL. Nur der Markt ist deutlich kontrollierter. Das heißt, wenn du dort einen Anschluss kriegst, kriegst du auch immer von dem Anbieter, das wurde ihm gleich mit. Das ist nicht so wie im DSL-Bereich, dass man da in den Laden geht und sich den DSL-Router seines Vertrauens kauft und den da dran hängt, sondern da gibt es sozusagen vom Prinzip eigentlich immer die Modempflicht mit. Das hängt auch damit zusammen, dadurch, dass du das Medium nicht für dich alleine hast, sondern auch alle deine Nachbarn da drauf hängen, die auch so einen Anschluss haben, dass natürlich der Netzbetrauer ein bisschen Kontrolle über das haben will, was du da hinten dran hängst, damit du sozusagen jetzt nicht den Bit-Daten-Strom von deinem Nachbarn mitliest, was ein Hacker natürlich trotzdem tun kann. Aber man will sozusagen autonormale Anwender davon abhalten, indem man ihm sagt, pass mal auf, hier kriegst du eine komplette Hardware, da kommt schon WLAN raus und hinten noch ein Ethernet-Stöpsel und lass die Finger davon weg. Da brauchst du nix konfigurieren oder so, da kommt IP für dich raus und der Rest geht dich nix an. Aber rein technisch gesehen ist das vom Prinzip auch dasselbe wie bei den anderen Gurken auch.
Und LTE ist jetzt im Prinzip, wir wollten jetzt hier im Wesentlichen eigentlich so über die Festnetze reden, aber es ist ja mittlerweile, ja.
Na derzeit ist es noch Festnetze-Technologie. So wie es derzeit hier in Deutschland vertrieben und vermarktet wird, ist es ortsgebunden. Die LTE-Netze, auch das was ich jetzt ausgesucht habe, von Vodafone, da musst du schon den Ort mit angeben. Es war auch eine SIM-Karte drin, die kannst du theoretisch auch in ein LTE-Handy stecken, wenn es denn so etwas hier zu kaufen gäbe. Und damit durch die Gegend reisen. Rein technisch ist es so vorgesehen, wird aber so nicht vermarktet. Momentan ist es sozusagen so, dass du das entweder so mit einem USB-Stöpsel wieder hast, den du wieder in deinen Rechner reinsteckst, oder zum Beispiel einen Router. Ich arbeite nicht, wenn ich jetzt schon wieder Fritz-Box sage, es gibt eben auch eine Fritz-Box, die genauso aussieht wie das DSL-Ding, nur mit LTE eben drin, da gucken zwei riesengroße Antennen hinten raus. Verhält sich ansonsten auch von der Oberfläche genauso wie so eine DSL-Box. Nur, dass es eben keine Schnur dran hat, sondern eben über die Antennen geht. Und da schiebst du halt die SIM-Karte rein und du musst dem Netzbetreiber natürlich vorher ansagen, wo das Kästchen steht. Wenn du damit irgendwo durch die Gegend fährst oder so, kriegst du keine Verbindung. Das ist aber keine Frage der Technik, sondern wie das Produkt vermarktet wird. Also man nimmt im Prinzip Mobilfunktechnik, schränkt sie politisch ein, dass sie ortsgebunden ist und proklamiert das als Festnetzersatz für Voice und Data. Wobei Voice als Voice-over-IP auf dem IP-Layer abgebildet wird.
Stellt sich jetzt noch mal eine interessante Frage. Wenn man sich die Festnetze anschaut und die Mobilfunknetze, dann merkt man, dass es auch in diesem Bereich, schwammiges Wort, Netzneutralität, da doch einige Service-Schwankungen gibt. Und dass die Mobilfunknetze immer so diesen Appeal haben, Ausnahmen einfordern zu müssen, weil unsere Netze sind so überlastet. Da kann man ja nicht alles machen. Dann werden bestimmte Dienste ausgeschlossen. Und ja, aber Skype darf sie jetzt hier nicht benutzen, etc.
Es geht uns das Netz kaputt.
Genau, sonst geht uns irgendwie das Netz kaputt, weil Skype-Bits, wissen wir ja alle, bringen ja die Luft zum Glühen.
Nee, die haben das Evil-Bit im IP-Header gesehen.
Genau, also all diese Dinge. Wenn jetzt irgendwie LTE kommt und als Festnetzersatz gilt, kann das jetzt dann genauso behandelt werden? Und wird es genauso behandelt, wie das Mobilfunk ist?
Es könnte, die Technik gibt es her. Man kann sich auch da wieder in Skandinavien angucken, wo LTE richtig gemacht wird. Da, wo auch UMTS richtig gemacht wird. So wird es nicht gemacht. Ich kann jetzt nur über das Vodafone-Net sprechen, was ich ausprobiert habe im Norden von Berlin. Tolle Bitraten, aber wird genauso gehandhabt, wie ein UMTS-Ding. Das heißt, du kriegst auch keine richtige IP-Adresse. Die feiern wollen dich auch. Das heißt, du kannst selber auch gar keine Dienste betreiben. Nicht mal mit dünnen DNS oder sonst irgendwas. Du kriegst, wie gesagt, eine RFC-1918-Adresse, also eine 10-Punkt-Quitsch-Punkt-irgendwas-Adresse, die dann in dem Netz von Vodafone genattet wird. Also genauso servicemäßig gammelig, bis auf die hohe Bitrate, wie das Mobilfunknetz. Da kannst du auch nicht auf deinem iPhone jetzt einen Service launchen oder so. Das machen sie halt eben auch, um dich zu beschützen. Weil du hast ja einen Volumentarif. Daher ist es sehr interessant, wenn man selber direkt an Internet-Backbones dranhängt, zum Beispiel in meinen Servern auch, ich ging direkt bei einem ISP an den Core-Routern, wenn du einen gewissen IP-Adressraum hast, dann gibt es ein Grundrauschen. Es gibt so viele Millionen verseuchte PCs auf dieser Welt, wo irgendwelche Trojaner oder Viren drauflaufen, Trojaner, die ein permanentes Adressscanning machen. Die nehmen irgendwelche randomen IP-Adressen und probieren dort aus, ob da was ist, ob da überhaupt was ist, ob da ein Port offen ist, ob man das als SMTP-Relay, als Spam-Relay missbrauchen kann, ob da ein fehlkonfigurierter DNS-Server drauf ist und wie auch immer. Und das erzeugt ein unglaubliches Grundrauschen. Wenn du so einen Adressbereich hast, wie das, was man früher ein Class-C-Netz genannt hat, 1.24, also 256 IP-Adressen, auf denen du selber nichts anbietest, sondern die einfach nur da sind, verbunden sind, dann hast du teilweise schon ein paar Hundert Kilobit Grundrauschen. Nur durch die Leute, die die ganze Zeit automatisiert scannen, ob auf deinem Netz immer drauf ist. Das willst du natürlich nicht haben, vor allen Dingen nicht dann, wenn du auf einer Luftschnittstelle, wenn du halt eben hingehen willst und den Leuten auch noch Volumentarife anbietest. Dann sagen die, ey, hallo, ich hab meinen iPhone den ganzen Monat nicht angefasst, wieso habe ich hier zwei Gigabyte Volumen zusammen, geht's noch? Das ist sozusagen deren Begründung. Da kann man natürlich auch andere Maßnahmen gegen treffen, aber vom Prinzip wirst du hier eingeschwert. Welche anderen Maßnahmen würdest du denn da? Man kann ja auch anders ein bisschen vorsichtiger feiern wollen zum Beispiel, ohne dass man jetzt diese Dienste kaputtmacht, beziehungsweise auch irgendwelche Freischaltungen dort machen. Ich hab's jetzt nicht probiert in Skandinavien, aber in Schweden, was ich vorhin schon erwähnte, mit meiner schwedischen SIM-Karte, wenn ich mich da einbuche, kriege ich zumindest schon mal eine richtige IP-Adresse. Das heißt, ich werde nicht genattet. Und ich kann dort auch alle Dienste benutzen. Ich kann ohne Probleme Skype und Badvzig nicht alles benutzen, ohne irgendwelche Sorgen. Die werden mich sicherlich auch vor diesen Adressscannern ein bisschen beschützen, wobei, wenn du nur eine einzelne IP-Adresse hast, auch nicht so schlimm ist. Das wird halt immer dann schlimm, wenn du als Provider einen größeren Adressraum hast, dann hast du diese Grundrauschen von Müll, von Datenmüll, der aus dem ganzen Internet auf dich einhämmert. Mit einer einzelnen IP-Adresse ist das nicht so schlimm. Und wenn du dann halt eben noch einen Tarif hast, der irgendwie seinen Cap nicht bei 1G hat oder 2G, sondern bei 10 oder 20G, dann ist dir das auch egal. Dann lass das halt rauschen auf der IP-Adresse. Das heißt also, das geht. Die Technik verbietet das nicht. Aber so wie sie derzeit eingesetzt wird, das LTE, ist es sozusagen was für den Konsumenten, der irgendwie Twitter, YouTube und E-Mail liest und so was. Aber niemanden, der auf die Idee kommt, irgendwie einen Dienst anzubieten, einen kleinen Web-Server oder sonst sowas.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch ganz andere verbreitete Methoden des Hijackings. Erstmal sehr beliebt diese DNS-Server-Übernahme. Dass wenn da irgendwelche DNS-Anfragen nicht aufgelöst werden können, dass er dann auf eigene Adressen auslöst, um dann einem so eine Webseite zu präsentieren mit oh, du bist allein, armes Rotkäppchen hier im Wald, komm doch mit mir.
Und nach dem Gau der CAs in den letzten Monaten, im letzten Jahr, wo er den SSL-Zertifikaten nicht mehr so richtig vertrauen kann, jedenfalls nicht im näheren oder weiteren Umfeld des Irans, das ist natürlich ein Problem. Aber nochmal, um jetzt drauf zu kommen, warum bieten die keinen vernünftigen Netzanschluss an? Aber das ist sozusagen deren Begründung. Außerdem ist er eben volumentarifiert. Es ist teurer, es ist wesentlich teurer, dieses LTE als DSL. Bietet auch mehr Bandbreite. Ich habe dort wirklich auf dem platten Land irgendwie 25 Megabit oder sowas hingekriegt. Im Downlink. Und irgendwie 5 oder so weit im Uplink.
Kannst du denn darüber so eine VPN-Verbindung hin?
Das kannst du machen. Du kannst ja beim VPN bauen damit. Das geht. Weil das initiierst du ja von drinnen nach draußen. Aber das ist schon sophisticated.
Na gut, hätte ja sein können, dass sie da auch wieder die paar Ports gesperrt haben. Es gibt ja so Unis, die machen ja irgendwie ihr Internet auch so dermaßen dicht, dass du noch nicht mal solche Maßnahmen ergreifen kannst.
Ja, nicht nur Unis, auch Firmen und so was. Aber da kann man sich mal ein gutes Beispiel an Skype nehmen. Skype bohrt sich fast überall raus.
Das ist unglaublich.
Aber diese Geschichten, das heißt, bandbreitentechnisch war das durchaus zufriedenstellend mit dem LT da draußen. Aber es ist halt nicht vergleichbar mit dem DSL-Anschluss. Noch nicht. Auch da, denke ich, muss einfach die Konkurrenz kommen. Dass es technisch geht, sieht man. Wie gesagt, Skandinavien, man muss es ordentlich konfigurieren. Und wenn halt eben mehr Verbreitung dafür da ist und auch mehr Nutzer da sind, wird es auch mehr Leute geben, die da rummaulen. Ich meine, ich habe vorhin schon erzählt, es gibt jetzt das Gerücht, wie da mal in die Gerüchteküche kocht, weil Apple ja im März vielleicht mal wieder eine neue iPad vorstellt und jetzt aktueller Hype, dass das iPad 3 jetzt vielleicht einen LTE-Chip-Satz drin hat. Dann wird es natürlich spannend, weil dann kommen natürlich viel mehr Leute auch hier in den Städten hin und die natürlich dann auch hingehen und eine andere Dienstqualität verlangen. Wir sind Einzelfall. Da wird es wahrscheinlich mehrere Webseiten geben. Wir sind Einzelfall bei O2, wir sind Einzelfall bei Telekom, wir sind Einzelfall bei Vodafone. Ich weiß gar nicht, der E-Plus spielt gar nicht mit bei dem LTE-Spiel. Aber da, denke ich, wird sich noch ein bisschen was bewegen.
Ja, man bräuchte so ein Movement, so ein Verband der Einzelfälle.
Deutschland.TV.
Wo alle irgendwie so ihre modem Auto-Detekt-Analysen irgendwie hochladen können mit so und so viel Bandbreite, hätte ich haben können, und so viel wird mir gegeben. Dann kann man immer schön sehen, wie hoch der Gesamtbandbreitenanteil ist, der einfach vergeben wird.
Man müsste mal Sammelklage erheben. Eigentlich, rein rechtlich gesehen, wenn du einen Vertrag abschließt, da steht dann bis zu 16 Megabit. Und die sind technisch machbar, kann der Provider nicht einfach sagen, ich gebe dir bloß eins. Weil steht ja nur bis zu 16 Megabit. Da muss man schon darauf abstellen, wann möglich ist. Und sich dann auf den Standpunkt zu stellen, zu sagen, aber steht ja nur bis zu 16 Megabit. Das ist genauso, wenn ich sozusagen in den Supermarkt gehe und er sagt, hier, Kilo Fleisch, bis zum Kilo Fleisch, für 20 Euro und gehst dahin, kriegst eine halbe Bulette in die Hand gedrückt und er sagt, da, tschüss. Dann würde sich auch jeder darüber aufregen. Aber an dieser Stelle ist das... Da gehört, würde ich mal reingehauen.
Höchstgeschwindigkeit eines Autos. Man kann bis zu 160 kmh fahren.
Ja, aber fährt nur 50.
Pech gehabt.
Tut mir leid.
Dann würde sich jeder darüber aufregen.
Hat wohl die Straße nicht hergegeben.
Ich meine, es ist so, dass die wenigsten Leute... Ich habe wirklich so viele Leute überreicht. Es ist kein Witz. Ich habe in meinem Auto immer eine alte Fritz-Box rumzuliegen. Wenn sich irgendwelche Leute beschweren, dass sie Probleme haben aus dem privaten Umfeld, das kennt man ja schon. Du bist aus der Branche, du kennst das nicht mehr. Dann hänge ich mir erst mal die Kiste dran und messe das mal aus. Weil du glaubst, wie viele rote Gesichter ich da schon geguckt habe. Gerade der Extremfall auf Usedom, mit 18 Megabit gemessen und 1 Megabit rausgekommen. Die haben ganz schön abgekotzt.
Ich schwitze auch schon ein bisschen. Ich bin jetzt nicht ganz unzufrieden mit meiner Bandbreite. Aber wenn das Doppelte drin wäre, warum nicht? Ich würde trotzdem gerne noch mal auf diesen, müssen sie nicht Netzneutralität nennen, aber diesen Eingriff in die Netzbereitstellung. Ich meine, wir als Oldschool-Nerds, wir hätten es ganz gerne immer schön kaltmetallisch, direkt nackt, einfach zwei Lüsterklemmen da irgendwie ran. Und dann will man einfach das Netz so, wie es aufschlägt. Because we know how to deal with it. Anderen mag es nicht genau so gehen, aber in zunehmendem Maße jedes Mal, wenn irgendeiner einem in die Verbindungen geht, geht irgendwo was verloren und stirbt wahrscheinlich auch ein Robbenbaby. Was ist dir denn da so an solchen Verstößen? Ich meine, diesen DNS-Beispiel haben wir ja schon benannt. Was ist dir denn so bekannt, was so aktiv getan wird? Ich glaube, es war im Telekom, Mobilfunknetz, das teilweise dann auch ins HTML hineingegangen wird und irgendwie Webseiten verdichtet werden.
Das haben sie alle gemacht.
Was haben sie alle gemacht?
Es gab mal ein Produkt, ich glaube, das kam aus dem Ericsson-Umfeld. Das haben die verteilt wie dumm an die Netzbetreiber. Das stammt aus dieser Late-GPS-Early-UMTS-Phase. Das hieß Speed-Proxy. Das hat so eine Sache gemacht, das war so eine Art Zwangsproxy, was sich den Verkehr zu den mobilen Endgeräten angeguckt hat und beim Abruf einer HTML-Seite festgestellt hat, boah, ist da viel Whitespace drin. Aus einem HTML-Dokument kannst du alle verdoppelten Spaces rausschmeißen, Taps und so weiter und so fort, kannst du dir alles verdichten, kannst Text kürzer schreiben und länger und so und man kann auch JPEGs rekomprimieren, das heißt, du nimmst die, faltest die auseinander und machst die halt nochmal mit Kompressionslevel 50% oder so was, dann sind sie halt halb so groß wie vorher, haben natürlich den schlimmer Artefakt drin oder so, aber das hat das gemacht, dieses Ding. Und hat das halt eben zum Endgerät durchgeschickt und haben das dem Kunden verkauft wie, naja, das sparst du doch Bandbreite und dadurch bist du schneller. Ja, es ist schneller für dich. Das mag auch auf so einem alten Nokia-Handy-Display mit 50 mal 50 Pixel vielleicht auch lustig gewesen sein. Leute, die jetzt heutzutage ein iPhone mit Retina-Display haben, die mögen das nicht so, deswegen haben sie das auch wieder abgeschaltet. Aber so was gab es. Und das warf natürlich die Diskussion überhaupt auf, inwiefern darf eigentlich überhaupt so ein Vermittlungsdienst eigentlich in den Content eingreifen?
Ich meine, die haben auch teilweise die Software zerstört. Ich meine, da kamen zunehmend so JavaScripten und Web-Anwendungen, die einfach dann diese Proxy-Behandlung schlicht nicht überlebt haben. Und die Funktionalität war einfach kaputt.
Aber die Frage ist grundsätzlich, was geht die da an? Ich meine, ich zahle für den Treff. Ich hab einen scheiß Volumentarif. Und wenn da ein dicker JPEG kommt, dann ist es so. Ich möchte das gerne haben. Das ärgert mich übrigens bis heute, dass der Apple mich vor irgendwelchen Up-Downloads bewahrt, die größer als 20 Megabyte sind. Ich meine, hallo, ich zahle für meine 5G. Ich will die benutzen. Das geht euch gar nichts an. Was soll das? Das ist jetzt noch mal Netzneutralität auf dem Endgerät, was ich mir selber gekauft habe, was mir gehört, wo aber der Hersteller meint, mir vorschreiben zu müssen, wie groß mein Download maximal sein darf. Hallo?
Was aber auch nur ein Deal mit den Telcos ist. Weil bei Apple ist es egal.
Vermutlich nicht mal mit denen hier. Die haben sich dort ausgeknusfert mit den Knallchargen von AT&T damals. Und das haben sie erst drüben gelauncht. Und dann haben sie sozusagen, als sie hierhergegangen sind, haben sie gesagt, na guck mal, nehmen wir das mal hier als Rahmenvertrag. Und die deutschen Provider haben natürlich auch gesagt, naja, wenn er das im Markt schon durchgesetzt hat, nehmen wir das auch. Ist uns recht. Ich glaube nicht, dass das auf Anforderungen der Leute hier kam, sondern das haben die Apple Leute mitgebracht aus Amilante. Und die anderen haben es dankend angenommen hier in Europa. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, die Zeiten sind jetzt auch vorbei. Nochmal, ich zahle dafür. Ich zahle für mein Volumen, möchte das ausnutzen. Möchte gerne eine App mit 22 Megawatt oder auch mit 100 Megawatt laden.
Das ist eine ähnliche Geschichte an der Stelle, dass man irgendwie auch Verträge hat, wo man dann drin steht. Man darf das dann nicht mit seinem PC verbrauchen. Okay, da steht zwischen den einen Bits und den anderen Bits. Ich meine, was ist der Grund dafür?
Die wollen extra Geld dafür haben. Du kriegst ja überall Tethering gegen Aufpreis. Es gibt Netzsteuerungstechnisch oder so. Weil sie dir nochmal mehr Geld abgeben. Du hast halt deinen 5 GB Tarif bei O2. O2 macht das nicht, aber bei der Telekom, der traditionelle iPhone, nur von der Telekom. Ich weiß, aber die machen diese Tethering-Geschichten nicht. Die wollen dafür kein extra Geld haben. Die Telekom, ich weiß nicht, wie das jetzt ist, aber die Telekom will ja immer noch extra Geld haben für Tethering. Die sagen, wir können es steuern, wir können den Kunden an die Karren darlegen. Was wir können, das tun wir auch. Wenn wir noch mal 5 Euro extra im Monat kriegen, dann nehmen wir die mit Kusshand. Scheiß auf die schlechte Presse, die überleben wir. Wir haben so viel schlechte Presse. Das ist das Tolle daran, wenn du den ganzen Tag verkackst, dann regt sich auch keiner mehr darüber auf. Wir könnten alleine eine Sendung machen, die würde 2 Tage am Stück gehen, wenn ich die ganzen Anekdoten der letzten 25 Jahre erzähle, was ich mit der Telekom erlebt habe. Das machen wir. Ich habe gerade, jetzt noch mal durch, vor 2 Wochen habe ich mir erlaubt, auf dem ISTN-Anschluss, der schon ein paar Rufnummern drauf hatte, noch mal 2 zusätzliche Rufnummern zu beantragen. Was habe ich gekriegt? Die Sperre der Rufnummer-Übertragung. Ich so, hallo, Rilik Chinesischer, habt ihr denn angerufen? So geht es noch? Ja, wir haben jetzt hier 2 Rufnummern, aber die konnten wir nicht. Stattdessen habt ihr mir die Rufnummern-Übertragung rausgeknipst, oder was? Das ist abgrundtief. Es ist unglaublich, was die immer wieder gebacken kriegen. Die sind schmerzbefreit in vielen Stellen, wo sie keine Konkurrenz haben. Sie wissen auch, dass viele andere nicht besser sind. Als der Alice angefangen hat, und noch ein paar hundert Leute nur hatten in Hamburg, als Hansenett anfingen bundesweit zu werden, da waren die noch alle relativ pfiffig. Aber heute kannst du anrufen bei einer Hotline, wo du willst, der Durchschnitts-IQ liegt dort bei weit unter 70. Anders kann man sich das nicht erklären. Also Forrest Gump wäre irgendwie echt... Es ist wirklich so unglaublich. Dinge, da glaubst du gar nicht, was da alles drin ist. Aber das ist, wie gesagt, das machen wir in einer separaten Senderei.
Nochmal zu dieser Netzqualität. Also ich meine, diese expliziten Eingriffe in den unmittelbaren Datenstrom, wie DNS-Abfangen, diese Zwangsproxysierung etc. Die andere Frage ist natürlich auch dieses Portsperren. Das haben wir schon so in etwa angesprochen. Das gibt es halt so erstmal nur im Mobilnetz. Jetzt quasi bei LTE, was irgendwie auch Festnetzersatz sein soll.
Immer noch, weil dasselbe einfach stippt.
Das heißt, dein Festnetz ist gar nicht mehr so fest. Dann gibt es ja noch, aber jetzt sagen wir mal, bei so einem normalen richtigen DSL-Anschluss wird dir ja an sich nichts gesperrt, oder? Gibt es da auch schon?
Noch nicht. Naja, sie haben ein kleines Problem. IPv4-Adressraum ist das Endeelende schon einiger Zeit. Und wenn sie jetzt noch mehr Anschlüsse installieren und die nur alle im Flatrate-Betrieb sind, das heißt alle 24-7 an sind, haben die auch alle eine Adresse. Und irgendwann kommen sie jetzt darauf, dass sie nicht mehr jedem eine einzelne echte IP-Adresse geben können, eine öffentliche IP-Adresse, sondern dass sie halt eben anfangen müssen, private IP-Adressen zu benutzen, IPv4-Adressen, wenn sie halt nicht gleich umsteigen auf V6 mit den entsprechenden Migrationsstrategien. Und dann müssen sie dich natten. Und in dem Moment, wo Nat drin ist, hast du quasi sozusagen schon so eine Art Firewall drin. Quasi, das ist nicht wirklich eine Firewall, aber es ist schwer trotzdem die Erreichbarkeit von außen.
Ich meine, heute eigentlich standardmäßig, weil man kriegt ja auch nur eine IP-Adresse und wenn man zwei Rechner hat, steht man da halt schön.
Ja, da ist aber das Nat in deinem Bereich, das ist dein Router. Da kannst du halt eben mit VPN-Techniken oder wie auch immer kannst du da noch was basteln. Oder du teilst halt die Ports auf. Du sagst halt, der Port geht auf den Rechner, der auf den Rechner.
Ja gut, aber das ist halt knifflig.
Ja, ist klar. Aber das wird halt eben zunehmend schwieriger, wenn den sozusagen jetzt mal richtig die Puste ausgeht. Und wir sind ziemlich gut dabei.
Aber es gibt jetzt noch keine aktiven Portsperren, in dem Sinne, dass so bestimmte Dienste nicht mehr...
Hier bei uns habe ich es noch nicht gesehen. Was ich schon gesehen habe, in manchen Ländern, teilweise sogar in Schweden, ist, dass die Leute, das habe ich auch einzigartig gesehen, dass die Leute Port 25 sperren. Port 25 ist der SMTP-Port, der eigentlich dafür da ist, um Mailverkehr zwischen Servern zu machen. Der natürlich auch für manche Client-Server-Connection benutzt wird, immer noch sehr häufig. Wo es aber schon seit vielen Jahren ein Alternativport gibt, nämlich 587 für. Das ist sozusagen eigentlich der Port, den man benutzen sollte, um Mail bei seinem Provider einzuliefern, von deinem Laptop oder von deinem Mail-Client, was auch immer. Und Port 25 ist vom Prinzip in den ADSL-Netzen oder so etwas zu 102% mit Spam belegt.
Also wenn da Aktivität ist, dann ist das dein Aktivität?
Meistens ist das ein Trojaner, den du drauf hast, der dann anfängt Mail-Kreuzung quer dich die Gegend senden zu wollen. Deswegen ist das in vielen Netzen, bei Comcast in den USA so ein großer Kabelnetz-Provider, die haben das schon vor vielen, vielen Jahren, haben die den Port 25 schon abgedreht. Und das sehe ich jetzt hier auch zunehmend kommen. Das ist aber sozusagen das Einzige, was ich hier in letzter Zeit gesehen habe.
Das findest du jetzt auch nicht unbedingt verurteilenswürdig?
Es ist zwar ein Eingriff, aber ein Eingriff, der mich jetzt nicht wirklich in meinen Sachen behindert und den ich derzeit einsehe, solange wir diese Torianna-Problematik da haben. Weil es ist wirklich, da muss man halt eben, ist es wie immer, auch bei rechtlichen Sachen, du hast immer einen Anspruch hier, einen Anspruch dort. Und also, was ich im normalen Rechtssystem daraus, ein Persönlichkeitsrecht versus free speech. Ja, so ist einfach die Frage. Und hier ist es auch wieder die Frage, kann man auch sagen, will ich die freie Rede auf meinem Internetanschluss, inklusive Port 25, den brauch ich zwar nicht, aber ich will nicht, dass ihr mir den abbremst gegenüber, wir tun wirklich dem gesamten Netz was Gutes. Auch der Infrastruktur, in dem wir diesen Spam unterbinden. Da muss man das gegeneinander abwägen. Und an dieser Stelle würde ich wirklich sagen, das Port 25 ist okay. Insbesondere dann, wenn es ordentlich dokumentiert ist. Wenn ein Netzbetreiber sagt, aus guten Gründen, die er auch darlegt, hallo, wir machen das, wir sperren dir das und das, aus diesen guten Gründen. Und wenn es dich wirklich, wirklich stört, kannst du auch hier das wieder abwählen. Dann finde ich das vollkommen okay. Weil man dann nämlich hingeht und sagt, man macht wirklich netztechnische Maßnahmen oder netzregulatorische Maßnahmen, die der Technik dienen und nicht irgendwelchen politischen Belangen von irgendwelchen Vertriebs-Hinies. Und der Benutzer kann die auch opt-outen. Man macht die dann als opt-out, weil Autonormalbürger wissen nicht, was Port 25 ist. Der will halt nur surfen und YouPorn gucken. Aber die Leute, die interessiert, können das wieder abwählen. Sowas finde ich dann okay. Da finde ich es durchaus angemessen. Ansonsten habe ich hier noch nichts gesehen. Ich meine, es gibt jetzt immer wieder Themen, du hast ja schon mitgekriegt, dass vor ein paar Monaten hat die Telekom ja ein bisschen Shitstorm gehabt, weil halt eben YouTube, oft Telekom-Anschlüssen, eben nicht so der Brüller war. Weil die halt eben in relativ, relativ, naja, da ist dünne Striffe, die hatten schon ein paar hundert Megabit irgendwie da in den Bereich rein, wo YouTube sitzt. Ich weiß gar nicht, inwieweit die jetzt schon in dieser Google-Wolke verschwunden sind oder inwiefern die noch ihre eigene Infrastruktur betreiben, die YouTube-Leute. Aber da gab es halt einen Shitstorm und dann hat die Telekom noch mal ein bisschen nachgerostet in der Richtung. Aber das war jetzt nicht so, dass die sich jetzt künstlich runtergebremst haben, sondern die haben halt ihnen gesagt, oh wei, oh wei, wenn wir da jetzt noch eine Strippe ziehen, müssen wir nochmal 5 Euro in die Hand nehmen. Na gut. Das ist ja eine andere Maßnahme sozusagen. Fehlender Netzausbau ist ja was anderes als aktiv hinzugehen und irgendwo eine Bremse einzubauen.
Was ja auch gerade in den USA, auch so mit so Comcast und solchen Buden ein Thema ist, ist natürlich so BitTorrent. BitTorrent hat ja einen beträchtlichen Anteil des Gesamtreffigs. Die Schätzungen gehen da so bis zu 50 Prozent. Ich weiß nicht, was du da so für realistisch hältst.
Ja, das macht eine ganze Menge. Ich müsste mir mal so Statistiken angucken auf so üblichen Kisten. Das macht eine ganze Menge. Spam macht auch noch eine ganze Menge. Insgesamt für so ein Provider ist das Signal-Rausch-Verhältnis, also sozusagen Nutzdaten versus Müll oder Sachen, die man eigentlich nicht haben will, derzeit noch deutlich auf der Rauschseite. Das ärgert natürlich viele Netzbetreiber. Wobei natürlich für den Endanwender ist sein Torrent-Stream auch Nutzdaten. Nur die Gegenseite, der Provider bzw. die anderen, die Content-Besitzer oder so, haben da natürlich eine andere Meinung dazu. Deswegen ist es offiziell als Free Bay und dementsprechend als Rauschen deklariert.
Unabhängig von dieser Urheberrechtsdiskussion und dem Druck, den die Lobby da ausführt, ist natürlich auch so dieses Oh, BitTorrent nimmt uns jetzt hier die Bandbreite weg, weil das so ein effizientes Protokoll ist. Alle machen das die ganze Zeit. Dann gibt es diese Vermutung, dass das ja nur Filesharing ist, keine legitime Nutzung des Internets.
Die Frage ist, was das für Files sind.
Ja, sicher, klar. Wir wissen auch alle, der illegal, will ich jetzt gar nicht mal sagen, oder zumindest so Austausch anderer Leute, Dateien, ist sicherlich nicht gering, gar keine Frage. Trotzdem stellt sich natürlich die Frage, inwieweit es angemessen ist, jetzt für einen Provider zu sagen, naja, BitTorrent, das erzeugt jetzt hier so viel Last. Da kommt das gute, alte HTTP nicht mehr so vorbei. Dann drehen wir doch da so ein bisschen an der Stellschraube. Und die Technologie ist ja glaube ich mittlerweile vorhanden, um das zu machen. Also wenn man das möchte, dann sagt man, hier machen wir BitTorrent-Detection. Und dann fällt da halt mal ein Paket mehr weg. Oder ja, ist halt irgendwie langsamer. Das wird getan, oder? Ist das nur eine Diskussion? Ich weiß, dass es hier und da mal angefasst wurde.
Ich habe es hier in Europa noch nicht erwischt. Und andere Leute glaube ich auch nicht. Es gibt so ein paar Leute, die das gelegentlich mal versuchen zu messen. Ist ja auch sehr, sehr schwer, so etwas zu messen. Da brauchst du halt viele Endstationen dafür, die man verteilt, um wirklich zu gucken, was ist da, wenn du jetzt nur eine einzelne Verbindung von A nach B machst, die du durchmirst, wirst du das wahrscheinlich nicht messen. Es ist bekannt, dass es ein paar Leute, ein paar Provider in einem Land machen, Comcast namentlich, die sind ja sozusagen der Pfuibe, der Provider. Die probieren das alles immer mal aus. Die sind so shitstorm-resistent, dass sie sich sagen, wir leisten uns einfach mal so eine Sache. Nur die, die nun wirklich echt nicht mehr gehen, die ziehen sie dann wieder zurück. Aber das sind sozusagen die Forerunner an dieser Stelle, die immer mal ausprobieren, was kann ich mal benutzen, eigentlich alle zumuten, bevor ich zu viele Kunden verliere. Und da schauen sie natürlich alle drauf. Klar, die Telekoms dieser Welt schauen, oder die Provider dieser Welt schauen da alle drauf, weil eigentlich wollen sie das auch gerne machen. Vor allen Dingen, sie wollen noch was anderes machen. Denen geht es gar nicht darum, diesen Bit-Torrent-Betrieb wegzukriegen. Sie wollen noch mal ein extra Kohle bieten. Was sie sehen, ist, dass es ein Verhältnis zwischen Kunden und Content-Anbietern gibt, wo wahnsinnig Bits transportiert werden, wo auch Geld transportiert wird. Der Google verdient sich dumm und dämlich, selbst manchmal nur mit ihrem Suchzeug. Andere Leute verdienen, werden richtig Marketing gemacht, der Amazon oder so was, auch mit seinem Zeug, der vermietet seine Plattform, verdient damit Geld, verkauft darüber Waren, verdient damit Geld. Und Igama, kleiner DSL-Provider in Berlin, Friedrichshain, stehe da und kriege 1995 von meinem Kunden. Und nicht mehr, nicht weniger. Und dafür kackt er mir immer mehr die Leitung zu. Das finde ich blöd. Ich möchte jetzt als Provider dort gerne eben auch mit dran verdienen. Und was die halt eben gerne haben möchten, ist, dass sie dann halt eben sagen, die wollen gar nicht den Bit-Torrent runterdrehen. Was denen am besten gefallen würde, ist, dass der Bit-Torrent so zunimmt, dass der Amazon nicht mehr richtig funktioniert. Oder der eBay. Dass sich die Leute darüber beschweren. Dann würde nämlich dieser Provider hingehen und sagen, entweder zum Endkunden, wenn er nicht so viel torrenten würde, würde das auch gehen. Oder, schlimmer noch, er geht nur hin zum eBay und zum Amazon und sagt, bei mir ist so viel Rauschen im Netz, die Leute torrenten wie die Dummen, aber ich kann das ja nicht anfassen. Das verbindet ja ein nacktes ISDN. Und so kann ich das ja nicht unterdrücken oder wegmachen. Aber wenn du mir ein paar Euro geben würdest, ein paar Dollar, dann könnte ich dafür sorgen, dass deine Pakete ein bisschen bevorzugt durchs Netz rennen. Dann funktioniert doch deine Webseite wieder, lieber eBay. Das ist eigentlich der Punkt, wo die hinwollen. Da kann man jetzt auch eigentlich erstmal auf den ersten Blick, könnte man jetzt sagen, naja, wird es jetzt daran so schlimm? Das ist ja nicht mein Geld. Abgesehen davon, dass der der eBay, der Amazon irgendwann wieder draufschlagen wird. Aber das führt zu einer anderen politischen Diskussion, nämlich das sagen, okay, das Internet wird dann sozusagen nur noch nutzbar sein oder vernünftig nutzbar sein für Leute, die auch auf der Contentseite dafür bezahlen. Das wäre sozusagen dann eine deutliche Benachteiligung der Blogs, der, ja, wir sehen Internetrevolutionen in Nordafrika und so weiter und so fort. Alles basiert irgendwie auf solchen Geschichten. Oder deine Podcasts zum Beispiel. Ich weiß nicht, ob du hingehen willst in der Telekom, dafür Geld bezahlen willst, dass sie deine Päckchen präferiert in ihrem Netz transportieren. Das kannst du vielleicht auch gar nicht. Das kannst du vielleicht auch gar nicht leisten, das Geld, was sie dafür haben wollen würden. Das heißt, dadurch ist so ein bisschen...
Es könnte auch sein, dass sie mir überhaupt gar keine Beziehung anbieten, weil ich gar nicht groß genug bin.
Und das ist das politische Thema, deswegen ist es auch auf der politischen Agenda, es ist jetzt gar nicht so oft so eine wirtschaftspolitische Agenda, sondern dass die Leute sagen, es herrscht derzeit eine Demokratie im Internet. Jemand wie ein Tim Pritlove kann als ein Mann Aktionen, Radioprogramm machen und die auch verbreiten an viele tausend Leute. Das ist für unsere Demokratie ein wichtiger Faktor. Das könnte er nicht mehr, wenn sein Traffic nur noch unter ferner liefen, vielleicht mal gnadenhalber mit durchs Netz geschleift wird.
Weil gerade noch was frei ist.
Weil dann deine Dienstgüte dementsprechend abfällt, dass die Leute von deinem Dienst abspringen. Die gehen dann eben hin und kaufen Content, weil denen können sie zehnmal so schnell runterladen wie dein Podcast. Das ist der Punkt, deswegen interessiert es auch politische Parteien, auch jenseits des wirtschaftlichen Faktors, dass sie eben sagen, wir gefährden damit in gewisser Art und Weise die frisch erworbenen, frisch vor 10, 15 Jahren erworbenen Demokratie, weltweite Demokratie, die ja im Internet noch mehr oder weniger vorherrscht. Abzüglich von chinesischen Firewalls und so. Aber das ist der ganze Diskussionspunkt um diese Netzneutralität.
Was könnte die Lösung sein für diese Problematik?
Eine politische Vorgabe. Einfach das, wo wir vorhin schon mal waren.
Dass man politisch anerkennt, dass das Internet ein Ding ist, wo sich die Wirtschaft nach Gutdünken austoben darf. Sondern dass es eine Grundversorgung ist. Eine Grundversorgung wie Wasser, Strom, Gas, Lebensmittel. Diese Erkenntnis mit den daraus resultierenden Folgen. Dass man eben sagt, das darfst du nicht. Wenn dein eBay rummauelt, dass er so schlecht durchkommt, bohr deine Leitung auf. Das geht ja, Technik ist ja da, Leitung ist da. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man die Bits nicht noch hochschrauben könnte. Ja, dann geht auch der Bit-Torrent mit hoch, aber okay. Ja, das verhält sich linear. Das kann man machen. Und vor allem eben diese Neutralität, dass man eben einen Tim Pritlove mit seinem Podcast nicht schlechter behandelt als ein eBay. Zumindest aus Sicht des Endkunden. Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Es gibt ja auch ein paar Länder, an denen diese Netzneutralität jetzt auch schon gesetzlich beschlossen wurde. Fällt dir da ein Beispiel ein? Holland, glaube ich. Die Holländer haben das doch gemacht, oder? Muss man nachgucken.
Ich weiß es gerade nicht.
Ich muss noch mal gucken, wo die Schweden da stehen. Ich bin immer so ein bisschen unschlüssig. Ich mag eigentlich die schwedische Politik in vielen Dingen, was Netzsachen angeht. Auf der anderen Seite haben sie natürlich auch wieder mit der Abhörnummer dort. Diese Frage setzt dort, ist natürlich wieder so ein bisschen ein Fleck auf dem Bild. Aber normalerweise sind die dort relativ pfiffig, was sowas angeht. Die haben also sehr viel verstanden.
Niederlande schreiben Netzneutralität im Mobilfunk vor.
In den USA ist die Diskussion ja auch noch am Gehen. Der große Kampf ist noch nicht entschieden. Man guckt natürlich jetzt viele Leute, gerade auch was da passiert, von den USA lernen heißt Siegen lernen. Also werden sich natürlich viele Leute auch noch zurückhalten. Erstmal schauen, was da geht. Gerade auch so kleinere Länder, die können sich jetzt eh nicht, wenn sich jetzt Luxemburg auf die Hinterbeine stellt und sagt, wir wollen aber Netzneutralität, dann sagen die alle, ja aber, bei euch stehen doch eh keine Server. Kommt der Elend aus dem Ausland. Also ich denke, das sind schon die großen Wirtschaftsnationen wie eben.
Ah, interessantes Detail, was mir noch gar nicht klar war, in dem Kontext dieses Berichts hier über Netzneutralität in Holland. Der Auslöser war tatsächlich, dass jemand gepetzt hat, dass bei KPN, also dem großen ISP- und Mobilfunkbetreiber in Holland, sie festgestellt haben, dass diese Messaging-Anwendung WhatsApp, wie auf dem iPhone und mittlerweile auch auf vielen anderen Plattformen läuft, die ja aus einer SMS-Konkurrenz ist, erheblichen Traffic erzeugt hat. Und dass sie dann eben ihre Deep-Spec-Inspection, die eigentlich für Überwachung installiert wurde, zum Einsatz gebracht haben. Und das hat dann halt den entsprechenden Shitstorm losgetreten.
Das müsste man hier auch mal machen. Gerade die Mobilfunknetze in Deutschland sind ja wie vorhin schon erwähnt nicht transparent. Deswegen ist eben auch LTE kein Ersatz für einen DSL-Anschluss in dem Sinne. Es ist halt einfach nur rein funktional wie ein UMTS-Anschluss mit dickerer Bandbreite und einer Ortsbegrenzung. Also eine Ortsfestlegung, fertig, zack. Da muss ich noch ein bisschen was tun. Aber das liegt wie gesagt nicht an der Technik. Es ist nicht so, dass es da nicht ginge. Das ist übrigens das Allerbeste, wenn du dich denn bei irgendwelchen Providern beschwerst, egal über was oder so. Sie sind ja sehr schnell immer dabei, diese doofen Hotliner, von denen ich schon erwähnt habe, mit dem MaxIQ von 70 zu erklären. Das ginge ja so nicht anders. Das müsse so. Da wäre ich denn richtig wild, wenn sie jetzt einfach nur doof sind oder mal irgendwelche anderen Sachen verbocken.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es wirklich immer ein Mangel an Intelligenz ist. Wahrscheinlich gibt es gar kein Interesse daran, da sehr viel mehr Informationen zu kommunizieren.
Aber manchmal tun sie es. Da muss ich dann immer sagen, mit Dieter nur, wenn man keine Ahnung hat, einfach mal Fresse halten. Aber jetzt nicht hingehen und mir einen vom Pferd erzählen. Da wäre ich dann wirklich echt zum Bär. Ich bin immer noch relativ höflich. Ich weiß, dass der arme Hotliner an Ulm von der Telekom nichts dafür kann, dass seine Kollegen in Neubrandenburg was verkacken. Aber wenn er dann anfängt, mir einen vom Pferd zu erzählen, von wegen, das müsse so und das ist alles schon richtig so, und das ging ja gar nicht anders, technisch und so, und dann sag ich immer so, nee. Also das ist wirklich noch eine arschwörende Ergernis. Das sind dann noch eben noch die Kundenverarschungen. To add insult to injury. Ja, immer noch sozusagen mich noch für blöde verkaufen.
Ja Clemens, ich glaube das Kapitel können wir jetzt hier auch vorerst einmal Schluss machen. Der Podcast hat ohnehin jetzt hier schon Rekordlänge erreicht. Aber nee, wird hier nichts zusammengeschnitten. Hier bleibt alles ganz neutral erhalten. Podcast-Neutralität, ja alle Argumente.
Du sparst jetzt die Traditionsfrage, ob wir noch was vergessen haben.
Ja, ich weiß, dass wir noch hätten in viele Bereiche hineingehen können. Vielleicht machen wir das ja auch irgendwann noch mal. Aber ich denke, an der Stelle können wir es erst mal abschließen, weil der eigentliche Bereich, mal so einen Überblick zu geben, was eigentlich so Internet-Bereitstellungen mit dem Schwerpunkt Festnetze betrifft, ich denke, den haben wir jetzt auch erst mal ganz gut abgekaspert. Und die sich daraus ergebenden Fragen sind natürlich vielfältig.
Man kann sich auch noch bei Backbones unterhalten. Da gibt es auch sehr spannende Sachen. Also gerade internationale Backbones wären auch eine spannende Geschichte. Oder allein schon über Seekabel könnte man sich stundenlang unterhalten, was da so geht. Und High-End, die dranhängen und so. Das ist ja eine sehr lustige Sache.
Ja, hier wird dann mit den Füßen abgestimmt. Ihr seid hier als Hörer natürlich alle aufgefordert, da auch irgendwie eure Kommentare abzugeben. Bei uns im Blog. Oder aus welchem Wege auch immer. Twitter, keine Ahnung. Gibt ja alle möglichen. Die findet ihr auch auf der Webseite. CAE.fm ist das ja jetzt. Jetzt, wo das hier alles nur noch CAE heißt. Und an der Stelle?
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Schließen wir das mal ab. Und ich freue mich über das Zuhören und fürs Wieder-Wieder-Zuhören. Wenn die Netzneutralität greift und ihr den Podcast noch runtergeladen bekommt, das nimmst du mal.